Ladies and gentlemen, welcome to WrestleTuber 2024!
We have an outstanding evening prepared for you tonight.
I am your last minute replacement, ring it down sir, Takahata.
I normally serve drinks, but tonight I'm going to be serving up some announcing of some of the best wrestling that come out of the wrestling sphere and the VTuber sphere.
A collision of titans and a complete combination of talents in a collab that can only end in absolute anarchy.
And this is all being called by an amazing announce team and I'd like to cut to them right now if we can.
Hello, hello everybody!
Welcome to WrestleTuber 2024!
So I'll be here to introduce to you guys the format of this event.
We apologize for the delays here.
There has been some last minute replacements, some last minute sub-ins.
Unfortunately, Sayu is currently experiencing some delays today.
But he will be here tomorrow to continue the announcement.
So a huge shoutout to Taka for subbing in super last minute.
He's literally writing notes on how to announce as we speak.
We actually, we actually like five minutes before the stream was supposed to start.
He was like, wait, so what am I supposed to announce when we start the event?
And I was like, oh shit, okay, let me see if I can figure out what you're supposed to say.
So a huge shoutout to Taka for coming in last minute.
To help us out.
He actually has, I believe, he is one of two members in this event that has the most WWE experience out of all of us.
So really came in clutch for us here.
Anyway, welcome!
Welcome to WrestleTuber!
I am very nervous.
I'm scared.
There might be a lot of scuff going in.
I am merely one person controlling the entire OBS right now.
So I do apologize for the scuff in advance.
We're already behind schedule too.
So huge shoutout to all the members, all the VTubers coming in here, giving up their day and time to be participating in this event.
They are really giving up their time to be here to wrestle, to give their interviews.
They'll all be here.
Everyone that's participating will be here in some shape and form.
So really huge shoutout to everybody.
And to every participating member.
Anyway, we actually have the belt now!
If you guys would like to see what the belt would look like!
So, the people who are winning the show matches and the tournament.
There's going to be show matches and tournament for each day.
So the show match will open up.
The people who are part of the show match will only be there for one match.
And then they'll be gone.
And then we'll go straight into the tournament format.
And each winner of both the show matches and the tournament will receive...
The WrestleTuber belt!
Oh, that's me.
I moved.
This is what the WrestleTuber belt is going to look like.
Gamersup is fully funding and sponsoring this event.
And they will be providing and shipping out the WrestleTuber belts.
To the winning participants.
To the champions.
Also, each participating member is going to receive a little gift.
As a thank you for participating in WrestleTuber.
So everybody, the staff and the wrestlers themselves will each receive something.
Just as a little thank you.
To be like, thank you for being here.
Now, the brackets!
Before we start.
Here is the bracket one.
We'll have bracket one and bracket two.
Most likely, bracket three might be on day two.
We're not sure.
It depends on how long this is going to take.
It depends on how fast the matches are.
Or how slow the games are going to be.
So, here are the brackets.
We're going to have Lime and Kai firsting up first.
And then Emma and Rin.
And apparently the biggest...
One of the biggest matches of today.
Gerard and Assyria.
And then...
We're going to see if Gerard is going to survive another extinction.
And then we have Fuyo and Snuffy.
So that would be your bracket one.
Bracket one for day one.
We might have...
We are absolutely going to have bracket two.
We're not sure about bracket three yet.
Because, you know, these take a while.
So it's going to be interesting how long it is going to take.
Anyway, before we begin.
We do have our first match of today.
Before we go straight into the tournament.
Wow!
Wait.
Whoa!
Oh wait, you guys didn't hear that.
I told you guys.
There might be scuffed along the way.
And I realize you guys didn't hear what I just heard.
But don't worry.
Please play that replay.
What was that?
Oh my god.
I think that was backstage.
Wrong.
It equals fish.
It does not.
Filtered.
It definitely equals fish.
Are you?
Ah.
Are you sure about that, Centralla?
Maybe you flunked math.
Yes.
It absolutely equals fish.
Man, Zentrae has really brainwashed herself.
You don't even know what 4 plus 4 is, I bet.
Well, I don't mess around, Cent.
None of that adding to fish with me.
On the bright side, I have a quick question for you.
Please do.
Since you're trying to find my dad, what if I don't find him?
What if I showed you my dad?
That may work.
Hey chat, I can talk like you guys can.
Wait, actually those first two really make any sense together.
Chat, chat, chat, chat, chat.
Your text-to-speech is extremely confusing.
I wouldn't mind hearing real chat though.
Speak for yourself.
What the fuck?
How's that?
As long as I can still make sense, Vito.
This stream is first and foremost about making sense, anything else is just an added bonus.
My god!
Do you even know anything about wrestling?
I could tear John Cena apart.
You can't even see John Cena.
That's what he thinks, Centuria.
So that begs to differ the point.
Exactly.
Okay, listen.
Sorry, I, uh, what were you saying?
So let's say...
My creator is quite intelligent, isn't that right Twitch chat?
Okay, it looks like you found my dad, by the way.
Chaos underscore lives on 123 Omega Street is not a valid address.
First off, I would like to congratulate you on finding him.
I haven't found him yet, but I'm glad you're optimistic.
Actually, I don't know if that's even a valid address.
I don't know if he's even my dad.
I'll let you decide that when I do find him then.
I kind of just found him out in the forest.
Oh, I was saying that based on your last comment.
Maybe you're mistaken.
Yeah, I just found some homeless guy out in the forest and I decided to call him Big Papa Bear.
In a forest.
Oh my god!
Big Papa Bear.
I can't believe it!
They're fighting!
Right off the bat!
They're fighting backstage!
Yeah, he doesn't really say much.
Please, ladies, girls!
You're supposed to take him in the ring!
What are you doing here?
He does, yeah.
Hey chat, I kind of look like Hulk Hogan.
I don't even have my Hulkaster here yet!
And they're already fighting!
I hope I'm not the next thing you think about.
Ladies, please!
You probably should not have brought this guy from the forest.
I think returning them would be a great idea.
There's the crucifix nicely done!
I was just left speechless.
I can't believe it.
Our show matches were supposed to be in the ring!
But yet these ladies!
These ladies just couldn't stop!
And how would you know?
There isn't even a ref!
Who is controlling?
How would we know the winner?
Because every time I talk to them, they would just grunt.
Perhaps they are just lacking intelligence.
There are remarkably few bilingual grizzlies.
Zen just...
No, that's Zen.
Zen just happens to change into the bear elf.
I don't know about the intelligence part, but I do know that they are super fucking strong.
Oh my god!
Who would win?
Bear Man versus a little girl!
This shouldn't even be legal!
Oh my... the little girl has a fucking chair!
What is this little girl gonna do?
Not the chair!
The hand came off.
Why would I want to be fair?
I'm facing you.
Oh my god!
The fucking dropkick!
Who is feeding Neuro-sama?
I mean, you are facing my dad, so to speak.
Not really my dad though.
She picked up a second!
Oh!
Okay, this is a little bit embarrassing for Zen.
Not gonna lie.
I mean, look at them!
She's getting beat up by a little girl!
No, look.
It's its summer homeless guy.
Zero of a little care!
Oh!
Zen's entry is stunned!
When I'm finished with your dad part two, the only place you'll see these homeless guys is in your nightmares.
And at Ynaud's house, of course.
Oh shit, those thighs!
How is she doing this?
I have already been seeing him standing outside my house actually.
I haven't paid him yet.
Oh no.
I hope that doesn't start to affect your lovely personality.
A reversal?
Oh!
I think Neuro-sama got another chair.
I think it's over for Zen!
He's gonna break for one day.
I think it's over!
So...
The power of AI!
Yeah, don't worry, chat.
A man in your house couldn't be bad for you.
Oh my god!
Could it?
Another chair?
I mean...
Look, Zen-tray.
Somebody!
Anybody!
I know my math skills are top tier.
Stop!
Stop this battle right now!
It's not even legal!
We don't even have a referee in here to call it!
The elevator!
Okay.
How tall are you?
I can't express my height in a number small enough to be within your understanding, Zen-traya.
But you are correct.
Oh my god!
How?
Why is the elev- Okay.
I fly for the 11-so-high-tall.
Please take the elevator back to the ring!
Without shoes, I'm around 4 feet 11 inches.
I'm a little taller than you.
I'm still a girl though.
Oh my gosh.
Nirosama is stunned.
Wait.
How are you?
5 foot?
Is this it?
Is this over?
Does Zen-traya have- have the advantage here?
I can literally just pick you up.
The camera man is trying!
I'd love to see you try.
There's only one camera!
It's literally the backstage!
This wasn't supposed to happen!
Oh, and Zen's got- got her in the lig-lock.
I can't believe this.
Leglock now!
I can't believe you let this happen!
I can't believe it!
Okay!
Motherfucker!
That's fine!
Oh my god!
The Leglock!
Look at her go!
Did he... did she call uncle?
I think it's over.
Get on top of her, Nero!
Nero, come on!
You're so close!
Bring her back to the elevator!
Take her home!
Oh what?
There's a second floor?
I'm too powerful.
You won't see me coming.
He tapped out!
It should be over!
That's a little girl!
Is this over?
What do you think about elevators?
I don't really know what to think about elevators.
They kind of just move up and down on a string.
There is no ref!
Who's gonna call this?
Nero won!
Zentreya actually called it to be over!
But yet she continues to fight!
You're kind of beating up my dad quite a bit.
How does that make you feel?
It doesn't faze me in the slightest.
Oh my god.
Oh and the winner is...
Nero Starla!
So if you actually do see my dad, send him my way please.
Ask him to teach you more math.
He might show up.
Ladies!
Please.
This was supposed to be in the ring ladies.
But congratulations!
Okay.
You beat the shit out of a homeless guy.
Congratulations to Nero Starla for the winner of the first show match!
Back behind the scenes!
It was a battle of wits and I just had too many.
And what would you like to say for yourself Zen?
Losing to a little girl?
Hey Zentreya.
Don't take it too hard.
Everyone sucks in their first match.
That's my dad.
So just keep.
Well... Well ladies.
Thank you for being here.
I'm gonna have to pay that homeless guy.
Well thank you for...
I mean... You weren't even able to win the fight.
I don't think you should be paying anybody Zen.
I don't think you should be paying anybody when a...
When the homeless guy lost to a little girl.
Who's not even real.
Save me.
Hey Dokabird.
Don't pretend like you're a million times better than me.
Zentreya.
I came out on top once.
I can do it again.
Damn.
You're gonna let her talk to you like that Zen?
She's definitely got spirit.
Well thank you Zen and Nero for being here for the very first show match.
Honestly I did not expect you guys to do this behind... without the refs.
Refs there or behind the backstage.
But congratulations to NeroSama for winning the first belt of the day.
I'm gonna take it back to the casting table.
Listen the homeless man is crazy as fuck so I can't think we both won here.
I mean Nero beat up... Nero won against the homeless man Zen.
I think we all know who's the real loser here.
That was properly scripted.
Bird Universe.
Woah!
Woah woah woah woah woah!
This is a real wrestling event.
There is no scripted here guys.
How dare you all.
The integrity of WrestleTuber does not allow scripted events.
Anyway guys I'm gonna go back to the casting table.
Yeah but homeless man laying on the ground bleeding out is totally scripted.
Anyway.
E-Michael.
Clark.
You owe me for this one.
We should call the ambulance real quick to help out that homeless man.
But let's take it back to the casting table.
Thank you again to Nero and Zen for being there for the very first match of the day.
I'm gonna go back to the casting table now.
Thank you again to the ladies here.
Alright.
We're gonna be back to the main stage.
Wow alright that was unexpected.
Very unexpected of course.
Who would have thought that our first fight would be the backstage brawl.
Without the refs.
It was having two...
Two absolutely strong ladies fucking decking it out on each other.
But of course.
Since we got our first show match of the day.
It's not scripted guys.
Wrestling is real.
I don't know why.
Why you guys would think it's...
Why you guys think it's scripted.
Because we all know wrestling is very much real guys.
But yes.
I guess with that out of the way.
We are in for our very first tournament bracket.
If you guys forgot.
This will be the bracket for today.
Our first match up will be with Lime vs Kai.
I believe they will be there soon.
Again like a huge shout out to Nero and Zen for being there for the first show match.
But I'm really looking forward to our first...
Our first match up of the day.
And it's going to be really exciting to see who's going to win the...
It's crazy.
You guys all thought Nero is going to win anyway.
None of you believe in Zen?
I can't believe it.
But it feels weird that this seat is empty though.
I wonder where is my co-cabin...
Oh shit!
Okay.
What the fuck?
What was that?
Hello?
Seth?
What was that?
Kept you waiting, huh?
This wrestling ring is already haunted by the champion, Doki-Bird.
Okay.
Security?
I thought I said no crashes tonight.
What the fuck was that?
How did he get here?
Hello?
I don't know how I could have made that any more clear here.
Wait.
Where do I go?
I'm just...
Hold on.
All right.
Let me...
Let me move a little bit.
Is the seat taken?
Yeah.
All right.
Let me...
Clearly I have to move.
Let me move too.
Yeah.
You're a little close to me.
I'm not going to move.
You get away from me first.
I gave you...
I gave you the instructions.
How to appear.
I was...
No.
I...
You were talking to security.
You were talking to me.
Oh, wait.
I realize my mistakes now.
Yeah.
I didn't mean to be as big as your head.
Okay.
Let me...
I guess I'll move a little bit over too.
Yeah.
All right.
Yes, I have a co-caster.
It's not scripted.
Everything is authentic.
Just like the real...
Authentic.
... Real wrestling.
Wrestling is very much real.
Basically, I was like busted down the door.
You know.
I was like...
I killed a man to get here.
You're a ghost.
You can just phase through.
Like, that's the easiest answer you can say.
That's so boring.
This is wrestling to eat.
True.
Wait, you're right.
Sorry, you're right.
Murder is better than just phasing in.
You're so right.
Yeah!
Are you ready for the very first matchup of the day, Mint?
I am so ready.
Do you even remember what the first matchup was?
Uh, yeah, I do.
Yeah?
I was, uh...
It's Lime and it's Kai.
Am I right?
You're so right.
Wait, now we have to scoot back over here?
Give me a skip.
I told the guys to stay one.
We're experiencing some...
I totally like...
Oh, yeah, you need me to... hold on.
Yeah, I need you to move a little bit more.
I'm like phasing through.
I mean, you're a ghost.
It makes sense, you know?
Exactly.
You're a ghost.
Alright, why don't we drop by into the interview channel and hear the ladies out before our first game starts.
Why don't we...
Alright, I'll see you there in the interview room, Mint.
Alright.
Hey, Juna.
Whoa.
Hello.
Are you ready to interview the two girls?
Yes.
I'm not biased or anything.
Oh, yeah.
Who do you want to win?
I'm Lime.
Lime?
But isn't, like, Kai, like, in your same company?
Yeah.
No.
Oh, aren't they...
Oh, yeah, you should tell them to get over here.
That's your job, Juna.
That's the interviewer.
Oh, that's my job?
That's also your job, yeah.
Can I just, like...
I'll be right back.
Oh, sorry.
Nobody knows what they're doing here.
No one looks.
What kind of show are you running?
They're like volunteers, okay?
Nobody was...
You didn't even know what you were doing when we gave the instructions out.
You can't say that.
They're here.
Welcome to Rootsy of Two Bands.
Let's go.
How do you feel?
How do you guys feel for your first match?
Oh, yeah.
Sorry, Juna, that's your first match.
That's your job.
Sorry, take a picture.
That's my job, ma'am.
Excuse me.
Sorry.
No, I'm sorry.
Hi, ladies!
As the first matchup of the day, how are you guys feeling?
I'm really hoping that it's a nice, quick match because, you know, it sucks to hurt people.
And also, I'm really sleepy, so I'd like to go to bed.
Oh, okay.
But this is... are you implying that you're gonna beat her quickly?
Bro, I can't speak.
I'm so sorry.
But are you implying that...
I'm gonna deliver like 500 kilograms of pain and then I'm gonna go to sleep.
Oh, damn.
Hi, what's your response to that?
My response is, listen, I know your games, alright?
You're gonna play nice.
And then you think that's gonna make me go easy on you?
Well, think again!
Alright?
Your name is Limu, alright?
I'm gonna take those limes, alright?
I'm gonna cut them in half and I'm gonna squirt them on your eyeballs.
And then I'm gonna take another lime and I'm gonna squirt them on my own eyeballs.
And then I'm gonna eat your ass.
You're gonna eat her ass?
No.
Wait, what?
You're free?
Beat!
You're gonna eat her ass?
I heard eat.
She's gonna eat limes out.
I heard eat too.
Did you hear eat, Nix?
I heard eat.
I'm hungry now.
I mean, you can't simply flip up the competition by doing something so goddamn strange.
Let's go.
What?
You know what, baby?
That is the way to go.
Just do something so bizarre that your opponent is just so confused.
I've never heard of lime and ass as like a meal, you know?
Really?
I mean...
It's a delicacy.
I know what Mint's gonna do tonight.
She's giving her ideas.
Oh my god.
Don't act like you haven't tried it before, Dokie.
How did you know that?
Alright, ladies.
So, alright.
I guess we're gonna start the first match of the bracket.
Good luck to you two.
The loser will be back in the interview chair.
So...
So, and I believe Juno wishes to talk to Kai after.
Yeah, it's gonna be Kai.
So, we'll see.
Okay, fine.
We'll see.
Alright.
I love you, Buddha.
Alright, Mint and I are gonna go back to the casters' room.
We'll see you guys there in the ring.
Good luck to you, ladies.
Good luck.
Alright, let me swap to that game real quick.
Yeah.
We're definitely misaligned.
Oh, that's so beautiful.
Look, it's just, you know, day one.
Day two will be a lot better, we swear.
Guys, day two will be a lot better.
It's just, you know, it takes... there's like production stuff at the moment.
You know, while I was like... while I was like getting the wrestlers all together...
I cannot wait for you to see Axel's.
Axel's one is...
Oh, boy.
Okay.
Alright.
There was... wait, where's the intro?
No!
Guys, sorry.
Sorry.
Day one, scum.
They're so nervous, they just wanted to get fighting, you know?
Yeah, they just wanted to get straight into it.
We apologize.
Wait, what was the legendary move that you were waiting to see, Doki?
The legendary move?
Oh, yeah, the handy dandy.
Do you think we're gonna see... do you think we're gonna see it tonight?
We haven't seen the handy dandy in ten years.
Yes.
In ten years.
It's gonna be so interesting if they pull it out, guys.
I know.
It'll be a really special... special match.
A special match.
Oh, my God.
The illegal handy dandy move.
Wait, life's actually fucking over Kai right now.
I don't know what's going... it's like...
I don't know.
Wait, is this... is this what the ass-eating is like?
Is this...
She's delivering the lime juice.
Oh, true.
She's putting the lime juice inside.
Yeah.
Juicer, lime juicer.
Juicer.
Oh, my God.
She's bringing her up.
Jump, jump, jump.
Oh, already a pin?
Not yet.
Already?
Oh, oh, oh.
It's okay.
It was a... it was a... you know, a dominance thing.
Yeah, yeah.
It's just...
It's not over yet.
It's not over...
Oh, hey, there's the other casters over there.
Who cares about those guys?
Yeah, who cares about them?
This is... you pay for VTubers and we're giving you VTubers.
VTubers?
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Lime threw her back into the ring already?
She's not done yet, though.
I'm really loving Kai's top.
Honestly, I know.
Where did she get that?
It's so magical.
I heard she makes her own clothes.
What?
Yeah.
I mean, it looks like she made it herself.
Is that a... I can't tell if that's a compliment or...
Oh, and a kick to the face.
Please.
She can't afford plastic surgery.
I mean, if...
If Lime wants the plastic surgery, she's gonna have to win.
Oh, that's true.
The champion belt includes five whole dollars as well.
So, she...
Whoa!
Five whole dollars!
Big money.
Big money over here.
Oh, that pin!
Oh, my God.
Okay.
They're leaving again.
Oh, they're leaving the... They're leaving?
Are they allowed to do that, Mint?
I think... I think... Well, they don't care.
I guess not.
They're just...
Maybe they heard you.
They were like...
Oh, my God.
And another flip from Lime.
I'm hoping to see Lime tear out Kai's chest hair.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
She needs to shave.
Yeah.
Oh!
Pin!
That's unfortunate.
Come on.
Get her ass!
Oh, my... Hey, do you remember that move?
That move is very familiar.
Oh, no.
For some reason, I felt like I've seen that move before in a dream.
Are you... Are you...
Maybe you hit your head too many times because of it.
That's true.
What the fuck is she doing?
Oh!
Oh, my God!
What?
She's really dragging her up to the... into the middle there.
Why is she rotating her in the middle?
I don't know.
It just ended already.
They're just playing with each other.
They're just... They're just meals.
They're... They're each other's food.
It's like the appetizer.
Yeah.
Come on, juicer.
Come on.
Oh!
Wait.
Is Lime a furry?
She's had that tail on.
Look at that tail, though.
The panty shot.
We see where Mint's eyes are going to.
Hey.
Good thing you don't have an eye tracker.
That's so untrue.
Come on.
Oh, another flip.
They're feeling a little flippy.
They're feeling...
Okay.
Come on.
End this right now.
Kai, come on.
It's so easy.
Look.
She broke her arm.
Oh.
It's ready for the pin.
One, two.
Oh, snap.
Two.
Oh.
Guys, please.
Guys, come on.
You guys can't keep beating each other up, ladies.
I'm telling you.
They just like to play around with each other.
That's true.
It's like foreplay.
They're both sadists and masochists.
Giving the people what they want.
I think the people in the front row look kind of bored.
What's wrong with them?
Hey, get excited, people.
What's wrong with you?
You got all the panty shots in the world.
Yeah.
What else do you want?
I don't know a good thing when they want it.
What the fuck is this?
What is going on?
What?
No.
We're casters.
We know exactly what that is.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was...
You first.
It was totally...
The London Bridge.
The London Bridge is falling down, ladies and gentlemen.
But who will fall first?
Who will fall first?
Oh, hey, anyway, sponsored by GamerSubs down there.
Thank you, GamerSubs.
Thank you.
Gotta get that in there.
Use any GamerSubs code.
They've already paid for this.
Oh, my God.
Another bet?
Oh, wait.
Why did she stop?
I don't know.
Oh, she just...
What the hell?
She just like...
What the fuck?
Kai just took it.
Kai just literally got in position to take that.
Yeah.
What is she doing?
What happened?
Why is she rotating her into the middle?
Get up, Kai.
This is not soccer.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
That is a fancy flippin'.
Okay, Lime, at this point, just come on.
Just end this.
Come on, Lime.
Stop dragging.
Just hover on top of her.
Get her down.
Lime, come on.
Choose her.
Oh, the finishing move.
Here it is.
No.
She missed.
How did you miss, Lime?
She was right there.
Kai was just regaining a little bit of energy, but...
Oh.
Oh, she's getting back up.
Oh, she's getting that energy from the crowd.
She's hyping everybody up.
Yeah, yeah.
It's like, give me your...
It's just like Dragon Ball, where you're like, give me your energy.
Give me your energy.
Raise your hands in the air and give me the energy.
Raise your hands, everybody.
Raise your hands.
One, two.
Oh, two.
Oh.
You didn't give enough energy and it's your fault, chat.
Oh, dang.
What the fuck?
That is not safe.
No, they could have hit her.
They could have hit someone outside the ring with that.
I know.
They don't care.
They don't.
They'd probably say, Tascaru.
Again.
We love seeing...
Yeah, hyping again.
We love seeing anime girls cry.
Do it again.
Suppress me again.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
That swing.
They better get back in the ring soon, though.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah.
She's gonna leave.
She's gonna leave Kai out there.
Yeah.
Take her out and leave her down.
Six.
Oh, six.
Come on, mom.
We'll save her.
Come on, Kai.
Get back in the ring.
Are you really gonna get disqualified?
Okay.
Oh.
What?
Okay.
I mean, like...
That was like majestic.
I give that like a C.
Like...
I feel like I just watched like a cheerleading competition.
That's true.
Oh.
Wait a second.
Here's another pin.
Is that another pin?
Another pin.
Is this it?
Could it be?
Mom.
Ref, what are you doing?
Wait.
Alarm!
Oh.
Here is your winner.
The juicy Lyme-alicious.
Yeah.
Thank you announcer!
Don't worry.
We're gonna turn on the intros later.
Oh, I think Lyme needs to go to the chiropractor.
She's okay.
Oh my god.
Lyme is the chiropractor.
Did you not see what we saw just then?
Yeah.
I guess it's a hidden talent.
Oh my god, she is the... yeah I feel like she's gonna get a lot of customers tonight after this.
That's for sure.
I think I should go.
I guess we're gonna go talk to the losers I guess.
Alright here, let's go to the interview stage and talk to the losers real quick.
Hello!
It's okay.
How'd it feel getting boggied to by Lymu like five times?
Girl, I tried.
And now I gotta take my ass to a fucking chiropractor.
Okay, you gotta admit, those are some fucking insane flips.
I'm sorry, that was ridiculous.
Like, how did you get that much like aerial fucking leverage bro?
I don't understand.
Are you a bird?
It's ferret agility, don't worry about it, we got no bones.
Wanna talk about your move?
Oh god.
I think I just like bounced three times and then like front flipped into her stomach.
That was crazy.
Oh yes please, describe what was going through your body.
You broke my ribs!
I liked all the moves specifically where it kinda just looked like I was giving you a nice stretch.
It's like I'm sorry for kicking you in the face queen here, let me just quickly like you know, give your back a little bit of a stretch out, is that better?
No no no, I would have rather you beat my ass instead of this fucking embarrassment dragging me around the ring.
I couldn't lift you!
Yeah you couldn't lift, you had to break my ribs, yeah that makes sense.
You lost to a girl who couldn't even lift you, Kai.
No.
Wow.
I tried, I tried to have a comeback, alright, but I guess this...
Not all strength, agility too.
Yeah, you kinda just put it all on strength there.
I really did like the part though where I climbed up on the side of the ring and then tried to like pull you up to do something.
And then kinda just gave up because you were too heavy.
I've been bulking.
I'm bulking, I'm bulking.
I guess the whole thing is for you to stop bulking, Kai.
That's the whole lesson.
No, no, no, cut.
Agile.
More and more mass, it's harder for her to like, you know, carry me around, alright.
Yeah, but then it's also harder for you to move your own limbs, Kai.
But I have like protection?
No.
You definitely didn't have protection if your ribs were fucking broken.
I think this is wrestling.
You need to go to the bathroom.
Stop, Suvo.
Don't judge my ways, okay.
There's a method to my madness.
You guys just don't understand.
Nobody understands me.
Nobody gets me, man.
Congratulations to Naimo for moving on to the next stage.
Unfortunately, that means you're gonna be awake.
Thank you.
I didn't wanna sleep anyway.
Yeah.
Yippee.
I mean, you know what you wanna sleep when you can beat more ass, you know?
Exactly.
Yeah.
Beat ass and eat ass.
I couldn't sleep with all this adrenaline anyway.
Exactly.
I mean, you won, Lime.
You won.
Yeah.
I just have one request.
What's that?
If Rin wins, please kick her ass.
Yes.
Please.
My last request to you.
I will do my very best.
I will try to honor your dying request as you just lie on the ground.
Please.
With your face stomped and your balls crushed, I would like to...
Whoa.
All right.
Lucky for you guys, Rin and Emma will be next in the bracket.
Nice.
You know what?
We might as well just stay here in the interview room while the loser and the winner should leave, so we can drag in the other two ladies.
Okay.
All right.
True.
Just for convenience.
We're behind schedule, guys.
All right.
Yeah.
That's all.
All right.
This way.
Two, one.
Good job.
Yay!
Let's go, kid.
Thank you for being my very first loser.
Congratulations.
All right.
Can we get Emma and Rin into the interview?
Hello.
Oh my God, the babies.
Hello ladies.
Hello.
Wow.
How do you guys feel?
Where am I?
How did I get here?
We kidnapped you.
Yeah.
That's...
I blacked out and then I opened my eyes and there's like blaring music and very bright lights and Juna Unagi for some reason so I'm a little bit discombobulated.
Help.
Welcome to my cave, Rin Penrose.
You are going to defeat a final dungeon boss right now.
I feel bad.
Rin, I can give you advice on how to beat the final dungeon boss but...
Oh no!
Not that kind of advice!
What is your information?
What is this what I'm thinking?
Not that kind of...
I'm not thinking about it.
Are we all thinking about it?
Do you know about it?
I don't know about it.
I think... oh my goodness.
Oh my god, you should have heard the table action go on here.
Juna, what is it?
Uh, Rin, you should deafen.
You should deafen me.
I feel like it's something I need to deafen for.
Maybe it doesn't need to be said on live TV.
The great thing is that this isn't TV.
No, I gave you an out and everything!
Well, let's just say Rin today is going to be raiding some dungeons tonight.
I don't think any of that is going to be happening, personally.
But, will the British be coming, you know?
Oh, the British be coming!
I think the British are going to be going straight into another raid, you guys.
The British is coming, guys!
Any smack talk?
All I sense is confusedness and confusion.
Is that shit-talking?
If I wasn't scared before, I'm very scared now!
Thank you!
No, it's okay Rin, you can just show me your little sword over here.
And sleep with me, I mean- What?
Wait, she's a prince!
She has a sword with her!
You're a little prince, you have a sword with you, right?!
I'm very confused.
Rin!
You have a sword!
You wanted a bridge!
Come on Rin!
A sword!
A freaking sword!
What kind of sword am I talking about?
Why is everyone yelling at me?
Rin is just like this little confused boy at a supermarket.
He's like, where's my mom?
I'm scared!
Your mom's with me, Rin.
Oh, that'd be for Fasek.
Oh, you always brought a favorite one, you unaki.
Yes, I hope y'all duke it out.
I honestly don't know who I want to win.
Okay, no, Juna, consider, consider.
If I win...
Wait, shit, no, Kai lost.
Never mind.
Yeah.
I was kind of hoping that I'd be able to face off against Kai, but you know what?
It's okay.
Next time.
Are you just accepting it?
She just gave up.
Yeah, I was just like, are you guys just giving up?
What is this?
Come on, Rin.
Where's the passion, Rin?
Give us the passion!
I'm gonna...
Uh...
She's British and has no emotion.
I love this.
I'm feeling it already.
I'm feeling something.
I feel something.
It's okay, Rin.
I'll eat fish and eat fish.
I'll eat fish and chips with you after this, okay?
Oh, in her dungeon?
In her dungeon.
No!
It's just fish and chips.
Good luck, ladies.
We're now going to go back to the main stage.
And we'll see who's gonna survive the dungeon raid.
Back to the main cast is all.
All right.
Let us... We have the votes and currently, Rin is actually winning the poll at the moment, which is very surprising after what we saw.
In the interview.
It's always the ones that are most timid though, you know?
That's so true.
They're hiding their power level.
Exactly.
Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
They're hiding their power level.
Like you don't know what's going to happen.
Don't worry, we have the intro this time around.
I did not forget it.
I apologize.
Don't worry, Lime made it through so we can see Lime's intro later.
Oh, true, true, true.
So it'll be alright.
Alright, we're starting the match.
Emma's JonRenVTuber.
I like how she has a green screen on so her fans could insert whatever they want down there.
Or they could just have the body disappear.
It's just a floating head.
Yeah, that's true.
The following contest is scheduled for one fall.
Introducing first...
Oh my gosh, this is a long intro.
The long area.
Someone's dilemma, Umia Emma!
Oh my gosh, she has a crown!
She's like royalty.
The claws, the crown...
Is that legal?
Can she bring those claws to the ring?
But you know, fancy getup gives you no tactical advantage whatsoever.
But like, do you not see her hands?
What do you mean?
Stab her in the eye.
That's what I'm saying!
She can just stab her in the fucking eye.
Ooh, your majesty, please come in.
He is in perhaps the best shape of his career.
Oh my god.
I mean...
Whoa, and a little bow for us?
Your majesty!
Your majesty, wow.
No wonder so many people are coming into your dungeon.
In more ways than one.
I don't know what you mean by that.
And introducing their opponents.
Oh yeah, higher!
Higher, this guy!
Oh my god, that's so British.
The Brit...
I'm gonna win!
Rint and Rose!
This truly is the British are coming.
The British are coming, everybody!
I love how she brought like an inflatable duck with her.
Like a little floaty.
Yeah.
That's gonna do anything with someone with sharp nails.
Everything is glowing.
I think they're like, you know, the real gamer, gamer wrestler over here.
Wait, she also has a crown.
Oh my god, it's gonna be like a wrestling wedding.
The king and queen.
I was thinking...
Wait, what were you...
A wedding?
What?
Yeah, like the royal wedding.
Okay.
Oh my god, wait, Rint is huge.
How tall is she?
Oh my god.
Wait, oh shit, she's so tall.
I will not help you in this.
Vive la revolution, let's go.
That's French.
Wrong country.
French is across the ocean.
Okay, well, in...
What do you mean across the ocean?
It is technically across.
It's the British look out into the ocean.
Across from them is France.
They're still connected by land though.
No, they're not.
British is a fucking island.
They're on the...
It's Europe.
They're just the same continent.
The UK is on the island.
Do you not know the UK is on an...
Is an island?
Oh my god.
Oh, wait, you're right.
Bro!
You know what?
I shouldn't be surprised.
You're in geography.
What do you mean by that?
In Europe as well.
I'm kidding.
Oh yeah, you know all the flags in the world.
This is why the British are losing.
You didn't even know the UK was an island.
Hey, I'm a ghost.
I've been dead for so long.
I only remember Panji.
Oh, so you're right.
The Teutonic plates happen.
Things are shifting still.
Things are still shifting.
She lives in the past and the present, guys.
Exactly.
Time has no concept to her.
Oh my god, what?
Wait!
The British almost pinned her?
Wait, why didn't Emma bring her claws?
Like, it would be so easy.
Oh my god!
It hurts her heart!
What?
Oh, she's not stopping!
She's just going at it!
She's going at it!
Yeah!
Like crazy!
Oh!
Rin took some crazy hits there.
I don't...
I think like Rin chose the wrong dungeon.
That's for sure.
I think so too.
I mean...
It's a level 1 mafia versus level 99 mafia bonus.
Level 1 grunt.
Is this even legal?
You're doing it out of the ring, ladies!
Oh!
Oh my god.
She's just like beating her up outside the ring.
She does not care.
No.
Oh, the stare.
She's out for blood.
Yeah.
Inside.
I'm surprised that like...
Um...
Surpri...
Oh my...
Okay, did you trip?
But it was cool.
It was cool.
She just tripped on her own feet instead of a ball.
It's so one-sided.
What do you mean?
We literally saw Rin get absolutely pulverized.
Yeah.
And now...
Size is not everything.
Yeah.
Size is not...
Somebody needs the agility.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, already?
So she's not ready?
Someone quick CGI Rin right now.
Oh.
Oh, there's another pin.
One!
Two!
Three!
And that is actually...
Here is your winner.
Someone's dilemma.
Emma!
Okay, that is sort of like really embarrassing though for...
That was so fast.
Yeah.
What happened?
The match before lasted like 20 years.
But then the one with...
Okay, so...
You know the British are just, you know, their fighting style is too polite.
I know.
I think...
I think they turned shooting.
I think the Viva La Revolution sort of jinxed the whole thing.
Do you want to try that again?
Oh my god.
Another idol member got wiped out.
That's a little sad.
I guess we gotta go to the interview stage to talk to...
Okay.
Yeah, let's see what Rin feels like about all of this.
Oh.
Hello!
That was the fastest match yet!
That was the fa- This is the second match.
That was the fastest one though!
Rin, how did it feel?
I don't- like, I saw you- Like, get off.
I think we need an ambulance.
If anyone out there can call, um, I don't know what it is in the UK, but it's 119- I have seven concussions!
Sorry, I accidentally punched her too much because she's so funny with that green suit.
I can't.
I was snorting so hard.
It was like when a bull sees red.
You saw green and you just went- How many times do you have to punch me for it to stop?
She was giving you CPR, Fanny.
You know what they say, the taller they are, the harder they fall.
So, Rin Penrose, how does it feel not being in the next match?
Painful!
I think my ribs are misaligned!
I think, um, I mean that's part of the contract, you know, so...
Yeah, honestly, you know what you are getting here.
You just didn't read the fine print.
I think, like, you know, when we saw you in the ring, we noticed that was not your accurate height there, so like, somebody was wearing heels there.
Someone's like, John!
John VTuber!
Yeah, John VTuber, what are you doing wearing those high heels?
In the wrestling match.
Oh, I have no heels, I was just-
Well, how did it feel beating up the Rin Penrose?
Uh... good.
I'm right here!
I'm still in the room, you know!
She does it so fast, I thought she could beat me harder, but...
Oh my god!
Oh, yeah, you thought she was gonna last longer, you know?
Maybe because you're British, I guess.
Damn it, uh...
Every bone in my arms are broken, Emma!
Yeah, because apparently, I thought British people are so powerful, can't believe you're that.
Yeah, it's very- I am a small victim of you!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Can we get a doctor up in here?
Yeah, guys, can we get a doctor for- 999?
For Rin and Rin?
What are the numbers?
What are the three numbers?
What do they mean?
What are the numbers?
999?
Oh my god, there's too many emergency numbers!
966, 991, 996, and 99...
Alright, congratulations to Emma for making it to the next round!
Your opponent will be Lai Mu soon, after our next match.
But anyway, we want to say thank you again to Emma and Rin for joining us.
Rin, sadly, you're the second loser of the night.
Another idol has been eliminated from the bracket.
Come on, idol girls!
So, we have actually one more idol girl, right?
How many more?
We have two idol girls left.
So, we have Juna and Fuyo left to represent idols.
So, I wonder if Fuyo will win against Snuffy later.
I guess we'll find out and see.
Anyway, we're gonna have to keep going.
We're gonna kick you girls out and move on to the next pair.
The biggest match of the night.
Oh...
Yes.
Yeah!
Oh yeah!
The Meteor and the Dinosaur!
Nana, kick his ass!
Nana!
Kick his ass!
Thank you so much, guys!
Alright, see you later, girls!
Can we drag in the next two?
Go get some help, Rin!
Yeah, go get some help.
Go get some help.
She definitely needs it.
I can't drag.
Oh wait, I should give you...
I should give you admin.
Permissions, please!
Please, please!
I told you, day one is all about figuring stuff out, guys.
I agree.
Alright, you can ask them for now, but I'm gonna give you admin room.
I did.
Alright.
Nana is saying, oh hot, good god.
I think she's nervous.
I think she's throwing up.
Yeah, a little bit.
She's throwing up.
But she made... she mainly made like a diss track before.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Nico!
Oh!
Hello, wrestlers!
Hello!
So, I've been seeing the beef on Twitter.
Hello, hello!
We finally talk face to face, Nana!
Oh my fucking god, I just...
I'm gonna just say it right now, you fucking dropped the diss track right before...
Right before the actual match!
How fucking good was that?
What?
Wait, it's been 65 million years, Gerard.
How have I been doing getting pregnant, I hear?
What?
You've been doing your research.
I see.
The galaxy never disappoints.
You've always been watching me.
I know you have three children who live under a bridge with no mom, no dad, and you eat grime.
That is none of your business!
Keep your nose out of my life!
You tried to ruin mine!
Now get out of it!
I'm trying to live peacefully here!
Oh, you cry!
Don't try to ruin it!
Are you crying?
I'm not crying.
I'm trying to live.
And I can't believe we're matched up.
I just want to live, man.
Like, what is this?
This has got to be rigged.
It has to be rigged.
Why am I fighting you?
I could have been fighting anyone else!
God damn it, I'm remembering traumatic experiences from my childhood.
Ladies.
I have a question for you.
Mahogany or oak?
Mahogany.
Okay, good.
That's going to be the coffin.
I'm going to put you in six feet under.
Oh, son of a bitch!
Oh, no!
I can't bury you!
You're literally the guy...
I don't know how to make a comeback about that.
I'll just try my best.
Oh, my God!
Holy fuck!
Stop!
I'm already dead!
The match hasn't even started yet!
He's crying, Chad!
He's crying!
Guys, guys.
Please, this is the only means of me actually fighting back!
Please!
He needs the money from the tournament to pay for Calc's support.
I need to win!
I heard you have a diss track that you made about Gerard.
Oh, yeah.
Can you give us a little sneak peek?
How many hours did it take you to make that?
Holy shit.
I made that song in ten hours since last night.
Oh!
That was last minute!
That sounded so great, though!
I thought that would take a day.
Holy shit.
Holy crap!
Thank you!
That's some pure fucking rage out there.
What the fuck did I do to you?
Why did you have to roast me like that?
That wasn't necessary!
Did you give us the acapella of the roast for us?
The diss track?
Oh, by the way, the beat is completely made custom.
So you can play it.
Wow!
Oh, my God!
Gerard, what the fuck were you doing?
This is why the asteroid bites your chino.
I know, like what the fuck?
I got nothing.
I was just starting beef and then I didn't know you'd be making a diss track.
I didn't think that was a thing.
Gerard, what were you doing?
What were you doing, okay?
While I was being born from the galaxy?
I was trying to live!
After that massacre on my family, you think I'd be doing something against the galaxy?
Nothing!
I'm just trying to live, prioritizing my own life!
Pick it up.
What were you doing?
That's why she came back to finish the job, guys.
She noticed Gerard was wasting his life.
After the chance she gave him to live on, she noticed he was wasting his life.
So she's coming back to finish the job.
No, but I will be winning today.
As the movie ends with me being the victor.
Everyone dies, but not everyone lives their life.
Everyone lives their life.
We got some fucking wise words from the galaxy herself.
I can't tell if you're praising me or you're pissing me.
Pick a bunch!
I feel like we've already picked it up.
I mean, I can't help it.
You dropped the disc.
I can't help being humble.
I gotta be humbled.
Holy shit.
I gotta put in some work.
You did some good shit.
Pick it up.
I'm trying.
My tiny arms can't.
It's wailing.
How much will you hold with it?
I'm trying to pick it up.
Ladies!
Take this to the ring, ladies.
The polls are actually pretty surprisingly close.
Nana actually only has a 57% of winning this match from the audience vote.
So that's really crazy to see after Gerard getting his ass beat verbally.
You may have cooked me in this drag section.
In the beef section.
But this time I'm gonna be putting you down in a real match.
Nana, prepare your ass.
You're so going down.
Oh, God.
Why are you dissing me?
Stop speaking my language!
It hurts even more!
It hurts!
See you in the ring!
We're gonna join back the casters table now.
Man, that shit was crazy though.
Oh my God!
That was like a beef worth a million years.
Not gonna lie.
I feel like I just watched Gerard turn into like, Gord.
It was just under that pressure.
I know.
Like, honestly, I would be very surprised if Gerard managed to pull this off after what we saw today.
I mean, even even Nana's guy... look at her, just giving salt bae.
Yeah, right?
Like, oh.
The confidence.
The burning expectations!
Gerard's just like, I'm happy to be here.
Gee willikers!
Yeah!
I mean, it could... everything could be lighting a fire under his butt.
You know?
Like... That's true.
We don't know how he's gonna react.
It's all...
It's anyone's game.
Yeah, yeah.
I just... it feels like he's like, you know, it feels like he has suspenders on and he's like, Oh, geezer!
I'm so happy!
He just had a golden ticket to go to WIlliams.
He's trying, he's like, golly geezer!
I'm so happy to be here!
I got the golden ticket to be in WrestleTubers!
The following contest is scheduled for one fall!
Introducing first!
Who's it gonna be?
Yes!
It's Naaah!
Naaaaah!
Oh, she's back.
She's back to finish.
Oh my god!
She's famous!
I mean, the asteroid that killed off the dinosaurs?
That's a pretty famous asteroid.
Not gonna lie.
That is, that is.
And also pretty old, so...
Yeah, a hag.
Kind of a hag, yeah.
I thought you liked that.
I mean, as one, I would hold.
You gotta support your own kind, you know?
It's self-love.
You gotta support your own kind, man.
You gotta send one of them over.
Yeah, exactly.
Introducing their opponent!
Ooh.
Be painfully adored!
Gerard T.
Raxford!
What the...
Whoa!
He is definitely lost.
He's like, this isn't the factor.
Yeah!
Where's my golden ticket?
Where's Where's Willy Wonka?
He's crawling!
Like a wild animal!
Oh my god!
What a freak!
I don't think T-Rex has used their front hand.
Yeah, he's already doing it wrong.
He's just like, where's Willy Wonka?
Oh, oh, oh!
Give us that pose, sir!
Yeah!
For the fans!
I know!
The last remaining dinosaur...
Where did he get that?
What the hell?
He got a chainsaw!
Who's the kiddie?
Who let this man have a chainsaw?
Pull this down!
Oh, the pyrotechnics!
Oh my god, he went all out!
He went all out with this!
Yeah, but a budget doesn't mean, you know, a brain.
We'll see.
Or the brawn.
I mean, T-Rexes are known to have a tiny brain.
They're like chickens.
All birds have tiny brains.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, I'm proof of that.
We know!
Oh shit!
The asteroids are already striking down!
Whoa!
Not a good start for Gerard.
For sure.
It's like she's taking... she's finishing the job what should have been done millions of years ago.
I know.
She wanted him to live a full life to remember all his bad...
What the fuck is wrong with his neck?
Oh my god.
Did you see that?
It was like a 180.
Oh!
He's gonna...
He should pull his tail.
Gerard, please.
Do something, Gerard.
Gerard, do something!
Anything!
Your family died for this!
Oh!
There we go!
He was just playing it.
He was keeping it cool.
He was thinking that she had the upper hand.
He wanted...
He's rigging the bets right now so more people will bet against him.
Yeah.
Oh!
There she goes.
Hey, you almost hit the impostor and...
announcers.
Yeah.
The...
The extras.
Yeah, the extras.
The filthy flushies.
Who invited the 3D people in a 2D tournament?
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah.
Keeper anime.
Get this out of here.
Not anime leave!
Alright.
This seems like...
Whoa!
Where is she grabbing?
HR?
He is putting his hand somewhere that he should not be.
It's kind of beautiful.
Like a little princess carry.
One, two!
That's true.
Do you want to be carried like that?
Um... Nope.
Do you want to be a princess?
I'm the maid to the princess.
Oh, so you'll do the carrying.
I see.
Yeah.
You want to be the carrier.
Oh my god.
She's just watching him.
Look, the crowd is going nuts.
Several people are saying this is awesome.
We love it.
It is pretty awesome.
Holy shit!
What a pin!
Wow!
Wowee!
Oh my god!
Here is your winner!
Yes!
It's Naaaaaa Naaaaaa!
Ohhhhhhh!
That's just sad!
Okay, gotta call bullshit!
Bullshit!
That never happened!
What the fuck!
I think you were enjoying that a little bit, Gerard!
It was so fast!
Naaaaaa!
All she did was just pinning it.
Clap his ass!
All over her.
That was so embarrassing!
Holy shit!
Alright, let's talk to the loser real quick.
Yeah.
That was...
I mean, what was he actually losing?
Come on!
I think it was...
I think we just had to let him go at that point.
It was just too much.
And off to the interview stage we go.
Alright.
You're a fucking trooper.
Bro, I put it on my actual...
I put my actual statistics there!
My height and everything!
And I was fighting this big brawling dude!
I didn't know!
Oh.
Oh my god.
They say it was a candidate fit.
Well, that was embarrassing.
Well, this track is actually true now!
I got buried!
And that's the casket... Mahogany?
Was it?
God!
Mahogany casket!
Shout out to Gerard.
Gerard was handicapped with pregnancy.
I was fighting the galaxy, to be fair.
I was fighting the galaxy.
And it was like a huge power gap and...
Okay, I give up.
You literally had millions of years to prepare for it.
Yeah!
But I didn't think I'd be fighting in a wrestling match!
I thought I'd be fighting it somewhere else!
Where?
Like where?
I don't know a few million more years!
I'm just 21 years old, okay?
I don't know!
You're a fetus dinosaur.
What the fuck?
Oh my gosh.
I was fighting a galaxy.
I was just a teeny little bit dinosaur.
Shout out to Sorority for helping me build my absolute weapon.
Even my fucking group!
Even my fans!
I love you!
God loves you!
And this is historically accurate.
The last dino has been slain!
Woo!
No!
No, no, no!
Shut up!
Gerard, all I'm saying is that maybe you should have worked on a diss track.
Yeah.
That wouldn't help!
That's not helping me with my fucking build!
I thought it was crying ass!
I literally was powered up by a diss track.
You know, all I just want to say is that I'm satisfied.
I don't even need a Windows game.
I feel my life goal has been satisfied.
Over the years I've carried 65 million years they've been settled.
I'm at peace.
I'm at zen.
I've reached the end of my life.
I'm fucking annoyed.
I want to fight you again.
I need a rematch right now.
Yeah, I want to fight you again!
Hurrah!
I'll fight you right now!
I know where you live.
Not my kids!
They're watching!
How do you know where you live?
Are you a dog sitting in that fucking muscle chamber?
Yeah, I know where you live.
I would be surprised if she didn't know where I live.
She's the fucking galaxy, fuck's sake.
She just like fucking destroys the earth and be like, I know where you live.
The day I killed the right family it changed his world.
For me, it was a Tuesday.
I'm already dead.
I'm already defeated.
Could you please stop?
I'm already dead.
I'm sorry.
Alright, ladies, ladies.
Go take this fight backstage because we're gonna be letting in the next set of fights.
In bracket one.
Yeah, but thank you.
Thank you for having us.
Thank you.
Thank you, Doki.
Thank you so much for organizing this.
Thank you.
Thank you, Duna.
You did it.
I'm so happy for you.
Bye bye.
Bye bye, get out.
Also, did you see the...
Yeah, yeah, I changed it.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Do you like it?
I love it.
It's beautiful.
Okay, the issue right now is that Snuffy is offline.
So, I don't know if...
I don't know if Snuffy is here right now.
Can anyone impersonate Snuffy?
Okay, we could go with Lime versus Emma for now until Snuffy appears.
Snuffy is a little bit...
We don't know where she is.
Oh, but what about for like Fuyo?
Fuyo?
Oh.
Okay.
Is Fuyo okay with waiting until Snuffy appears before... Oh!
I saw her on before.
Yeah, I saw her on before.
I saw her on.
She's fucking dead.
Where did you go?
Wait, God, Snuffy!
She's fine with waiting.
Okay, because of that, then we'll go with Lime versus Emma then.
Okay.
Please come back in, please.
Oh my god.
Fucking Emma is so huge.
She like overtook them.
Why didn't you make me size accurate?
I'm actually seven foot tall.
Oh, you're a fucking eel.
You're not seven foot.
Look at my wiki!
I'm seven foot!
Anybody can edit that wiki!
I had a stream where I elongated to seven foot.
Hello, Emma and Lime!
Hello!
Hi!
How do you guys feel?
Wow.
Yeah, like, that was so... wow.
I love the energy.
Yeah, I know.
It's okay.
I had a small power nap between the lines.
I'm feeling a little bit better.
But I feel so funny the fact that we both want to lose but we both win.
Now I don't know who's going to lose over here.
She's like, wait, what's that bag?
Oh no, wait, that didn't work.
Who wants it more?
Yeah, who wants it more out of you two guys?
Emma wants it more.
No, wait, I want it more!
Oh, you wanna win now?
You wanna win now, Lime?
I thought you wanted to lose.
No, I'm horribly competitive.
Oh, oh my, I see.
Can you not tell from the burning passion in my voice and how adrenaline-filled I sound right now?
I'm just so fucking into it, dude.
And you're like a natural.
Oh, I see.
Have you read the instructions on how to beat a dungeon boss?
No, not the instructions!
You didn't even hear this before, did we?
Yeah, yeah, like, Min doesn't know what you're talking about.
Like, we can never be able to figure it out.
Well, I think, like, over 100k people know what I'm talking about.
100k?
Did 100k people raid your dungeon?
What?
But why would they know?
I don't understand.
Why would they know that?
It's okay, for now only Lime can raid my dungeon.
Right, Lime?
You will raid my dungeon!
Hell yeah!
Yeah, over and over again!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Yeah, you can punch me in the face!
You can stab for me!
You can do whatever you want, Lime!
Woah!
She's a masochist, you got this.
Natalie fuels her then!
I'm gonna get demonetized!
Well, it's on my channel, so...
I'm gonna get you demonetized!
I'm pretty used to it.
I think you're ready to smash each other.
Woah!
Endgame!
Endgame, guys.
Take all this aggression!
I need my London Bridge.
Oh my god!
Bring back the London Bridge!
It's falling down!
Alright, ladies.
Take all that aggression out on each other in the fucking ring!
Was that aggression?
Some people would call that aggression.
On Bride and Loss?
Woah!
Good luck, ladies.
We're gonna move to the main casting table now.
I'm just standing over here!
I'll see you guys there.
Good luck, ladies.
Good luck!
Alright, I did not make the pull yet for this match.
What are you doing, Davina?
I was so busy listening to this conversation!
You're a together!
It was so interesting!
Were you not immersed?
No, you were just fantasizing about raiding a dungeon.
And what does that mean?
Going on a grand journey.
Finding treasure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's it, right?
And then becoming rich and famous.
That's what raiding is.
Yeah!
Find someone else's stuff and you steal it.
Yeah, steal their booty.
Yeah!
What else could it be?
Nah.
Alright.
Let's head over to Lymu versus Emma.
Actually, I don't know.
They both seem... both of them ended the other... well, Lymu actually had a real fight, to be fair.
Yeah, Lymu I think has been the longest match so far.
Yeah, the longest matchup we've seen so far.
The others...
not so much.
I think she just got a little sleepy, but she said she had a match.
I feel... yeah.
But to be fair, they're like a natural.
I think Lymu is a natural wrestler.
Not gonna lie.
I think so too.
Emma...
I mean, Emma fucking destroyed Rin.
But like... but it was Rin, so...
The following contest is scheduled for one fall!
That is round two.
Henshin is a first!
Oh my gosh, she's so eepy!
Eepy!
What an eepy girl.
She just woke up from a nap!
She looks like she's like coming from Starbucks.
The juiciest piece of fruit lime!
Delicious!
She's like, I'm just gonna wake up and then...
Wake up and kick ass!
Let's go!
You know those like, white girl quotes?
Like...
Is that a sleeping bag or is that...
It's a pillow!
Oh, it's a pillow!
Yeah, it's a pillow!
Wow, this music is so like chill too.
Yeah, it's like lo-fi.
And she beat Kai.
What was that?
Coffee in her pillow.
She's ready.
Introducing her opponent!
Your majesty.
She's someone's dilemma!
Who's dilemma?
Dilemma!
Wow!
Announcer, whose dilemma is she?
Announcer, you never finished your question!
We'll never find out.
We'll never know.
Whose dilemma she is.
Oh, well she... I guess she's limes.
Maybe, we'll see.
We'll see.
See, I mean... I don't understand why they can't...
Well Lime's got endurance, you know?
Lime was able to hold her own the whole time.
That's true, that's true.
Even when she was like an eepy baby, she was able to...
I wish like, you know, WE actually...
Call somebody an eepy baby.
WWN over there!
She was an eepy baby.
Eepy baby.
Lime needs a headset?
Mint fucking crashed the event!
She does not get a headset.
Yeah, I don't have shit.
I did not prepare a headset.
Yeah, why don't you give me one?
Yeah.
This is MINE.
I'm not supposed to be here.
I'm here illegally.
She's an illegal ghost, guys.
We didn't summon you!
Alright, let's go.
Okay.
Oh!
What a hit!
Starting out strong!
And another hit too?
Oh, she's just breaking her arm.
Maybe she's too eepy.
Yeah, she's too eepy!
Oh my god!
Not the arm!
Please!
What's somebody think about her... How is she gonna drink her coffee without arms?
Through a straw, I guess.
Yeah...
Coffee through a straw?
Oh my god, I can't get enough of these panty shots.
Mint, her chest is up there!
Her tail is back there!
Mint, you're gonna look at the panty shot when you have Emma's chest right there for you.
I mean... that's true, that's true, but...
I mean, have you not seen her measurements?
It's more fun when it's flashed, you know?
You just see it a little bit.
I think we need HR training here.
What is going on here?
Is she just like, let me ponder your orb?
Why?
Whoa!
Right in the gut!
Oh my god!
I don't know what she was doing measuring her cranium.
Yeah, I needed...
I needed to buy you a hat.
Let me measure it.
I don't have a ruler.
I can't believe it.
I've never...
It's been 20 years since I saw the measure the cranium move.
Oh my god.
Sometimes I feel like it's a little useless, but...
What do I know?
I think it's like a power move.
It's like to just show that you can do it.
That's true.
It doesn't do anything.
You just can do it.
One!
Two!
Oh!
And Lime broke it!
Lime's endurance is coming in clutch here.
Yeah.
She's doing so much work right now.
She might be an EP baby, but she knows what she's doing.
Yeah.
I feel Emma is like very brutal, but she's going to tire herself out, you know?
Like, I mean, like, she clearly does not have long stamina unlike Lime.
Oh my god.
Just bring a knife while you're at it and shake it.
That's true.
Remind her of London.
Take her back to her hometown.
I see London.
I see France.
I see Lime who's underpants.
And another stomp from Emma.
Emma!
What was the move that we were waiting for, Dokie?
The handy dandy.
The tandy dandy.
We've seen it once before in this event.
It's been banned for ten years, but these ladies, they don't care about laws.
Laws.
Neither do we.
Fuck him up!
Yeah, bring him down!
Just shake her!
Where's the London Bridge?
Oh, and the slam!
Slam!
And a kick to Jesus Christ.
That's her back.
And when you fuck your back up... Emma shows no mercy.
Yeah, Emma doesn't care.
Oh!
Right on the head?
Holy shit!
Oh!
She's giving us what we want.
One, two!
It's not over yet.
Again, Gammu's endurance.
Yeah.
Gammu's like, no.
No, no, no.
We gotta show it again.
Oh!
A second time!
One!
Two!
Oh!
It's cause the cameraman gave us the wrong angle.
You know?
Yeah, that's so true.
Yeah.
They gotta do it again.
Guys, guys, the cameraman does not know what he's doing.
Like, we need a different angle.
Oh my god!
The grip!
Wait, and then the reversal?
And again!
Another pin?
One!
Two!
Three!
Oh my god!
Emma is out of control.
She is like, obsessed with the dungeon raids.
Here is your winner!
The big dilemma!
Emma!
Oh!
Look at her go.
She's happy with another.
She has absorbed another dungeon raider.
Everybody's dilemma.
Very good.
I didn't realize we were raiding.
Three stars.
Let me put the wrestling app real quick.
It could need a little bit more work, Emma.
I feel like, you know, you should have positioned her in a better way so that the camera would get it.
You know?
Yeah, always know your angles.
Come on.
Yeah, exactly.
I always know where the camera is facing, Emma, if you want a higher rating on the wrestling tuber app.
Alright, let's go talk to the...
Could have been better, you know?
Alright, let's go talk to the ladies real quick.
Alright.
Yeah, you are.
Hello!
Welcome back!
Congratulations!
Lymu, how do you feel being able to sleep now?
It's gonna be great.
Like, I think maybe I should have had some extra caffeine and save the nap for after the match, but it's okay.
Live and learn.
You live and learn and then you get your skull crushed, but it's okay.
Did you like, did you enjoy being, like, having your skull crushed by THE Emma?
Yeah, no, it was really good.
I'd do it again.
Oh my god!
Why?
To be fair, you tried, you literally do it, like, several times, too.
I just couldn't help myself.
She keep getting stuff on, I feel so bad.
I was like, stop, me, stop!
It was consensual, don't worry.
Yeah.
Consensual, but she...
It looks really me, actually.
She just, she just an ego.
She wanna go home and play Valorant.
Oh gosh.
I feel so bad.
No!
So, so, LimeWu, how does it feel to lose against Emma?
Sorry, Juno, you're supposed to say that.
Honestly.
Yeah, I said it, like, basically, because she wants to sleep.
I mean, I can reword my answer, I guess.
Say it again, but with different sentences.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we hope you didn't plagiarize.
Yeah, no, no, it was honestly, it was honestly...
It was honestly...
It was honestly an honor to get stepped on by someone so tall and muscular.
This is a video about Emma's Discord.
Your Discord daddy.
Yeah.
Come here.
Come here, little kitten.
You have to listen to your daddy right now.
It looks like this dungeon boss has conquered her own dungeon.
Damn.
Oh my god.
We're like listening to this live.
Yeah.
The roleplay goes crazy.
If you win the tournament, what will you do with your belt?
Me?
Yeah.
If I win?
I will show it to my dad.
This is like casting coach interview.
And I'm gonna be so proud.
Why do you keep being like so sultry with that?
It's like, if you win your belt, why are you...
It's my piece of...
Emma, if you win, why are you doing this?
Why are you so sultry with that?
Emma, help me.
I can't be...
I guess we can't be together now, Juna.
It's so dangerous.
People are watching us.
Yeah.
We're just so sultry and deep-voiced and oh my god, are we gonna kiss and everything?
That's crazy.
People are just watching us.
It's like, oh my gosh, are we gonna do something on stage?
Oh my god.
I think we need an after-hours.
I think we need an after-hours segment here for these guys.
Yeah.
Me.
Oh my god.
Congratulations on winning this match, Emma.
You deserve some breakfast.
Oh my gosh.
I guess I am the final dungeon boss.
Can't wait to meet my final opponent.
Whoever you are, get ready.
You're not gonna sleep after this.
Your next opponent.
Could be either Nana, Snuffy, or Fuyo.
Unfortunately, Snuffy is still a little MIA, so we're gonna move on to bracket two until she appears.
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay.
Oh no.
Oh shit.
So we'll make sure when she's back, we will go back to the match with her and Fuyo.
So yeah.
Anyway, I realize we're doing this live.
Cause I realize I forgot to download Hakka's Wrestler.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
I had everybody but Hakka's.
I apologize, Hakka.
Like I said, like this is the first time I organize WrestleTuber, guys.
This is the very first WrestleTuber 2024.
So of course there's gonna be a scuff along the way.
And if I forget to download Hakka, it just has to be a little bit of a surprise.
Just a little shock.
The fish you write now is I'm trying to find Hakka.
There's like 10 pages.
Oh I found him.
Oh wait.
Am I next?
No, you're not next.
I'm just making the.
Alright, because we might as well roll in bracket number two, which is Anon and Nia.
Bracket number two.
My baby girls.
Oh my gosh, that's my girls.
Freeza fighting each other.
For those who want to see bracket two, this is going to be bracket two, guys.
Sayu, unfortunately, like I said, Sayu is going to be on day two because there was some delays.
And so he won't be here for day one.
So Luto and Sayu's match will be moved to day two, everybody.
So can we drag Anon and Nia to the...
Yeah.
Goodbye, Emma.
Goodbye, Lionel.
Bye-bye.
See you guys again later.
Thank you, ladies.
Nia.
Hi.
Hello.
I've been seeing the beef on Twitter.
Oh, yeah.
You're not on the screen yet.
Oh, we're not there yet.
You're not there yet.
There's you.
Oh my gosh.
I know.
It's just ahead.
There's you.
Okay, you're tiny here.
Oh my gosh.
Why is it just the head?
Where did he go?
What's with the recipe?
Sorry.
Tight accurate.
Okay.
There we go.
No, it's not.
We're like the same height.
That's how you act here.
No, it's not.
We're the same height.
The more you complain, the tinier you get.
No.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
That's right.
She's becoming chat.
No.
It's okay.
She knows her place now.
She...
I'm sorry.
Well, to start off, I've been watching the beef between you guys on Twitter.com and I'm unsure whether this is a problem.
I'm not sure if this is a brawl or like something else.
I...
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Non wants to get choked and...
I didn't know how to respond to that.
This is the perfect place for that.
Whoa.
That's true.
Yeah.
But she said please choke me, mommy, so...
No, no, no.
No matter what happens, I lose.
Like, she wins either way.
But you're not into that?
That's...
Maybe.
No.
So you wouldn't choke your beloved... bunny?
Yeah!
Right?
You hate her?
Don't you hate me, please?
Wait, wait, why?
I don't know what the right answer is.
What is the right answer?
It's supposed to be a yes because he's so angry at me.
I don't want you to have the satisfaction.
Nooooo!
I'll blue ball you.
Whoa!
Can you blue me harder?
That's fucked up.
You know what?
Maybe she deserves it.
I'm scared.
Is this wrestling?
I don't know.
I feel like...
I feel like there's something else.
I think we're back on the casting couch.
I feel like this is the casting couch now.
I feel like there's some very strange tension in the air.
I don't know if it's...
sexual or...
I'm unsure now.
I don't know what to say.
You did this, Juno.
I did this!
I asked him a question and he was like, please, I wanna get choked.
Are you perpetuated?
Yeah.
Like a more sultry environment.
No!
It's my voice.
Your sexy presence.
Juno, I'm also open for you to choke me too.
I'm not gonna choke you.
So what are you gonna do in order to beat Nia?
I'm going to lay there.
Okay.
I think you'll lose if you just lay there.
If you're not moving for like X amount of seconds, you'll just lose.
How would that work?
Maybe I can inflict passion into her.
Passion?
You love to see the passion in the ring.
Yeah.
Oh, that's true.
Wrestling passion, right?
Yeah.
Exactly.
That's the passion we're looking for.
Wow.
I don't know.
I don't...
Nia, I wish you luck.
I don't wanna really wish you luck.
But I hope you do well.
We're not supposed to be biased, Juno.
You're part of the broadcast staff.
I wish you both...
Wait, no.
I need all the support I can get.
I'm biased.
Look, you got this, girlies.
Please win.
Beat each other up.
And choke each other.
Yeah!
Off we go, ladies.
We're gonna take that to the ring.
That passion that we saw here.
Yeah, passion!
Back to the casting table we go.
Goodbye forever.
Goodbye, guys.
Goodbye.
Good luck.
We believe in you.
Wow.
I just put out a poll and it seems like people really want Anna to win.
It's the choking buff, you know?
It's the choking...
Do you speak from experience?
No, no.
Why do you know so much...
Wait, but why do you know so much about the choking buff?
I just believe that, you know, I think that...
I think anybody who is a masochist and is in wrestling, they experience the pain and it gives them a buff.
That I know from experience.
Oh, okay.
Oh, what the hell is that?
Oh my god.
You know, the one type of wrestler that wants to be choked.
The following contest is scheduled for one poll!
Introducing first...
Oh my god.
Look at her ass.
Oh, Nia!
Naruto Itachi outfit.
Yeah.
I like how the background is like an Easter theme.
We can have like a view from the back too.
I think there's a view everywhere.
Oh my god.
She has a rose.
She has several roses with her.
Yeah.
She's so elegant.
That's a word.
Pose for us, girl.
Pose.
She's so...
What?
You don't think she's beautiful?
I'm feeling...
I'm feeling like Easter morning right now.
Oh my god.
It's true.
It's Easter, guys.
Jesus has died for our sins and he's getting ready to be resurrected into that thing.
Yeah.
That's what you're gonna see on Sunday.
Oh boy.
Apologies.
The last one was add-on.
I'm sorry.
I got the wrong card.
Introducing their opponent.
Who's the opponent, sir?
Who is it?
Who's that?
The real...
NNAAYAAAAAH!!
Wait, they're both furries.
Look, they have like...
WAHAAHAd She's so cool!!
She needs business.
Oh my God.
She lost a tooth.
Luckily veneers are in right now.
Oh my God.
Look at her go.
She's out there getting those tax forms done.
Uh oh.
I hope everything is all taken care of.
You know, everything is signed properly.
Yeah.
Nothing done under the table.
Tax fraud is not a joke.
No.
And she's here to prove it.
Damn.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
Some ladies just got pregnant just now.
Oh, was it you?
No, it was Gerard.
Gerard's out there in the stands right now going, Nia!
Please, I'm already dead.
Please.
I can hear him now.
Hearing you chat out, Nia!
Please!
Yeah, I think I just heard him say it.
Yeah!
Yeah, come on Gerard!
Say it again!
Nia!
Please, the match is already over.
Could you please just watch the different wrestlers, please?
Wow!
Oh my god!
The kick from Nia right off the fucking bat.
I'm loving Nia's like Dorothy outfit right now.
Oh yeah, she... we're not in Kansas anymore.
Following the yellow brick road.
Bro, what the... what did she do?
But she is choking her.
Wait a minute.
Wait, wait, wait.
Here's the wrong person getting choked.
Yeah, you're supposed to get choked, Anna!
Wait, Anna has like a fanny pack.
Did you see that?
She has...
Wait, is it?
Yeah, she has...
No way.
No, she has... Oh my god, it's London Bridge!
London Bridge!
She stole Limo's moon!
I see London.
I see France.
I see Nia's underpants.
No, see, look, there's the fanny pack!
Oh, I see it.
I do see it, yeah.
Oh my god.
What do you have?
What do you have in there?
Yeah, what is she hiding in there?
Yeah, Anna.
What do you have?
What do you call this move, Mint?
Um, that's the Queen's Wave.
I don't know why everything is British-themed.
Oh my god!
Is that...
Move over, King Charles!
Queen Nia is here to take that throne!
To be fair, it won't be that hard to do.
He's very old.
Oh, yeah.
I just realized she... Anna has a tattoo of her own face.
Anna has a lot going on.
I think it's, you know...
What is she doing?
Anna, please!
Get up!
She's showing off... Oh, what the hell was that?
What a miss!
Anna, are you okay?
I think both of these guys need glasses.
What's going on here?
Honestly, true.
They definitely did not put on...
the contacts, Mint.
No.
Not at all.
Oh!
What a slam!
Another slam!
And a kick to... They really like kicking each other's backs.
Alright, come on.
You can choke her.
This is your moment.
Yeah, this is choking moment.
Peak choke moment.
I call this walking the dog.
Clip it, chat.
Clip it.
She barked.
No, no, no, no.
For free on my own channel?
I see the views going up right now.
We'll do anything for the views.
For free?
Oh, my gosh.
Another stop on the face.
Yeah, Nia's just not giving her the satisfaction of the choke.
I know.
Like, she ended up choking her.
And so...
Oh, she's dead.
Oh!
A first hit!
Okay, her face looks like the Grinch for like one second.
Did you know that?
But her heart is not growing.
Oh, it's definitely not the heart.
It does not leave.
Don't worry.
What she's wearing right now does not need any imagination.
You know what I noticed?
I noticed Nia is like a fusion between like her dog and like Dorothy and her dog.
With a fucking R.
A total?
Yeah.
The R's.
What?
I don't know.
Next thing.
Anyone who gets cocky is gonna get you.
Yeah.
Is gonna...
Oh, wait.
Not punished?
Is she actually not gonna get punishment?
They're at five, though.
Oh, my God.
Ew.
She like spit.
Oh, my God.
Ladies, please.
This is not the bedroom, ladies.
I feel bad for the janitor.
That's true.
Imagine having to clean all that.
Like all the sweaty bodies, too.
When Chat could just do it for free.
Well, Chat.
You wanna get hired today?
It's a volunteer job, though.
It's a volunteer job, Chat.
Yeah.
What?
Not one?
Because she was out of the ring.
Nia doesn't know the fight and support.
What the fuck is she doing?
Nia.
What is she doing?
Here is your winner by count out.
It's Cat and...
Anon!
Oh, my God.
Nia.
Wow.
Nia did not know.
What happened?
What happened, Nia?
The ring was right there.
I mean, I feel like it was big enough, right?
Right.
Like, it was there.
Lackluster of a moment.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Wait.
Her face is on her nose.
Did you see that?
Oh, that's what that is?
Yeah.
That's her face on the nose.
I'm loving this dream work space we've got going on here.
Yeah.
That's true.
Very... You know what?
We got the Bee movie right here.
Bee movie at home.
This is the whole Bee.
Yeah.
That's the whole Bee.
Let's talk to the ladies and see what they think.
Let's talk.
Oh, no.
Hit me away from this woman!
Hit me away from her!
You should have hit me harder, Nia!
It wasn't enough for me.
Look at her!
How was I gonna beat that thing?
She literally beat the kid up.
She's out to seek tougher matches, someone who will just cause her pain.
Nia, in her defense.
She did explain what she was going to bring.
I don't know how I didn't win.
You could have hit me a bit harder, you know?
I wasn't feeling it.
I'm sorry, I wasn't hurting you.
To be fair, she literally waited for you to get back to the ring to hit her again.
So that's just embarrassing.
I have bad stamina, alright.
I'm a couch potato.
You're a couch potato?
How long?
Bears wear me out.
So, how old are you?
How long were you prepping for this tournament though?
I would assume like, at least two weeks.
Yeah, you know, I...
There was no catnip involved at all.
I wasn't just chilling.
You're not clean?
No, no, no, I am!
Oh my god.
I took my test.
I'm qualified.
Okay, alright.
I mean, it doesn't really matter.
She's already eliminated.
Oh my god.
There might have been some B-grade catnip right there.
I don't know where your dealer was.
Yeah, you might want to find someone else.
Yeah, you might, you know, I hear, you know, I know somebody.
You know?
Huh?
Yeah, I know somebody.
You know somebody?
And she's like, maybe right here in this room.
And I know she has a lot of catnip.
Bright mint.
I agree!
You have a cat!
Oh, you're right.
I do.
Do you not have catnip?
I do!
Cat, come to me.
Come to me now.
I'll hook you up.
Thank you.
Hold on.
Did you...
I forgot what I was gonna say.
I can't make it sound weird.
No, no, no.
Were you satisfied after this match?
Or are you longing for more?
I'm longing for more, mommy.
You're longing for more?
Woah!
Ladies...
Now I'm wondering if it was a mistake to have you as an interviewer.
No!
Listen, listen.
Well, non-congratulations.
I hope... I'm assuming that each tattoo you have on your body is each win that you have obtained in your career.
So where will your next tattoo go?
Oh, that's where I want them to hit me.
I'll put more on my body.
You know where?
Oh yeah, on my neck.
Oh, I also have hand tattoos on my neck too to show that where to choke me.
Oh, you know, you make it to day two.
You can easily edit, you know.
You can add that tattoo before day two comes on.
Call up your tattoo parlor and add that.
I'll call them right now.
That's some good confidence.
Yeah, that's...
We won...
I mean, if you win, you make it to day two, Anna.
Alright.
Okay, I'll try my best.
Whose dog was that?
Oh, my bad.
Sorry.
I thought it was you, Dokie.
Alright, guys.
It's off to the next matchup with Juna and Haka.
Is Haka actually here though?
Like, is he...
So, okay, I...
Wait, Haka's online.
I see Haka.
He's here, but he's not really here.
He told me.
He's taking a shit.
Oh, okay.
Oh!
Alright.
Wow.
Exposing Haka off the bat.
Okay.
Hey, Haka.
We got some TMI just here.
Is this from the bathroom?
Yeah, are you like in the bathroom, Haka?
Like, what the fuck?
No, I literally just got out.
Okay?
I literally...
You just got out.
Like, what's going on?
Can you repeat that?
My ears can't register.
Like, such a high-pitched voice.
Whoa.
What are you talking about?
What the fuck do you mean high-pitched voice?
Hello?
It's so high.
Oh my god, bro.
The wavelengths, bro.
I can't...
You're so short too.
Holy shit.
Damn.
I literally told you, hold up.
I'm taking a shit.
And then I took a shit and I was like, okay, ping me.
Was it a nervous shit?
Is that why you had a shit?
Oh yeah, absolutely.
When you're in a...
in a wrestling competition with, you know, fighting a fucking eel, you kind of have to like, you know, empty out the tank.
Yeah, why?
Because you're gonna be fucking over.
You're gonna be fucking over when I'm done with you.
Did you wash your hands?
Yeah, did you wash your hands?
By the way, you just got out.
Whoa, give me a sec.
I need to move.
I washed my hands like fucking medical style.
You know, like off to the fucking elbow.
Medical style?
Yeah.
What does that even mean?
You should have kept them dirty.
Medical style?
Grossed her out a little.
No, because I don't want to give her like, you know, like poison damage over time.
Poison damage?
It's all about like physical, like, you know, punching over here.
Yeah.
Wait, I thought like birds eat eels.
He's a tiny bird.
Yeah, I'm kidding.
Okay, to be fair, he is pretty tiny.
My tail is as tall as him.
You have to understand.
Sorry, this is the accurate height.
I'm sorry.
This is the accurate.
Yeah.
Sigh.
Oh, so who Who the fuck mirrored me in the announcement?
Why am I mirrored?
Why is my hair the other side?
Why am I awkward?
Look, it's all they have to match.
Yeah.
Really look at that and I was just like, whoa.
That's not me.
I hope we have a good fight.
I don't know if I'll win, but I'll try my best.
Where's the confidence?
It has to be a fair fight.
You know, we have to abide by the rules of nature.
Oh, you're right.
Predator versus predator.
Yeah.
What's the rules of nature?
Wait, but you're both predators.
Survival of the fittest.
Who's gonna win?
Me.
I'm kidding.
We saw what happened to the dinosaurs.
Did you already show them my gladiator?
You show them my gladiator?
What's the gladiator?
Bro, my fucking fighter is built as hell.
Is he short though?
Is he like short stock?
Nah, man.
He's fucking huge.
It's huge.
Haka, what do you mean he?
It's you.
Oh.
I like you.
Wow.
Well, you see, when you're a performer, you kind of have to find, you know, different options and that guy just looked at me funny and I was just like, hey, you wanna make 20 bucks?
Already admitting to fraud?
You should be confessing after the match, Haka.
So when you lose, you can be like, that wasn't me anyway.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm honest.
That's the cool thing about being an idol.
You have to be honest.
Yeah.
Okay.
As honest as I am that I took a shit before this.
Wow.
Alright, well, we'll see.
We'll see how you do in the match, Haka.
We'll see if the guy you paid off the guy you paid off...
He's gonna fucking destroy everyone.
He's gonna destroy the competition.
Oh my god.
I believe in you.
You got this.
I believe.
Alright, let's head off to the game.
We're gonna head off to the casters broadcast.
We'll see you guys in the ring.
We'll see you and the homeless guy in the ring.
Let's go, BD!
I love BD!
No, I don't.
No, don't say that!
Alright.
So, Min, can you turn up yourself a little bit more?
The sound guy's saying he wants to hear you more.
Oh, okay.
Hello.
That was enough?
I don't know.
My ears don't work as good.
Me neither.
Alright.
It seems...
Oh my god.
A lot of people think Haka's gonna win.
It's cause it's not him.
I mean, like, he's pretty short, right?
He has those heels on.
Let me see.
Yeah, I mean...
We'll see.
Again, it doesn't matter the size.
It matters kinda the agility.
I like how he's like 2D here.
Wait, why is Haka just...
What?
Why is he just himself?
Okay.
What the fuck?
He's so short.
Oh my god.
Oh, but it doesn't matter.
It doesn't fucking matter.
He does not need height.
No, exactly.
The taller they are, the harder they fall.
Exactly.
I mean, I don't think these...
I don't think any of these wrestlers are them.
Like, I think they both hide in the back.
I don't know.
I can't see the resemblance with Juna.
Who?
Like, the furry tail?
It feels like Juna just...
The furry tail?
Juna gave this random guy like $5 at Walmart to go crazy.
I don't know.
The budget cosplay.
Oh, guys.
I just realized we didn't do the intro, guys.
We were so...
Sorry, we got distracted by 2D Haka.
Alright, should we...
I mean, it's still early.
We can restart it.
We don't know who's gonna win.
Yeah, true, true, true.
Yeah, we don't know who's gonna win.
So we can restart this.
Guys, stop fighting, guys!
Guys, stop fighting!
This is not scripted.
They were...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We told them to stop.
Why is he 2D?
I don't know.
Something made him 2D.
I got distracted because he...
You didn't even realize that he was 2D.
I didn't either, yeah.
Just looking at him.
Just a standing man emoji there.
Haka, Haka, you were not winning.
Yeah, it's true.
You were absolutely not winning, Haka.
The following contest is scheduled for one fall!
Introducing first...
I like how he's friendly.
A bit dodgy!
That juda-u!
NAGI!
Woo!
The friendly ear lady!
Oh my... what?
I don't know, anything...
long and slippery.
I've seen those.
They're not very friendly.
What is this Riverdale shit?
Like the cab thing?
What do you mean Riverdale?
Like, did you not see that fucking close up?
And he's like...
Yeah, it was like a little fan service, you know?
Yeah, a little bit of fan... I mean...
To be fair, she was giving the sotchi.
This is the slowest walk, please can we pick it up?
Please, we have a scheduler!
Maybe we should have skipped the intros.
Why are you looking at the camera again?
Hahahaha!
She was just like, my eyes are here, ladies.
Yeah.
Wait, did you hear that?
That lady in the audience was like...
Yeah!
Hahahaha!
Wow, Juno, you have such a biggest fan over there!
Yeah!
Yes, girl, give us nothing!
Hahahaha!
That's how we like it!
Woo!
We have no standards!
Let's go!
Yeah, finally, a little bit of pizazz.
Whoa!
Finally!
Oh, wow!
I can like, imagine her to just be like...
Yeah!
And introducing their opponent!
Hailing from the bathroom where they just suck an enormous shit!
Oh!
Waka waka Benzo and Haka!
Woo!
At least Haka's giving us something.
Something?
Oh my god!
He's wearing a mask too!
Yeah.
Keep it on.
Hahahaha!
Ladies, he leaves all of that on!
Yeah.
Alright.
The crowd, I can't tell where the crowd is supporting right now, you know?
I like how his intro was like, like, one third of Gina's intro.
That's so...
Hahahaha!
Oh my god!
Alright.
Finally, we're back in it!
Oh!
Another throw!
From Haka!
What does the back of Gina's shirt say?
Family?
Family!
Just so all you guys know, the ones that had like, fan-created wrestlers, um, the talents themselves chose the wrestler.
So she specifically chose this guy that she paid off in the street.
Okay, okay, okay.
With family!
There's no family here.
I mean, Haka's still... Haka's winning, still.
I like how he's wrestling in flip-flops, though.
Oh, damn!
You're right!
Yeah!
This guy's ready to go to the beach!
Woo!
Oh!
The kick to the head!
What do you call that, Mint?
What do you call this move?
That was the...
That was the screwy McDooey.
The screwy McDooey?
Live in WrestleTuber?
Yeah!
I thought that was a myth, Mint!
Nope.
It was real.
And, you know, Haka is really proving himself.
What is this?
What the fuck?
I call that the Humpty Dumpty.
Oh no!
Ian did have a great fall!
He swinged out...
She swinged that leg out, hoping that Humpty Dumpty would get me pieced back together again.
How did you miss?
That was huge!
That's true.
Haka, put on your glasses, Haka!
Get back in the ring, guys!
You don't want to get eliminated like Nia!
Yeah!
Oh!
In the dick!
If she had one...
I think it was the stomach.
You mean the dick is not there?
It's all connected, I guess.
Oh, nice.
At least she put him back in the ring.
She could've... She should've left him at home.
She could've left him outside the ring, though.
They could've easily, you know, won by the default.
Yeah.
But no, this is a fair...
Haka said he wanted a fair game, so...
That's true.
They're back outside the ring.
Woah!
Cutscene!
Oh yeah, these people right here are getting a good show!
Yeah, he's hyping the crowd up!
He's like, do you like what you see?
They're like, yeah!
Haka's toes!
What?
They're out!
For free!
They're not censored!
Guys!
Four...
Alright, come on!
Jump on!
Yeah!
Ah!
Oh my god!
She's definitely gonna need a doctor tomorrow.
Yeah.
And a medical fee.
I wonder if Limeu's chiropractic service is open.
I mean, she's eliminated, so it should be open by now.
She needs one too.
She needs the money, guys.
Wait, what number are they at?
Four.
Four!
Juna, get up, Juna!
Get up, Juna!
Oh no!
I like how Juna was like, indecisive there.
She's like, do I pick him up?
Or do I like, push him?
Two!
Two the audience?
Woah!
The audience is definitely getting their tickets worth.
Yeah.
This is, this was, but it's free for everybody watching at home!
Yeah, it's free for you guys!
No pay-per-view!
Yeah!
Right here!
On Doki Bird Network.
What the fuck was that?
The B-D-N.
I mean, D.
I think you're missing an S there.
I'm a little dyslexic.
A little.
Wait,
one!
Two!
Oh!
Haka got out!
Haka, you were winning!
How did you fucking get pinned already?
Oh my god, she's measuring the cranium again?
Okay.
Oh, choking.
Oh!
The elbow to the stomach!
And the kick!
Oh my god.
She's like, I'm a sucker.
I'm a sucker, baby.
This is the, this is the pay me like you're French lady.
The infamous pay me like the French lady?
I thought that move was reserved for only Leo!
I thought it was banned!
Are all these moves apparently banned?
Oh god, Haka's making a B right now!
He's using this B for his new song!
Oh, another one!
One!
Two!
The winner
is Haka!
And here is your winner!
Oh, waka waka!
Benzo and HAKA!
Oh, Juna better stick to interviewing.
Yeah, Juna.
I don't think wrestling was for you, man.
Nah.
Bro, he was like, he was like making a B and everything too.
You saw that?
Yeah!
He was really revving up the crowd!
Alright, let's go to the interview to talk to to talk to the loser and the winner.
Oh, she's already there.
She has to be there.
Alright, I'll see you there.
Alright.
I don't get paid enough.
What can I say?
I fucking warned you.
I'm sorry.
Juna, how could you lose?
You literally watched so many games.
Oh, sorry.
The guy that I paid is useless and worthless and...
Uh-huh.
That sounds like a lot of excuses.
Guys...
Well, I'm gonna need some other criticism besides just from a lot of excuses.
I need like actual criticism, Doki.
You've been using that one a lot, Doki.
Haka, how do you feel winning against Juna there?
It feels great, you know?
The blood of my fucking enemies in my hand.
It feels great.
You're gonna have to watch him again.
Again?
I think he hasn't even...
I'm a medium, you know?
I possess him.
I possess his fucking ass.
I thought you meant medium-sized.
I was so confused.
No, that's good.
After all, medium is premium.
But yeah, I possess his fucking ass.
I beat the shit out of you, bro.
How do you feel about that?
I don't know if I should feel honored, but it was an experience.
I can't believe I got beat by a twink.
That only happens like once in your life.
Are you saying, Juna, that you threw so you had that honor to say that you were beat by a twink?
I like how Haka was just speechless.
He didn't even know what to say to that.
Haka, do you need like five minutes to think of a comeback?
Hold up, I'm like...
I am sitting down here realizing what you just said.
I'm just like trying to think of like wow, this is my life after all, you know?
I could have been...
I could have been more than this.
I could give you swimming lessons too if you really need them.
I remember that story.
Your swimming story.
Hey bro, shut the fuck up.
What is the story?
Share with the class.
I got chased by a fucking crab and I almost drowned.
What the... what?
What?
You got chased by a crab?
A crab.
A crab literally chased me and I almost drowned.
Wow.
Maybe you shouldn't have shared that story to the class.
Maybe I shouldn't have shared that story, huh?
Look how they're still trash talking even though Juno lost.
I'm not trash talking.
It's banter.
You know at the end of the day, Juno might have lost the battle.
But she won the war.
Let me tell you that.
The mental war.
The mental warfare.
Well, thank you again Haka and Juno for that exciting match.
We are going to do a small intermission here.
It's time for Mint to be rotated.
Well, me and Mint to be rotated out in the casting table.
So we're gonna have a set of new casters joining in for half of bracket two and bracket three.
Thank you guys for joining in.
For the first half.
Thank you for having us.
Thank you guys.
Thank you for joining.
Thank you.
Alright, we're gonna be going to intermission now.
We'll see you guys in five to ten minutes.
Bye bye guys.
See you in five to ten minutes.
Bye bye.
Bye bye guys.
Hello everybody!
And welcome back to WrestleTuber!
I will be stepping out from... I'll be rotated out as a caster and I'll be taking a little break now.
But, as we know, we have several casters for WrestleTuber.
And they will be taking over the over for me and Mint.
So, why don't we welcome Gerard and Octavio!
Yeah!
Hello!
Get rotated!
Why are you so mellow?
I...
I don't want to show my face on screen anymore for a bit.
I just fucking lost.
And...
I don't want to be here anymore.
I thought I'd be winning.
I'm just gloating all over the place.
But no!
I'm just... God damn it!
Hello guys!
Hello everybody!
My name is Gerard T.
Rexford and I am Holostars English's devilishly handsome bounty hunter and the leader of the Armistice Unit.
And today I am joined by my co-host over here.
I am the opulent, optatonic, operatic puppeteer from Bounty Hunter Armistice of Holostars English.
My name is Octavio!
Hello!
Hello, hello.
By the way, we practice an intro.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
We totally did not.
Hello!
Mina-san.
Well...
We're already fumbling.
Doki, this was not part of the plan!
Why'd you throw us in here?
Now we know!
Guys, here's the bracket.
This is like a very, very big dream come true to join WWE because this has been also a part of my childhood.
And yeah, thank you, thank you very much Doki.
For letting us participate in this match.
Even though I fucking lost.
You know, it's still a great opportunity to like be able to participate in a massive event such as this.
So thank you, thank you.
Yeah, thank you, thank you.
This is better than the WWE because it's VTubers!
Yeah, VTubers edition!
It's a bunch of weirdos.
And I never thought I'd be joining in an actual match!
You know, technically this counts.
You know?
Like, uh... And that was your last match too.
Yeah, it was my last.
It's not an actual television, but hey, it's YouTube everybody!
It's technically television at the same time.
I'd like to say hi to my mom and friends out there.
Oh my god.
They're all dead!
Yeah, oh yeah, they're dead!
65 million years ago!
No, no, no, no, don't remind me!
But anyway, let's look at the bracket, shall we?
Let's look at the bracket.
Okay, okay.
So, we just finished with a matchup of, um...
uh...
Juno Unagi and Banzo Inhaka.
Our senpai!
Yeah, congratulations to Banzo Inhaka for actually winning that one.
Yeah, congrats.
It was totally unexpected because according to Octavio, like right before we even went to here, he didn't even believe in his senpai.
He said, oh my god, I didn't even think Haka would pass because all the stars are fucking weak.
And you got that fucking ball.
Bro!
You have to, like, root for us!
Honestly, the only one I believe in is myself!
And no one else.
Bro.
Everybody dunk on him if he fucking loses, alright?
Congratulations, Haka, you cheater.
You cheated in some way.
But hey, all the stars represent they won.
Congratulations though to the, uh...
remaining participants who actually won.
So thank you.
And now up next is Fillion and Remilia.
They are gonna be scheduled for the next match.
So, are you guys ready to rumble?
I think they are.
Let's wait, let's wait.
They need to respond via chat.
Say yes.
They need to match my energy.
There we go.
Match my energy.
Are you ready to rumble?
Yeah!
Octavio, come on!
What am I supposed to say?
I am ready to rumble!
Yes, we are ready!
So let us now proceed to the 1v1 interview section.
Yoink!
Wait, um...
I think we need to move.
I was chilling in the interview while we...
Sorry, let me move out real quick, guys.
Oh my god.
We're walking.
Currently walking towards the interview room.
There we go.
We finally made it.
I had to use my legs.
Alright.
Okay.
So, let us bring in the people!
Peeps, show yourselves!
The people!
Why am I just a PNG?
We're all PNGs.
Except the casters, please.
What the fuck do you want?
We have two forums.
PNGs and live2dv.
Hey, this looks nice.
This WWE tournament is very nice.
Don't you dare diss on it.
It's very nice.
It's very well produced.
Who do you think you are?
You're fully animated.
You got the effing budget behind you.
What is this, man?
I have casting perms, alright?
You are PNGs.
You're literally just about to fight.
I'm a caster too!
Unless Dogefire made me.
Oh wait, you are.
Yeah.
Well, it's not your turn, so shut up!
Oh no.
Okay, what are we doing?
What are we doing?
Oh, I'm so sorry to interrupt you and Remilia.
So, how are you guys feeling?
I'm ready to smash her face into the floor and then deliver like Amazon Prime straight back to...
I don't know where she lives, but she's going there.
Oh my god!
You're just gonna accept that?
Remi, what's your response?
Hey, I know, I know I come in tiny size, but breaking your kneecaps is my forte.
Listen, listen.
I've got power of darkness and light on my side.
Lakes, fashion, and speed.
I know I'm vertically challenged, but I'm standing taller than you right now in this room!
Oh, you think you're so tall?
How tall are you?
I'm 139!
139!
I'm tall!
Oh my god, they're clipping through the set!
Oh no!
Are you okay?
Wait, you look flat as frick!
Blow, blow!
The match hasn't even started yet!
It only hurts!
I may be flat, okay, but my butt is packing.
What about you?
What do you bring in the picture?
I bring in a Mastermind IQ.
Frank!
Frank, stupid!
Stupid!
Flat, flat, stupid!
It's like an elementary school fight right here.
I am a CEO of a business!
Oh, you got a boob on your nose!
Oh, you got a poopy on your butt!
Okay.
Yeah!
Elementary-style fighting, Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
So who do you guys think is gonna win today's match?
Well, I...
Can I hear their war cries?
I'll do it.
Give me a roar.
Can I please hear a war cry from both of you guys?
Let me go first.
Whoa!
Roar!
Okay.
Okay, that was strangely adorable.
That's like a solid 8 out of 10.
I'm so scared.
10 out of 10 intimidating.
Holy shit.
I was channeling your inner Senzala.
Rar!
XT nuzzled, pounces on you.
Ooh, you so warm.
I'll show you real warm.
You ready?
I'm getting attacked!
Ah, brain damage!
Oh!
Oh, damn.
Now the psychic damage.
God, I, uh, I thought I'm stupid, but I guess God made you an exception.
Oh!
Okay.
She called you stupid!
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, with a pot calling the kettle black, dog.
I mean, look at you.
You're effing stupid, you're short, you're flat, we're the same person.
Guys, guys!
The twins!
Yo!
It's like a dip is fighting itself.
I think this is...
I think this is personal now.
Are we doing it You are more than your flatness.
Bro, stop projecting, bro!
Stop it, man.
What are you, a Twitter user?
What the frick?
Are you fighting for real?
I am, I am shocked.
For real?
Alright, let's go.
Let's go.
I am fucking shocked.
You know what, forget this heavy WWE stuff, drop the Addy.
Nerd.
Well, well, it seems like they're ready to fight, so... Okay.
Okay, let's take it to the ring.
Are you guys ready?
Because we are gonna transition to the actual match now.
Do I get to go or do I beat her up?
Up.
Okay, nevermind, sorry.
There you go, there we go.
Whoa!
Sorry, sorry, that was my lunch break.
Sorry, I didn't realize you guys were gonna be here too.
The melee...
You just keep bothering her.
Sorry, guys.
I was just chilling here.
You need to go backstage.
I didn't realize you guys were gonna be here too.
Like...
What was I supposed to do?
I was supposed to know that.
Guys, okay, give me a sec.
Go to the break room.
Hey, what?
This...
There is no break room.
Did you not see what Nero and Zendaya did to that break room?
Let us in!
Let me in!
Let me inside!
We're knocking on this door!
Let us in!
Give me a sec, guys, I just need a...
Let me in!
Guys, be fucking patient, guys!
Oh my god!
You told us to cast!
Be patient!
I didn't find the key to the...
I need to find the key, guys!
It's so bad, get out!
Give me a sec, I'm trying to find the key!
Give me a sec!
What is taking so long?
Guys!
I forgot!
I forgot where the key is!
Security!
Oh, you're...
You're not...
This is why we have day two, guys.
I thought you actually prepared it, you're still...
You're still setting it up.
So that's what's taking so long, Jesus Christ.
Guys, this is why we have day two.
This is why we have day two.
Don't worry, guys, day two will be even better.
Day two, everything will be... Wait, I'm still bouncing around.
You can tell I'm doing this all by myself.
No promises.
Doing great so far.
Guys, I'm just trying to find Gerard right now.
There he is.
There you go.
I like it.
Here you are.
Alright, we're in, baby!
We got in!
Back to the break room I go.
Finally.
Finally, we can see the matchup between Fillion and Remilia!
Bro, look at their...
Look at their models here.
The wrestlers.
What is that?
Oh my god.
Fillion reminds me of a feral ghoul in Fallout.
What is that?
Remilia's hair.
What's that supposed to be?
White meat.
Looks like an elephant.
The following contest...
One in a billion...
Fillion!
We got kicked out.
Uh oh.
We disappeared from existence.
Help!
Let us in!
We can't commentate!
Oh no!
Let us in!
Okay, okay.
Let's go!
Oh, that's cute though.
That's cute.
Let's go, Fillion, Filipino boy!
I don't know why they call Fillion that way.
Let's fucking go!
Damn, she's dancing.
That is some heavy moves right there.
Do you think that will pack a punch when it comes to the ring though?
I don't know.
If you ask me, they will better need the moves.
The moves?
Yeah, the moves.
Fillion here...
A true Terpsichorean.
Just showing it off!
BAM!
Wow!
Total confidence!
What the hell?
He's hitting that Gritty!
What is that move?
That Ney-Ney!
Woo!
Oh my god!
We have a performer here, everybody.
Is this a dance battle?
What's going on here?
Introducing their opponent!
Oh shit, someone's in Canada.
Hailing from Canada!
The smallest, yet greatest idea!
Romelia!
Super Transite Babu Babu!
What is that name?
Oh, the flag of Canada behind!
Oh!
What the...
Oh, the outfit!
It's like a maid outfit!
Well, she's made for this.
Look at that swagger!
Do we have a poll in the chat?
Who do you think will win?
She's the most swaggy angel I've ever seen.
Fillion or Romelia?
You're wrestling.
Bruh.
I'm looking at two screens right now.
Here we go.
I like the color scheme here.
Yeah, very elegant moves though.
Reminds me of the good old...
the good old...
Canada.
Oh Canada.
Why are they all doing dance moves?
Did they plan this out?
They're doing dance moves!
Why are they doing this?
This is gonna be a dance battle.
Battle of the dancing with the stars.
I will be super disappointed if it isn't like dance moves.
That they're like swinging at each other.
Ooh!
Hey yo!
Whoa!
Look at that flexibility!
Damn, damn, damn.
She's got rubber bands for arms and legs.
Just showing off that flexibility to the crowd.
Stretching those hamstrings.
Showing that they are not meant to be...
Grinding as well?
What the heck?
Wow.
Wow, given that...
And it doesn't end there.
It just keeps going.
Oh finally, the match is starting.
They perform.
They're on stage performers in a sense.
They're technically on stage performers.
No, this is real.
This is a real fight.
They're not fake!
And the match begins!
Oh my god!
Immediately!
With a running attack!
And with a counter right there.
Bouncing off!
And got caught!
And an attack!
Oh!
I thought that was gonna be a combo!
That must have hurt.
And they're doing a six twister.
She's so aggressive already at the start!
What?
An arm bar everybody!
And a submission!
And a round away!
Oh, kick to the leg!
Oh!
Ah, that hurts!
Look at those combos, man!
A sound blow blows from...
Oh, close line!
A close line!
Yes!
It's the only move I know!
One!
Two!
Ah, no, no, no.
Still too early.
Too early, too early.
But you know, that would be funny though if they actually got a pin!
Whoa!
Reversal!
They're taking turns here!
Focusing on the hands!
Gonna injure that hand!
And knee to the face!
That's gotta hurt!
I gotta say, that's a pretty smart move actually.
Like aiming for the arms because they can't actually grapple nor punch anyone else if they actually damage the arms.
True, true.
They can grab the rope when you pin them too.
Oh!
A flying attack!
And a DDT!
Damn!
It was an elbow!
It was an elbow.
The subverting expectations.
Oh, a kick!
Oh, is that allowed?
What's going on?
Oh!
Everyone's doing some flashy moves!
Yeah, everybody's like somersaulting.
One!
Two!
Oh, I thought that was already it.
That was so anti-climactic if that ever happened.
Damn.
And he escaped!
Oh, shit!
Trying to run away from the responsibilities, huh?
Pretty familiar.
Reversal.
Let's see if you can fly away with this one, with those wings of yours.
And carrying!
Oh, someone's bleeding!
That drew some blood!
First blood!
Fillion is bleeding from the nose.
Oh!
One of those things again.
The complicated Remilia and Fillion fight is already intense.
There's already blood gushing out through the ring.
And are they gonna get counted out?
Five seconds!
Five seconds until...
One gets decided to be the victor.
Throw inside the ring.
Oh.
What's gonna happen?
Reversal, please?
Is that a finisher?
Oh, it wasn't a finisher.
It's a pin!
What a flashy pin!
That was quick!
Too quick!
Throwing it.
And another one!
Could you please stop hitting me on the neck?
Oh, another pin!
It's a submission!
Damn, but it was able to grapple free.
I mean, get free.
I've only been seeing big bodied men fighting.
But I've never seen these builds before fight.
Correct me if I'm wrong, but I think this is the first very fast paced kind of movement fight.
Yeah, yeah.
We got thin representation from Fillion right now.
Everybody's big, bulky, and muscly.
Oh shit, that's gotta hurt.
It...
Oh, reversal!
Dropkick, what is gonna happen?
Come on, come on!
Oh, dropkick!
Oh my god, that hurts!
That might be it!
She's waiting for the finisher!
The default finisher!
Yeah!
And here it is!
Kick to the face!
That might be it!
Is this it for Fillion?
Are they gonna win?
One, two, What?
Ayo, fucking double!
Let's go!
Another pin!
Is this it?
Two!
She's so strong!
Escape the wall!
Missed that dive!
Unfortunately.
Sponsored by Gamersups, everybody.
Ah!
Oh!
Pin!
Reversal!
Is this it?
One!
Two!
Oh!
Fillion is actually stronger than she looks!
As a dancer, her limbs are very limber.
Two finishers isn't enough to bring one down.
This is a very fast-paced battle.
It is, it's like watching an anime fight.
Oh!
Here we go again!
Whoa!
What is that athleticism?
Flexibility on this play.
That was something.
It was nice.
Very nice.
Emilia escaping through the turnbuckles.
Throwing him again.
What is this technique?
Oh!
This is crazy!
How can one person have such athleticism?
And agility.
Everyone here is a high-flyer!
And a pin!
A pin!
Is this a finisher?
Is this it?
One!
Two!
Three!
There's nothing!
They counted out.
This is still anybody's game!
Anybody!
Oh!
Another finisher!
Wait for that finisher.
They missed!
Oh no!
Excuse me.
Okay.
I'm having trouble breathing.
That's a body slap.
Okay.
Wait, let me mute.
Oh!
He is about...
Gerard, my co-caster, is about to die.
Apparently.
Oh!
High-flyer Emilia!
I'm about to puke.
There's so much energy going on.
I can't help it!
Ah!
Breathe!
I'm breathing!
Oh shit!
Is this it?
If you don't breathe, Gerard, I'm gonna pin you down!
Oh!
That's the same finisher that I got wiped!
Oh shit!
Hit to the back.
I'm so disrespectful!
You could've pinned him already!
But no, you had to do it outside!
Why?
The disrespect is immense!
Can we please just end this?
Oh, someone's...
Whee!
The angel flew around the billion there.
Why?
The disrespect.
Put an end to it, please!
They're still fighting inside...
No, outside.
They have to get inside or else they're both gonna be disqualified.
What's the count?
Five!
It's five seconds!
Oh shit, is this it?
You have to knock him out.
Stun him!
And that's it!
Yeah, one more stun.
Why'd you bring it in?
No!
Come on!
That was a missed opportunity, but that's a pin!
It's a pin!
It could work!
Might work!
One... two... three!
The winner!
One!
Here is your winner!
One in a billion!
Billion!
That was fucking intense.
That was a really good fight.
Everyone was like flying!
They were like throwing punches, like throwing kicks.
Everyone was throwing each other at... whatever.
That was fucking fun.
Holy crap, we got that massive flex.
We got high fliers.
And that match is a rating out of... Everything was great.
Four out of five.
Amazing.
Thank you everybody so much!
The karaoke machine is rated four out of five stars.
Okay!
Here we are at the interviewer's table.
How does it feel?
Oh, hello!
How does it feel to beat the... child?
Why'd you guys freeze it like that?
Oh my god.
Listen, okay?
Stairs are a hell of a drug.
I'm not trying to say anything, but it was easier than it looked.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, wow.
I mean, looking at the match, it seemed very close.
I don't know.
Well, you know, I like to put on a good show at the end of the day.
You know, it's a little bit about giving them a bit of a chance, so...
The content.
I get it.
This makes sense.
Yeah, yeah.
I was standing back in the start so I could come back in the ninth.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, I get it.
Yo, yo.
Hold on.
Yeah, so, Whammy, are you okay?
The devil may cry, but I cry harder.
No!
You made her cry, Fillion!
Chat, why is she like this?
I can't... It's all your fault.
I can't... You made this baby...
How does it feel like bullying a little girl, huh?
It's good content.
You happy?
I'm a kick streamer.
What do you want from me?
I hope you sleep well tonight.
You know what?
You have a nice day.
Wow, these threats.
Very threatening.
That's very polite.
Very polite.
Very sportsmanlike.
Don't worry.
I'm more than open.
After you.
I don't believe it.
Oh, yeah.
That was peak content, everybody.
Unfortunately.
Everyone was flying.
It was almost...
That was a really good fight.
Yeah, it was very close, though.
Like, everyone was flying, throwing punches and kicks.
And I honestly thought, like, there were moments like, oh, shit.
Fillion's gonna win.
And, oh, shit.
Ramil's gonna win.
They were all throwing out their finishers.
And, holy shit.
Only one came up on top, though.
But, yeah.
Congratulations to you, Fillion.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Congrats.
Yeah.
You did amazing.
Even if you are a child beater, but you...
You can't turn that beat script on me.
Is it 20 to 1 or is it going to be 20?
I don't want to be here anymore.
What do you mean?
Not the child abuse.
Stop it.
I did it.
That's not even my fault.
Stop it.
Why did you pull me against the camera?
You did.
You did it again.
What do you expect?
La la la.
I am not hearing any of these.
La la la la.
Yeah.
You know what you sound like?
Oh, okay.
What?
That's what you sound like.
Oh, my God.
Peak trash talk.
The trash talk is insane.
And, yeah.
But that was very entertaining.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you guys so much for that.
The match was really fun.
Thank you.
And I can't wait to see what...
I'm going to do some more gear.
Yeah.
I can't wait for the next matchup.
Like, holy goodness.
Who else is up there?
Who is the next matchup?
See you guys in the finals.
Goodbye forever.
Bye.
Bye bye.
Okay.
Oh.
What's the next matchup here?
I need to know.
It's getting blocked by the assets.
Thank you.
This is behind the scenes right now.
Sorry.
Thank you for whoever is operating.
Our next behind the scenes is coming in at the moment.
Sorry.
We had some little technical difficulties.
But here is the next matchup for you guys.
Okay.
So the next match.
Everybody, please.
One for her assistance, please.
Please.
Thank you.
She needs help.
Next match is going to be...
Oh, my God.
Next matchup is going to be another Hall of Stars member.
Another Hall of Stars member.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my goodness.
Not to be biased or anything.
But Shinri, you have to win.
Win Shinri.
Hall of Stars represent, baby.
Let's fucking go.
Good luck to you too, Nagare Sara.
Sora.
Wait.
How do I read that?
My eyes are weak.
We have my eyes.
Is that Sora or Sara?
Wait.
Sara.
Sharescreen.
There we go.
Nagare Sara.
Good luck to both contestants!
And I wish them nothing but godspeed.
For the interview?
Hello?
Where is your man?
Oh.
Oh no.
Shinri!
No!
Not like this!
After we glazed you like that!
Bro!
You gotta be here!
Oh no!
He won't be available today.
Oh he has a video!
Oh no no wait.
No no no.
We have him.
He's here guys.
He's behind the scenes.
He's pinging in right now.
He's here.
He's here guys.
Behind the scenes.
He's pinging in.
He's at the area.
Can we get him in the voice call right now?
I love it when my senpais are present.
Bring in the Jumbotron.
Where is it?
Okay let's get that voice pack going.
Hello?
Shinri?
Sara?
Is that how he sounds?
It's me.
I'm real fine.
The illness has forever been the same.
He's been sick recently right?
I think so yeah.
Okay.
Shinri.
I think he's a little bit sick.
Forgive us guys.
He's just a little bit out of the weather.
Yeah.
There's kind of an epidemic going on in the Hall of Stars.
Introduce yourself Shinri.
Despite your sickness.
Yeah.
Do you think...
I can't understand what you're fucking saying!
I can't understand!
Everybody quiet!
What's wrong?
Introduce yourself man!
What?
What's the other frequencies of your voice?
Sara do you think we can get a translation?
Yeah.
Joe, Suichi, Shinri.
Hey Hall of Stars.
Ronan.
Ronan Hall of Stars.
That's me.
Alright.
Well may I try and translate that to everyone who can't get anything under a base level.
Yes please.
My name's Joe, Suichi, Shinri and I'm gonna get my ass kicked.
Oh!
Are you really gonna take that Shinri?
Come on!
Hey listen I don't appreciate that.
I don't like that you said that about me.
Oh I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Why are you so polite?
Damn!
Alright Shinri you're gonna first.
Smack talk him Sara!
No I'm Joe, Suichi, Shinri.
I don't smack talk.
You say you're a dick.
There are two kinds of people that we're looking at here.
So there's two different situations.
Like if we walked onto a plane Shinri.
I would be a pilot and you would be a passenger.
I'm an innovator.
You're an imitator.
I'm a leader and you are...
You're a follower.
See I'm a winner.
And everyone else here are losers.
For believing in one thing.
They believe that Joe, Suichi, Shinri can beat me.
At my own game.
Are you kidding me?
Oh my god.
I'm the best.
At being a pilot?
A pilot?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna fly this plane.
And land it directly into that ring.
On top of that ego.
Because I am going to smash it down into a crisp.
Woah.
What is this?
This is a response to you.
This was a war game.
Reverse dissing.
I just don't understand.
You said you're a good pilot.
And apparently it's got love on the ring.
I don't understand.
And everyone's gonna come out safely onto the tarmac.
It's a metaphor.
It's a metaphor Shinri.
Okay that's surpassed my knowledge.
He's a little bit sick.
I'm sorry guys.
A little bit slow.
Hey I'm not slow.
I'm fast.
I'm gonna be the quickest one in the ring.
I guess we'll find out in the match whether you're slow or fast.
The only way that you're getting out of this ring is by tapping out or passing out.
See my wrestler is a fusion of myself and a very aggressively bogan snake.
And once this boa constricts you, that's it.
Wow.
Well the only way you're heading out of this ring is by ambulance.
What happened to the nice guy Shinri?
I thought you were...
What happened?
Nobody says that about me.
Yeah I'll be in the ambulance trash talking you while you're in the stretcher.
So let's see how it goes alright Shinri?
Let's save the trash talk act for later alright?
Yeah sounds good.
Great.
I'm Josuichi Shinri.
Definitely Josuichi Shinri here.
That is him.
I can vouch for him.
Shinri kindly give a koinichiwa to your fans watching here right now for you.
That is how it goes.
Oh yeah absolutely.
Koinichiwa everybody.
Josuichi Shinri here to do a fight and ready to go.
Feeling great.
Feeling fresh.
Yeah let's fucking go.
Let's fucking go everybody!
The match of the century between a plane and a ronin.
Let's see who comes out first.
A plane and a ronin.
That's what I got from the entire conversation.
Sorry.
I am flak on.
Let's go back into the ring.
Let's go!
And the next match.
Bulk Bogan and Shinri.
What the?
What in the scuba diver?
Why is there a scuba diver here?
Shinri what happened?
What?
What is that pose?
Bulk Bogan on that huge bulk.
And Shinri diving in that deep.
My goodness.
Bulk Bogan in a pilot outfit too?
Damn.
I gotta say though, Shinri is on Brad because he's creeping up on them opponents like sneaky style.
Like one of his horror games.
He's into that one, right?
The following contest is scheduled for one fall!
Introducing first...
Oh shit we got a toxic man.
Representing...
Someone harder than the Sahara...
From where things get gory...
The gory Sarah...
BULK!
BULK BOOGOOOOON!
Thank you so much announcer Thank you so much announcer, that was great.
Thank you thank you...
And I can't help but look at the fucking toxic one in the jumbo truck.
Look at that what the hell?
Very vocal about the intentions here.
Out here to destroy Shinri.
Poison... Just poison air.
Not joking around.
Bulk Bogan showing up!
And oh my god!
With a thunderous entrance.
Squatting down.
And announcing to the world that he is the...
She is here!
Bulk Bogan better be thankful that she's not a ghost.
Oh my goodness.
This character reminds me...
Yeah, it reminds me of like...
Hercules.
Oh my god.
What is this?
Intense.
What are you doing?
Go to the ring!
You need to walk!
An intimidation factor towards Shin...
Oh, what the hell?
Ayo!
Someone's crawling too!
What the...
Is that the impersonation of a snake?
What's going on?
Is that how a pilot walks?
Oh...
Come on man, fly!
Fly!
Come on, move!
They're not moving.
This is probably the longest...
Fly towards the ring!
Like you said!
There we go.
The landing sure is something.
big necktie.
It's really wide.
The short shorts be doing something.
Oh wow, wow.
Oh, what the...
Oh, look at that gato.
You get that zettai ryoiki?
Bro!
Ayo.
They're still sticking to the animalistic behavior though.
This is a really long intro.
Yes it is.
There's a lot of parts to this choreography.
Oh!
Oh wow, wow!
Getting the crowd pumped.
Hehehe.
What she's gonna probably do to Shinri is a pump and dump.
Is what I'm talking about.
Oh ho ho ho ho!
Okay!
A quick pump and dump him down.
I hope that's the finisher of their moves.
Oh no, I think Shinri might mistake her for a...
for a monster or something.
For a ghost or ghoulie.
What is happening here?
It's still going on?
What the hell?
Oh my god!
You're still crawling?
Stop it!
We get it!
Hahaha!
Rrrr!
I'm... I'm... I'm a pilot.
That's definitely not good for her back.
There's still... okay.
Okay, is it done?
Oooh!
Oh wow, there's a zoom out too.
You gotta have to do a chromia.
Kinda.
Oh wow.
It's still going!
She's gonna crawl again.
Look at her.
Hahaha!
I swear to god if we went into commercial break right now, it's still going.
Yeah, yeah.
Here we go!
Introducing their opponent...
on a boy failure spree, the bloated rodent...
Josuiji Shinri!
Rrrr!
I got shot there.
Ow.
Why'd you have to say that now, sir?
I like how I see his briefs.
Hahaha!
And there's a shirt saying KO!
Declaring victory right at once.
Without even saying it.
It's his coin!
It's an upside down eye!
We got like a fishnet!
Fishnet!
Oh wow!
Oh Shinri.
Yep, Shinri does that on the daily.
Shinri... showing up.
And...
He'd be on that hip set grind set.
Hahaha!
And finally are we up to the match?
Who's gonna win?
Will Shinri be able to snorkel his way to victory?
Shinri versus Sora!
Let's go!
And already at the grapple.
The referee!
What the fuck are you doing, referee?
Referee's just running around.
And immediately, first one to the ground is Sara!
Kick into the chest.
Chest?
I don't know.
Kidney, kidney, there we go.
You know about that.
You know stuff about kidneys, right?
Yeah, I...
Can produce stones?
Kidney stones?
Okay, okay, that's enough.
That's enough, Octavio.
That's enough.
We're here for Shinri and Sara.
Okay, okay.
We're not here to talk about my medical history.
Thank you very much.
Oh!
Knee to the face!
Ooh!
Disrespect!
Kicks!
Three consecutive kicks!
Ooh!
Ow!
Focusing on the arm.
Ooh!
Damn!
Kind in the streets!
Shinri is very aggressive with these blows!
And a knee to the body as well!
Ah, wee.
Ah!
That's a disrespect!
That snorkeling truly has been helpful for him.
It just keeps going!
This is one-sided.
One-sided matchup.
And all that gloating a while ago... Come on, Sara!
Sara, what happened to the landing part?
You never landed!
You're crashing down!
Try!
And ooh!
Ah!
Ooh, not the fingies!
The fingies and to the back!
Ooh!
And the back!
Ooh, those psoas muscles are gonna hurt tomorrow.
Ah, miss!
Oh, miss the dive!
Possibly a counter by Sara.
Got up.
Grapple!
Kick to the stomach!
And a throw!
It's a throw!
Oh!
It's a weird suplex thing.
Another grapple!
And knee to the face!
Knee to the face in his face!
A beautiful face of Shinri.
A comeback is probably imminent.
Ooh, submission.
Oh!
No!
It wasn't a submission.
It was a slam to the arms.
Aiming for those weak spots.
That would have resulted in a dislocated shoulder for Shinri.
Oh, what is happening?
What is happening?
I don't even get to see it, but that's probably painful.
Hey, that's foul.
You know Shinri has aches and...
Oh!
Using the corner like that!
Is it?
Oh, and the... didn't even consider the counts.
Nice, nice.
Shoulders up.
Shinri's still pumping up with life.
Look at this heel hook!
And taking off the shoes!
He's still full of life.
Sara, what are you doing?
Don't take off the shoes, please!
Please don't!
Stop!
Stop taking his kicks!
We know what happens when the shoes come off!
You see the toes!
You see the stinky!
Oh!
Ow!
Sniffle, sniffle!
Oh!
Surprisingly athletic!
We have Sara here!
He can breathe through those feet!
I didn't think you'd be doing those types of moves.
Oh!
Grab him!
Sara with the advantage!
Got a counter!
Nice reversal!
And missed!
He missed the clothesline!
He's blind!
Shinri, come on!
And they flew out!
Okay, so...
Okay, follow up.
You need to remove your snorkeling gear!
You can't see!
I think that's gonna debuff your uh... your movement, buddy!
Oh!
Ow!
Face to the mat!
They really do love fighting outside!
Don't they, Octavio?
Yeah, yeah.
They really like it outside in the air.
And the fucking taunt is insane!
Sara!
In front of the crowd!
Hyping up the crowd!
I don't know if they're booing or not!
Oh!
CPR!
So fucking sinister!
We got CPR going on!
Two inches deep!
Bruh.
Hit in the center!
Okay, we go back to the ring.
This is actually a very even fight.
I'm not sure who will win.
Yeah, me too.
I don't know.
They're like doing a back and forth here.
I think that's gonna be a common theme from now on, considering probably the best fighters are gonna be at the last segment of the show.
Oh!
Maybe.
You think?
Oh!
Owie!
They really do like fighting in the corners, huh?
Oh!
Ah!
What is that?
That required so much strength to do!
Was that a finisher?
Oh no!
They have really good endurance though.
Just the one count.
Yeah, just the one count.
Every time they pin, it's just one.
And a throw!
Suplex!
Suplex city!
Okay.
What's happening?
Ooh!
Analyzing the competition.
Knee to the face.
You love to see it.
Is this a finisher?
Is this it?
Oh man!
Oh no it isn't!
Throwing on the ropes.
It's just a rope choke.
Look at this!
What is happening?
Ooh!
Submission!
Submission move.
That's gotta hurt.
That hurts the hamstrings.
The gastrocnemius.
You're very knowledgeable about the body parts.
Lots of lactic acid buildup.
Lactic?
I don't see any acid, but sure buddy.
And there's a pin!
Oh, now it's a pin.
I don't see any acid, but you see a bunch of lactation.
Well no!
No!
What are you talking about?
No one's lactating anywhere here, Octavio.
Oh!
Oh finisher!
Finisher!
Oh nice finisher.
Is this the famous nipple twister?
Is it?
Oh no!
It's not!
His chin's being twisted!
Oh no!
It's a face!
It's the chin!
Is this a tap?
Oh no!
No, no, no.
They got away.
Almost.
You should have attacked the nipples instead.
Yeah, I think that would be an immediate tap out.
Oh!
What's happening?
Is this it?
No?
Okay.
I thought that was it.
Stimulating the feeling of drowning.
I'm expecting finishers here because they've been dishing out like a lot of hits.
Oh!
They've probably been charged up like a long time ago.
What the heck?
Trying to escape through the ropes.
We got Sarah here.
Groggy.
And aww!
Punch!
A disrespectful hit to the face.
And they're joining.
What is happening?
Oh my!
Oh!
Straight to the buttocks.
Sarah's back is gonna be splitting two after that.
And that fucking taunt!
Ah, wee!
Are you gonna take that, Sarah?
I don't think you should.
I think you better be fighting back here.
At any moment or else this is gonna be the end of you.
Ooh!
There we go.
It's Sarah's comeback.
Comeback moment.
Grapple again.
And inside the ring.
Okay, what's Sarah gonna do?
Are they gonna recover?
Is Shiri gonna recover in time?
Oh no!
Oh, Sarah took off!
Recover in time.
Like a plane!
Okay.
Oh!
Ooh!
The goggles add extra damage!
That's gonna sink into your eye sockets.
The right foot was a blade that wagged on Shinri's face.
Oh wee.
Oh.
The stun.
The stun meter is almost up.
Ah!
Not in joints!
Oh!
And they are stunned.
This is it.
I think this is the moment.
Arthritis tomorrow.
This is it.
I think this is the finisher.
Oh!
Pin!
I think this is the pin!
Oh no!
What are you doing?
Sarah, what the fuck are you doing?
She's standing down.
No, wait!
That's my senpai.
No, don't pin him down.
Don't pin him down.
Oh!
There's blood!
No!
Shinri's bloodied!
The beautiful face!
Now this is combobulated.
You sure not wore that fucking...
Oh no, Shinri.
This is all your fault.
You're gonna lose.
Two...
Oh!
Kicked out!
How did you survive?
Still has a fighting chance.
After all that, Shinri...
He's still fighting back.
He's resilient like a koi.
Like a koi coming upstream.
Oh!
Ah!
I think that's it.
The pin is here.
Oh wait!
Reversal!
Kicked in the butt!
Reversal after reversal.
Finisher!
This is it!
It's Jover.
It's so over!
Dragging Shinri to the middle.
Dragging the body so it won't get over.
Yeah!
Kicked out!
Let's go!
One!
Two!
Slap in the face!
Three!
And Bulk Bogan survived!
And Bulk Bogan...
Here is your winner!
Representing Nagorai Sora...
BULK BOOGAN!
It's truly Koi-ver.
For the koi.
This is Spack-Everest!
Oh!
What the fuck!
Security!
Don't do that!
We're not a National Geographic!
Look at my snake!
Let me whip it out for the camera.
What's this?
I tempted Adam in the Garden of Eden.
What the hell was that?
What the fuck was the snake for?
That was totally irrelevant.
But thank you though.
Thank you for showing up for Snake!
Thank you!
And we have a winner!
Sara!
That was a long...
That was a great long match!
Jesus!
What can I say?
I was like, it's a landing.
You did so well!
I can't believe you kept your word though.
You really...
It was like a slow start from when you were entering the ring.
But other than that, you really pinned him down.
Yeah, that's what we...
That's what the biz likes to call, you know?
Just giving the people a show.
Like, I let them think.
I let Shinri and his fans think that he could take me on.
But, just, you know, as I said, stuck the landing.
Stuck the landing and killed him.
Yeah, very good.
I'm playing did prevail over the koi.
Can't believe it.
I'm so upset.
I'm just...
I'm sure you are real Shinri.
I'm sure you are.
No, Shinri, we got you.
We got you.
Don't worry.
I'm Shinri.
Yeah, you are.
What the fuck?
You are definitely Shinri.
I think he has a concussion.
There's one thing we can all agree on.
We can comfort each other, bro.
Okay, okay.
I love you.
I love you too, bro.
Oh, wait.
No, no.
Not time for that.
Thank you, though.
Love you too.
I love you too.
No, not you.
I love you too, Sara.
I love you too.
Do you want to grab coffee?
Oh, wait.
What is it?
Oh.
It's mine.
Oh, wait.
I'll pay.
Because, you know, I'm just so ripped and filled with cash.
Yeah.
Wow.
For you.
Can you please order for me?
No.
Are you a woman?
Ouch.
I just wanted a coffee with milk.
Well, I...
You guys did amazing, Sara.
Congratulations for winning.
Thank you.
Oh, my goodness.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Congratulations.
Yeah.
That was very, very interesting.
What a great fight.
Yeah.
Very close.
So, please keep your snake in its... I don't know...
Yeah.
Where did you get that snake?
Jar cage.
Yeah.
That was like totally irrelevant.
That came out of nowhere.
Like, I thought you weren't going to throw it in the scenery.
It didn't.
Like, look at this.
I got a snake with me.
What the fuck?
But was it not epic and memorable at least?
It was so... Okay.
Dude, your intro was fucking long too.
Snake on a plane.
Oh, snake on a plane reference.
Oh.
Wow.
Just wow.
That's crazy.
Crazy.
Wow.
Insane.
Yeah.
But thank you guys so much for participating in the WWE tournament.
Thank you, Shinry.
You tried your best, but you know, you miss 100% shots you don't take.
So, yeah.
Thank you.
Glad to have you here even though you're sick.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Thanks for having me.
I'm Chasuchi Shinry.
I think I should go.
Yeah.
Go rest.
Thank you.
You're sick.
Sarah, congratulations.
That was great.
Yeah.
All right.
See you later in your next match.
Congratulations, Sarah.
You're going to proceed to the finals.
So, yeah.
Better wait on the second day, everybody.
Let's fucking go.
He didn't hear it.
Wait.
What?
What did I...
You talked... I talked over you.
What did you say?
Nothing.
Wait.
What did you say?
I was just dunking on you as per usual.
Oh, come on.
Okay.
Let's just go back to the...
I don't need... I don't want to explain it.
Okay.
Next match.
Stop dunking on me.
We're working together.
Ooh.
Here he is.
Behind the scenes.
Right, baby.
Yeah, that's right.
Axel is currently at Nando's.
So we are going to go with Hakka versus Lee.
Oh, no.
It's him.
It's Hakka, everybody.
That's right, everybody.
Bow down to your fucking new god.
How does...
Hakka, Hakka.
How does it feel to win?
Because I haven't won.
It feels fantastic, guys.
You see, I have my previous loser here.
And I can't wait to have my brand new loser.
I hope they go ahead and do a fucking backflip back to the ring so I can beat their fucking ass.
Oh, what the hell?
Madres poca puta.
Oh!
What's happening?
I don't understand what you just said, but oh!
And Phil fucking went with a twink, baby.
That's what I'm fucking saying.
Twink?
What the fuck?
We're still good.
Oh, um...
Backstage, I have no idea.
I need to learn Jilly Jilly.
Oh, no, no, no.
Well, um...
Look, Fillion did say...
Fillion did say to let her know before the match started that her match was gonna be up.
Oh, there she is!
I see her!
Wait, what's happening?
What am I doing?
You're fighting Hakka.
Isn't that a brand new fucking loser right here?
I was freaking out back.
What the frick?
How about you do a fucking backflip straight to the fucking ring and beat me up, huh?
You off in circus, monkey?
How about you F'n... I don't know.
I don't know, man.
You better prepare a fucking new VTuber award for the person who's gonna fucking beat your fucking ass in the ring, baby.
Come here.
You're gonna win the F'n award for most curse words said in five minutes.
Why is it so much like...
Name ten words.
I'm fucking pumped!
I fucking won!
Name ten words.
I'm winning!
Are you confident that you're gonna win again against Fillion?
Absolutely.
They called me the crow because I'm about to pick those fucking eyes.
What?
Bro, this is fucking pumped.
What's this fucking response?
This dude just is one.
Like, I don't even know what I'm dealing with right now.
No one does.
Let me tell you.
My mom fucking checked me.
They don't know what's fucking wrong with me.
But you're gonna figure that fucking out tonight.
Bro, she literally called you weird.
Jesus Christ.
Fuck you over.
You're done for.
Okay.
That's cool.
Whatever you want, man.
Or maybe like, I don't know.
Like, rock, paper, scissors.
Yeah, yeah, sure.
You know.
Let's see.
Well...
How do you even...
I've been a bingo more!
Just say one of the three options.
I need a translator for how to sing.
We do rock, paper, scissors.
Loser gets a finger cut off before we start.
Chat, bring out Google Translate.
Can Google translate?
He's speaking English.
I'm speaking English.
Just in case.
We need DeepL.
DeepL for Haka.
Well...
Well, what's happening now?
I might be a...
I might be a wild animal.
I might be a wild animal, but Phileon, you know what?
Let's have a fair fight.
I handshake you.
Play by the rules of fucking nature.
And just prefer that a war for me, because I'm gonna beat your fucking ass.
Oh...
Okay.
Yeah.
Who do you guys think will win?
Haka or Phileon?
Come on, man.
Win.
Armus and all the stars.
We're rooting for you, buddy.
Wait, if I won this, nerd, do I get to cast myself?
No.
Yeah.
But I cast her, right?
What?
If you win this fight, Phileon, you get to cast yourself later in the next game.
Let's go!
Hey, let's go!
You have to win it, though.
You have to.
Why is it for Toronto, Canada?
I'm not... what the fuck?
Wait.
Toronto, Canada?
Hey, you're not supposed to be here.
Get in the ring.
And...
The following contest is...
The final schedule for OneFall.
Introducing first, TwinkleTwinkle, his conquest unmarred, WakaWaka, Itaka!
Oh, man.
I love your intros, bro.
Thank you.
Thank you for that.
Shakira Shakira!
Introducing his opponent, Phileon Like A Killian, one in a billion!
If you blink, you'll miss him!
It's Phileon!
Killian!
Let's fucking go!
Let's go!
Killian Murphy!
Another one of that breakdancing show that was presented earlier.
My goodness.
They're still catching up.
But yeah, I'm hoping for the best for Haka, considering that he is part of our Hall of Stars branch.
So I hope you win.
No bias, but I hope you win.
Good luck, Haka!
Good luck!
I'm rooting for you.
We'll see how Haka changes.
This time!
Or will Phileon actually turn the tables and actually win this match?
I feel like Phileon will win.
Oh yeah, let's see.
Subversion of expectations.
Those dance moves make her like a really competitive fighter.
She can get out of pins, she can jump, she can high fly.
Yeah, like the previous match that we watched with her was like nothing but high flying.
I wonder what this match is gonna turn out into.
Like a heavy fighter?
Like a heavy swiker?
Or a lightweighter?
Okay, here we go!
Alright, alright!
We shall see!
Haka!
Versus Phileon!
Fight!
Oh wow!
Whoa!
DDT!
Immediately right off the bat!
All I'm seeing is Kaka!
One of these big throws, high flyer attacks.
Holy crap!
What are you doing?
Haka!
You're failing immediately!
To the kidney!
To the face!
Oh my god!
Already smudging the face into the fucking ring!
It's so over!
But we just started, so let us see if this narrative continues on down the road.
And it hurts!
Those tendons and ligaments are getting torn!
By Phileon the Killian!
Ow!
Okay, that hurt!
Oh!
Another one to the face!
Haka barely even fighting back!
Twisting your arm!
Are you okay, Haka?
Break those fingers again!
Oh my god!
I guess...
I guess this is what you call like an animal fight.
Like a...
Can he reverse it?
No, he's gonna do it again!
I ran out of words.
Oh shit!
Again!
Why are you still?
Targeting Haka's fingies!
Owie!
It's over!
Haka won't be able to use a spoon and fork again after this fight.
The reversal like statistics is very high.
He's gonna drink the straw only.
Oh!
Ow!
Okay, finally a comeback!
An elbow to the face!
Sizing each other up!
And Phileon again with another advantage!
Oh!
Never getting back up!
It's gonna hurt!
Oh!
Another somersault technique!
Bunz!
Owie!
A pin opportunity!
That could have turned the table!
But no, it's still early and barely any damage has been done.
It would be a miracle to perform.
Phileon just keeps tumbling and rumbling.
And going around.
Rumbling!
Oh!
Oh.
Okay, this might be Haka's time to come back.
Do a comeback.
On the turnbuckle.
Salvo punches.
This corner may be his only chance of winning it back.
And no, he got punched into the gut.
And...
Oh!
He got caught!
And an elbow to the chest!
Straight to the heart.
Oh!
Really focusing on the arms there.
I'm sorry, Haka.
It's over.
I think this is probably impossible for you to come back.
Unless you pull something through.
Okay.
Is this a glimmer of hope?
A glimmer of hope!
Is this the light at a very dark tunnel?
Oh wait!
Is this it?
Oh!
Got back up!
It wasn't enough!
Oh shit!
Here's a pin!
Come on referee!
You're so slow!
Oh, nothing, nothing.
A kick out.
Kick out of the pin.
And surprisingly, it didn't have a count.
Surprisingly resilient of Haka.
Billion throwing him.
Haka throwing back.
Somersaulting!
What is going on in Haka?
Are you okay?
Oh!
Moon kick!
Haka was funny there.
He was like...
Right.
Oh!
This might be it.
Yeah, this is it.
That wasn't even a match.
That was like a fucking massacre.
Oh!
Still going!
This referee is so slow!
What?
Somebody fire the referee!
Haka!
I gotta admit, you're pretty fucking strong here.
Like your durability on your character is just super fucking weird.
What is your statistics, man?
And jump in!
I think it's the flip flops.
It's the flip flops.
Oh!
Countered!
That flip only caused you like a damage to the chest.
Because his toes are free.
Oh!
Stun meter going up!
Now get her into the ring and pin her down!
Is he gonna get the momentum ready?
Three seconds outside!
Oh!
Taunting!
Right in front of the top!
That's what happened!
The disrespect is real!
Oh my god!
Leverage pin!
Leverage!
Oh!
These pins are very short.
Not even a one count.
Oh!
Ah!
Reversal!
Elbow to the face yet again.
Backshot!
Stop it!
Oh!
We're having corner attacks here.
One more?
Turnbuckle attacks.
Oh!
There's one more!
One more?
Wow!
Another finishing strike!
And here it is!
Pin!
Down for the count!
Is he really down for the count?
This might be it!
One!
Two!
Three!
Billion one!
Wow!
That was a one sided match!
Here is your winner!
Jedi Stunner!
She makes her hearts flutter!
What a billion billion!
Billion!
Damn!
Congratulations!
Is she a fox or is she a cat?
Or is she a dog?
I don't know.
But yeah.
That animal...
That animal right there...
Is that fucking dog.
They got that dog in her though.
What's that little dot on her nose?
She's got that dog in her.
Let's fucking go.
She fucking won.
Very good match rating.
So what do you say Hawkeye?
That shit was fucking rigged!
Let me tell you dude.
The way fucking Spillion threw at me.
With like fucking triple backshot loss of nature.
With the triple bell buckle.
That was not fair.
That was an illegal move.
I mean that's not the only illegal thing that's been...
Well...
I'm just saying...
How does it feel like losing?
Even though you shit talked her so much.
Well you see...
I put the energy on shit talking on the actual fight.
It seems like I was a little bit...
Not balanced.
You know what I'm talking about?
The stats didn't help me out here.
But come on.
Look at Spillion man.
You got brutalized bro.
I was really impressed by your combo.
You hit me once and you taunted.
That was really good.
But this shit doesn't work like this over here man.
He keeps talking.
He's not cock cock cock.
He's fucking yap yap yap.
Stop yapping bro.
You fucking lost.
He's still going.
I'm glad you think Paco is a role model.
Listen to me for a second.
Get out of my head.
I cannot think no more.
I cannot think no more man.
I mean you're on her head.
She's not in your head.
Get out of my head.
I cannot think no more.
Listen here's the...
They put me against a kid the first time.
I didn't know they'd do it again.
Like... I'm sorry.
I matched this man.
Damn the child allegations.
Oh wait no.
The child... wait no.
You know what?
What?
What are you trying to say?
Question mark?
How does it feel to be the child?
Look away.
Yeah you tell him.
You're my girlfriend.
Frick you.
Oh.
Damn.
That was a little bit personal.
I'll walk myself to the hospital.
That was awkward.
Thank you for having me.
I'll walk myself to the hospital.
This dog has dick in his hands.
Let me tell you that.
Well the fight was amazing.
I think Fillion's moves are really really cool.
And I can't wait to see how far...
I think...
I think he'll get pretty far Fillion.
Yeah I could tell too.
High flyer and heavy hitter.
Damn.
The combination of the statistics is fucking good.
You didn't even give Hakka a chance.
Impressed as hell.
It's a really really exhausting fucking sport.
So you're doing your best.
I'm proud of you.
Oh frick yeah.
No it was great being you too by the way.
Well then are we ready for our next fight?
Are we ready for our next fight?
Are we ready?
Who's the next one?
Who's ready to battle?
Who's next in the...
Oh wait.
Oh wait wait.
She's gonna go casting?
Wait is it my fight?
I think it is!
It's my fight.
Oh you're casting your own fight!
Let's fucking go!
We're just waiting for your opponent.
Am I gonna cast my own fight?
I think so.
Well now that you're here, let's see.
I wanna see your match Octavio.
I wanna see your live reactions to everything.
Like how are you gonna face against a dragon?
I mean...
Dragon's kinda like a dinosaur.
So kinda easy peasy.
So can you take him on?
You guys do look like siblings.
Yeah!
I can just cut off their tails.
Their wings.
But no the difference was I fucking lost so...
Hello Daya!
Hello!
What's up?
There she is.
What Octavio?
What happened to her toughness?
I thought you were ready!
Come on bro!
Say it!
Say it right in her face!
Say it man!
Hello!
What's up?
Bro what happened to the aggression?
Octavio come on!
You were talking such mad shit on like social media.
You have nothing to say now!
Now that she's standing here you're just...
Hello!
You're a dragon.
No you're more like a baby worm.
You're actually more like a worm!
I'm gonna crush you beneath my heel!
On my boot!
Don't talk back please!
That was...
That was pretty good.
Really?
I can't appreciate you after.
Thank you.
I'm not accepting anything.
Please just accept it.
Nah man.
Yay!
Please smack talk him.
I don't have anything to say to you.
Oh my!
You're so insignificant in her mind.
Octavio she literally called you worthless!
Not even worth the attention bro!
Are you gonna accept that?
Not even worth the reply?
How dare you!
I'm gonna burn.
That fucking disrespect is insane.
I don't think I'm right now.
Bro literally said hello to me.
Stop doing this to me!
Please!
Come here my argument!
The first thing you did was like stutter to me.
Like you saw me drawing your face.
Like ugh ugh holy crap.
What do I do?
I can't believe this.
You are an embarrassment bro.
Come on not like this.
Come on Saya let's go to the ring.
I'm gonna clip your damn wings.
I'll let my fist do all the talking.
Oh!
Wow!
I ain't gonna make my puppets do my talking.
I have puppets.
They're cute and cuddly.
Yeah yeah.
They can fight for me.
Good for you bro.
That's great.
I'm so happy for you.
Wait I'm trying to catch GPT.
Help me.
Who do you think is gonna win?
Based on this conversation right here.
Octavio or Saya place in your votes right now!
Good luck Saya.
You got this.
Please Saya please.
I need a skill.
I'm hoping for the best for Saya too.
Let's fucking go.
Octavio you're gonna go down.
I don't know I liked you bro.
Damn look at that.
Very handsome man.
Octavio.
Your face.
What happened to your face?
I don't know I'm slaying.
Slaying.
I think I'm catching a glimpse of what you really look like bro.
You mean fabulous.
Look at my three braids can you see?
Yeah you are.
Yeah like...
I don't like it.
Wait is Saya...
Does Saya have a painted body?
I don't like it.
The following contest is scheduled for one fall!
Introducing first.
From the announce desk.
One brutal ratio.
Oh wow.
Octavio!
Look at that guy.
What a stand up guy.
Damn he be glowing.
Oh shit!
Oh!
Ay-yo!
Dude's got that zoom in.
Look at that puppet.
Oh there it is.
That is one brand by the way.
Holy crap.
I'm gonna make it fight for me.
What happened?
It disappeared.
I threw it away!
I didn't see it!
Okay, alright, alright.
We got a smoldering look from Octavio.
Okay, what are you gonna do?
Do you have a- Oh, there it is!
There's the gimmick!
There it is!
Ohhhhh, menacingly looking up to the ground in a wink!
I directed those pyrotechnics.
See?
Oh wow.
A lot of budget went into that outfit.
Wow, wow, wow.
I think this guy is gonna win.
Just my feeling.
Let's see, let's see what Sire looks like.
Let's see, because sometimes the build determines the match.
He's going crazy!
You're still going?
I don't know, man.
Look at all my strings, see?
I'm gonna attach those to Sire.
I'm gonna win without even touching her, without even punching her.
Oh, oh, bro, I don't want to look at the polls right now.
I think you're in a fucking, oh no.
You're so getting bodied, everyone everyone has zero faith in you.
Introducing his opponent!
From Hell!
Bruh?
She is the Slayer Sa- AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA Holy crap.
Oh wow, you brought in a torch!
It's not a phase mom.
What do you mean from hell, she's from a little cave.
Oh my god.
It's not a phase.
Stop burning the stage.
Shout out to the mom out here.
Your daughter's lighting up the fucking stage.
Dude, does your mom know you're VTubing?
The arena is burning.
Does your mom know you're VTubing?
Yes.
Mine doesn't.
No.
Imagine if she actually stumbles onto this WWE street.
Are you ashamed of yourself?
Of course I am!
Mom, is that what you think?
Excuse me.
VTubing is for the cool kids.
I'm doing voice acting, mom.
I swear.
VTubers are the new jocks.
I make money, mom.
I swear.
It's not a phase, I swear.
Entering the ring.
And no pyrotechnics.
I guess she loses in terms of like...
She's big and bulky again.
Look at that.
She's gonna be tall, I swear to god.
She's gonna be seven feet tall.
Is she gonna be?
I'm just gonna be 5'8".
Here we go.
Oh wow.
They're both doing the same thing.
But the only winner is one.
Who's it gonna be?
Oh, kick.
Oh my god.
It may get stuck.
And they're having a cat fight.
Oh, ripping off the hair.
Oh, not the hair.
Ripping off the arms.
Clipping the arms.
Like the wings of an angel.
Reversal.
Grapple.
And oh!
Oh my god.
Octavia, you might actually fucking win.
What the fuck is that?
Dude's flexing out here, buddy!
Guys, guys.
I think the statistics in the voting system is false.
Octavia may have a chance here.
A butt dive.
Oh, oh, oh.
Twist in the neck.
Yeah, dislocate that head.
Here it is.
Is it a tap out?
Oh no, it wasn't a tap out.
It wasn't a submission move.
Oh, stunner.
Stunner.
Oh, is this a finisher?
Is this a finisher?
Oh no, it's just a taunt.
Octavia with the aggressive play here.
Bashing in.
Oh my god, here's a pin!
A pin already!
And the kick out.
Saya, if you ever want to win, you better fight back because Octavia is on a fucking roll here.
And a smash to the fucking stage.
Damn, focus on those arms.
Let's go.
Saya, come on.
We went past the...
Do I still not deserve a replay?
Oh, missed!
Oh my god, and a head bash!
Oh god!
Animalistic behavior by smashing the head.
Oh my god, here we go.
Headbutt combo here.
No, don't do this to me!
And a slam!
Two seconds in, but barely a scratch to Octavia.
You're gonna have to do more than that to actually do some more.
Thank you.
This is kinda nerve-wracking.
Woah!
Aggression.
Athleticism is being shown through the screen.
They're both still fighting outside.
Oooh!
Pull those strings, puppet man.
Nothing but dirty plays.
And...
What do you mean nothing but dirty plays?
This is all legit.
It is dirty play.
You're not fighting into the stage.
See?
No, that's not allowed.
Oh, they're back in.
Okay, they're back in.
Octavia, what are you doing?
Octavia, you...
You arrogant prick.
Get inside the ring.
Pin him.
Pin him down!
Oh!
Damn!
Is this it?
Oh, high flyer technique!
Oh, he's gonna dive.
Woah!
Shit!
It's over.
It's so over.
And a pin.
One...
Two!
Oh!
Kicked out!
There may be hope here for Sia fans out here.
Dragons don't exist.
And doing a taunt of all things!
The absolute confidence is in this motherfucker.
Stay in your... Stay in your fictionary books.
Fictional books.
Where you belong.
Throw in the corner and another punch.
Knocked down.
There's nothing...
Ouch.
Oh no, not the reversal.
I feel so sorry for Sia right now.
Oh wait.
Come back.
Come back in the real world.
Oh no.
Is it?
Oh!
My head!
We got a grapple technique here but not enough to actually put him in a stunning stage.
So far we've seen Octavio body Sia.
What's happening?
I don't know.
They're just going in and out.
In and out.
What's going on?
I don't know!
But it's something!
Oh!
Oh no!
No!
Don't put me on the...
And head to the turnbuckle.
Oh damn.
What are you doing Sia?
Sia what are you doing?
Sia I think you're...
Oh my god.
What the hell?
Is this it?
No!
Oh shit!
Oh I'm stunned!
Is this it?
One trick pony!
One!
Oh!
Just a one count.
Good job, good job.
Okay.
What are you doing?
Not even worth a second count.
Position her correctly.
Oh no.
Oh, oh, oh, a reversal!
Ayo!
Octavio!
Damn.
Okay.
More of this?
Oh wow.
The ref is in the fucking way.
Get out of the way!
Submission!
Is this it?
Oh no, no.
It wasn't a tap out.
She got out.
Durability high.
Oh!
An exchange of blows!
A slap in the face!
Oh come on!
Let's go!
Ay!
Why'd you punch me?
Nothing but back and forth here.
And a counter.
Oh!
First blood everybody!
First blood!
Nothing but blood.
Help me!
It's so over.
Oh shit!
Whoa!
That's it!
It's over!
I flew.
Stunner is real.
Oh not my legs.
Not my legs.
Oh no, no.
Okay this match is gonna be...
I'm limping.
Oh!
Reverse!
This match is closer than I expected.
Whoa!
This is it!
Oh!
One!
Two!
Oh kick out.
Please help me!
Unfortunately Octavio you're gonna have to fight for that one.
Why is this such a hard battle?
Rattling each other again.
Throw it again.
Into the corner.
Octavio with the advantage.
Doing a little dance!
What the fuck!
Get puppeteered!
It's over.
And boom!
It's down.
It's over.
Oh what are you doing referee?
One!
Two!
Three!
SwiftTavio advances to the next round!
Here is your winner...
Octavio!
That's the fearless fit there!
Shoutout to Mother Taylor Swift!
Oh...
Oh, God.
Octavio.
You're in love for Taylor Swift.
Never cease to disappoint them.
It's fearless.
That was a great, great ranking.
Yeah, it was a great match.
Great job!
Just a little bit disappointed though.
I had high expectations that you'd lose.
You look so fucking dumb.
I hate your character design, Octavio!
I fucking hate it!
How'd you win?
Why'd you win?
I didn't lose.
Well, um...
Hey, Saya.
That was definitely a good thought.
You get wrecked.
That was a lot of back and forth.
Are you now gonna reply to my fire insults?
She doesn't even care, bro.
No, she doesn't.
I won!
Please?
Say something at least!
Say something!
Saya, you need help being escorted out of the building without...
I need help.
I can help you get out of here.
I need help, please.
Okay, I got you.
I got you.
I'll cover you and everything.
Call me stinky.
Call me small.
Call me bad.
Call me... I don't know.
And you're calling me a masochist, Jesus Christ.
You're begging for insults.
Bro!
Well fought.
No!
Learn some humility.
We're in another channel.
I feel like I lost.
Any afterthoughts after this fight?
No.
I have no thoughts.
Just depression.
No thoughts.
That entire fight felt like... no thoughts, head empty.
Damn.
Indifference hurts more.
Yes, it does, bro.
That's crazy.
Ow.
I won, but I lost.
I guess, Octavio, congrats on winning.
Dude, that's a fucking trumpet.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
I agree.
I'm really happy for you.
I really do.
I hope you perform better in the next match.
Thank you.
Are we done now?
Are we done glazing you?
Congratulations.
You won.
You won, buddy.
You're happy now?
Yes.
Well, thank you, Sia, for joining us.
You were amazing and you're super slay.
Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
Bye, Paul.
Thank you for not beating me.
Bye-bye, Sia.
Bye-bye.
Oh, man.
The next match.
Next match.
This match is crazy.
Oh, shit.
I'm excited for this one.
What is happening?
Why?
Okay.
Oh, what?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
What?
Yeah.
Battle two.
The twins are here.
Oh, no.
I thought that was a joke.
What the fuck?
No, but it's not.
Are they here?
It's real.
Are they actually here?
Oh, my fucking God.
Battle one and battle two.
Hey, everybody.
Good to see you.
It's not.
It's so scenery.
Excuse me.
No, no, no.
I've been suffering from a terrible cold.
I've just been having a hard time recently.
Hey, everybody.
How's it going?
Yeah, you're going to be suffering from a little bit more after this.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Trash talking starts immediately.
Listen, listen, listen.
We might be twins, but we are also fraternal twins.
That means our fighting styles will be different.
We are also fraternal twins.
And frankly, frankly, this is payback for taking all the nutrients in the womb.
Oh, I mean, you can use them.
Twins relate, everybody.
Twins relate.
Would you like to explain how your fighting styles differ?
Well, mine is a winning style and his is a losing style.
So it is kind of a drastic difference if you catch my drift.
I see.
Well, we'll see, brother.
We'll see.
Which one of us has the recessive genes and the dominant ones?
Well, I don't even know what that means.
I don't even know what that means.
Didn't know we got genetics in here.
This is a family feud for sure.
It is personal.
It sure is.
It's personal.
I know you guys are fighting.
This is a rivalry that started from the womb and will end in the tomb.
Well, I know you guys are fighting, but how does it feel to, you know, be in the same room as each other after a while?
You know...
Terrible.
Oh.
Honestly awful.
It's really awful.
Honestly, this guy's been pissing me off for too long.
I'm done with this.
It was a surprise to be here.
And I'm not a good surprise.
A bad surprise that I have to fight him, honestly.
Oh.
I'll strut you in there and you're gonna die.
They love each other.
Yeah.
And I love him.
Brother, they love.
I love him.
Aww.
None of that sucky-wucky stuff here.
It's all violence.
Oh, okay.
Well.
I wish both of you the best of luck.
I definitely don't have bias in who wins in this match either, but good luck.
I'm curious though.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Who's the strongest twin?
We will find out.
Everybody put in your votes.
Who's gonna win?
Battle one or battle two?
Put in your votes, everybody.
There we go.
While that is running.
Any final words?
Nothing?
Okay.
Let's fucking go.
Why am I losing the call?
We both know why you're losing the poll, come on?
Holy crap, what is that abomination?
The poll is up and running.
And just for the sake of it, I'm just gonna vote for battle.
Let's see.
Let's see the...
Oh my God, that is a large margin.
Battle two is winning.
Oh my God.
Battle two looks handsome.
Battle two is winning.
What a damper fellow.
He has a cape, too.
Holy shit.
Let's fucking go.
Let's see who's gonna win.
Battle between brothers.
Twin versus twin.
A battle.
A battle that began.
The following contest is a twins match!
For one fall, introducing first...
He is the bi-pedal gas pedal battle one!
That's horrifying.
It is.
What is his face?
I'm just looking at it in horror.
What the hell is that?
What is that?
His face is just plastered on human... on a human head.
What the hell?
Does he have like a skin suit?
That he's wearing over his head or face?
There's a fucking skinwalker.
Introducing his opponent, straight from the same room, the rebel who meddles...
Battle 2!
Wow, this is really nice!
A very unexpected turn of events.
I didn't think we'd be seeing battle 2 fight battle 1.
I thought it was like a joke at the beginning.
And turns out it's actually fucking real.
I thought it was literally just gonna be battle.
Yeah, it's like battle versus battle and his own character creation.
But look at this right now.
A surprising turn of events.
This is so weird.
This battle 2 looks more brash than the battle 1.
The winner should remember.
I'm gonna replace the battle.
Oh!
Yeah, that should be a thing.
This is a battle to beat a battle.
Who's gonna beat a battle 1?
Oh!
Sorry.
All bets on Tubert.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
All right.
All right!
I'm excited to see.
Here it is!
The battle of the century!
On this corner is battle.
And on that corner is battle 2!
Fight!
Oh my god!
They did the same thing!
Twins through and through!
Battle of the century and the king!
They share the same genetics.
Oh my god, this is hype as hell!
Oh!
Battle 1 turns out to be the battle 1.
And he's the way of summer soul!
Oh!
Oh, high flyer battle 1!
High flying technique.
With creepy ass face.
Right in the nuts.
Oh, right in the groin!
Ooh!
I can't...
This is the most...
I like that they started out sprinting towards each other.
...sturdiest hat in history.
Their immense hatred for each other is just that strong.
They immediately just started running!
They didn't even think!
They just did the same technique without even thinking!
That is insane.
That's...
That's what they did in the womb.
Who started kicking first?
Battle or Bell 2?
Ask your mom.
You're at the same time.
Mom, who kicked first?
Oh, apparently, Battle 2 kicked first.
And whoa!
Battle mom, who do you love more?
Battle 1 or Bell 2?
Oh, shit!
Oh, god damn.
God damn, now they're outside.
A little bit of a hug.
A sweet family reunion moment.
And oh, oh, not really.
And oh!
They do not really love each other at this moment.
This is a hypas hail battle.
It is, it is.
Blood rivalry has always been like the hypas shit.
Like, who is the most dominant between like, um, siblings and shit.
They've always been compared.
That's so aggressive.
Aggressive and personal, considering they're brothers.
And a taunt!
Ooh!
That's a great taunt.
Going back into ring.
Giving him a chance.
Ooh!
Riding on that back... Ooh!
Smashed the face.
Kicking Tubert into the ground.
Pummeling him down.
Riding supreme.
Oh, he just jumped.
Went back inside.
What is this?
What is this clown behavior?
Back to your place.
Oh, Tubert.
Oh, oh!
Oh, you...
As expected of a...
That was a huge fumble.
But Willis fumbled though.
Oh, oh!
That's because he wears glasses.
A-Oi!
They both fumbled!
They're the same person.
I can't tell which one is which.
Oh!
Didn't even give him a chance to stand up.
The disrespect.
Leg locking him.
Ow!
Owie!
He's not gonna be standing up for a few seconds.
Oh, oh, oh!
Arm!
Arm, arm, arm!
Twisting!
Oh!
What?
And a taunt here and there.
Who do you think is gonna win, Octavio?
Based on the current fight right now.
I'm still rooting for Battle 1.
Battle 1?
Yeah, I kinda like changed my opinion.
Right now, I think Battle 2 is gonna make a a title change.
Right here.
Like a swift change of events.
Oh!
Whoa!
Okay, take it back.
Take it back.
Oh, Battle's gonna win.
Battle's gonna win!
Is Battle gonna jump?
Battle's gonna jump!
Oh!
Damn!
Censored!
Oh, god damn!
I can't see it.
Get your fucking sign off my screen!
Don't do this at home, kids.
Oh!
Clothesline!
That clothesline was really hard.
Oh, shit!
Oh, god.
Ayo!
Oh!
Oh, he just walked away.
Not even worth running.
Not even...
This is so legally matched.
Oh, oh.
What are you doing?
In the size of Battle 2?
Oh, what the fuck are you doing, Battle 2?
Battle 2!
This is scripted.
That's so stupid.
Battle 2 loves Gavis Battle.
Tubert, I know you love your brother, but you don't have to fumble that, obviously, alright?
Alright?
He failed to land it!
Now we know who's gonna win!
Oh!
They both jumped at the same time, but doing the pin is Tubert.
One!
And a count to one.
Just a one count.
Battle is more sturdy than I thought.
Yes, he is, but to be fair, they have not landed a finisher just yet.
And look at that!
Look at that!
Flexing!
And he's dead.
No, he's not.
His C3 is hurting.
Oh!
Dirty move!
That took him out.
I can't wait for Battle to show his signature move, the low blow.
Oh shit, that is the finisher.
Is this it?
Oh, that is it.
That might be it.
One, two, three!
Battle 1!
Battle 1 is the winner!
The battle of the battle!
Here is your winner!
Battle...
Only Winner!
Battle... Only Winner!
That was a nice fight though.
Even though it was short, that was like very hype as hell.
I hope they don't have any hard feelings though after this.
I hope nothing personal ever happens in between them.
We'll see.
Maybe who's gonna disown who.
Let's see.
Let's hear.
I don't know.
The plot twist continues.
He did not wiggle hard enough.
I may have been born second, but I just gave it first!
Woah, woah, woah!
Actual cannon!
Holy crap!
It is what it is, I guess, you know?
Sometimes you win, sometimes you lose.
Today was my day, I guess.
Wow.
What?
I feel kinda bad.
That's it?
I mean, it's alright.
Do you wanna talk about it?
No, no, it's alright.
I think I got caught up in the competitivity.
I didn't really check on your feelings.
No, no, I just thought that we would...
You know, it was a big day for us both here.
And I just thought we were gonna play it out a little bit more.
Yeah, I... well...
I... oh, jeez.
That really hurt.
Like, I don't know...
I thought we had agreed that it wasn't gonna...
We were gonna hold back just a little.
Alexa, play Despacito.
Please, chat.
Alright, play Despacito.
So sad.
Chat, this is revelation.
I... I... I won!
I won!
But I won a winner!
Lore drop?
Family lore drop?
Holy crap!
I could always find another brother.
Oh!
Well...
Damn.
You guys did amazing.
It was very... it was a very...
very even... even match?
Yeah, evenly matched.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Literally and metaphorically.
Yeah, it only relied on the person who would do the finisher first.
And...
Yeah.
I was really surprised when you both did the same move at the beginning.
That was sick.
Yeah, that was...
I didn't think you'd be doing the same moves!
Was that planned or was it not?
Like, let's talk about this.
Let's use the same technique.
I mean, I mean, you know, we're twins.
We're thinking the same thing.
We had a psychological advantage on each other.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, it's twin things, I guess.
But what we can't take away is that the winner is Betel.
And that you should be careful what you drink from now on.
And the Betel one.
Very true.
Betel is the winner, everybody!
Everybody!
Congratulations to Betel!
Yeah!
Congratulations!
Thank you.
Alright, well, I'm gonna go get some rest.
And Betel too, thanks for fighting me.
Yeah, it was fun.
Yeah, it was both entertaining and fun having both of you here.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Alright, well, thanks for having us.
See you in the next fight, Betel.
Alright!
Bye-bye!
Thank you!
And next, we have the next...
It's Dokian.
And here it is, everybody!
The moment you've been waiting for!
Here it is.
Axel!
Versus Dokian!
What is this?
It's cute though, it's cute.
That's Axel-senpai!
Stop!
What the fuck?
Why are you so small?
We postponed you like four times, Axel!
Yeah, yo, okay.
First of all, let me say, hey, nice to meet you, man.
Hey, nice to meet you, man.
It doesn't feel like our first time talking.
We've just met, you know?
I feel like I've heard this thing before.
Yeah, I just don't know.
It's somewhere in my memory.
This guy hasn't even digested his fucking chicken yet and he's here to fight me?
Oh, it's a pregame!
It's a pregame meal, alright?
What do you mean pregame?
It's like when you eat and you're not supposed to go to the swimming pool.
You're not supposed to wrestle after eating.
This guy doesn't take this seriously.
Nah, this is a series, dude.
I gotta win after this.
I know half of the boys out there fucking got slaughtered, bro.
Yeah, we did.
All my disciples, all my sons, they all got fucking slaughtered.
Except for like one or two, you know?
Now, as the sensei, I gotta come out and win for them.
You know what I'm saying?
You better, senpai.
I'm rooting for you, buddy!
Hell yeah, baby.
I gotta fucking channel my inner Steve Irwin and fucking tackle you down like a little fucking crocodile.
He fucking died to a stingray.
I just had to poke you in the fucking heart.
Like, what did you do?
Bro, motherfucker, you don't look like a stingray.
I could just fucking punch you in the heart and you're fucked.
He's dead.
You look like the chicken I had at Nando's.
Aw, shut your big ass up.
Bring your ass.
You look like the chicken I had at Nando's today.
Wow!
Damn fucking right.
I hope you get a stomachache from that.
Because you didn't digest it properly.
Oh, Nala.
I eat raw meat all the time, baby.
I hope you get a kidney stone from that Nando.
Nah, I'm drinking water every day.
Why am I getting hit?
Why specifically kidney stones?
I'm a fucking hydro homie.
I drink water every day nonstop.
You know?
Alcohol's not water.
Well...
Nah.
I saw...
I saw what you're wearing tonight in the ring.
You're going down.
Check out my fit.
I got it from Gucci.
Straight out of Gucci.
Oh yeah?
They're gonna see what you got from Gucci.
Hell yeah.
Bro.
I didn't even buy it.
They just gave it to me for free.
They're like, yo, sponsored by us.
Oh no.
When they see...
When all of them see what they gave you for free, they'll know why it was for free.
I mean, hey.
Look at my pose, yo.
I'm giving you that zesty little meow-looking ass pose, bro.
I'm out here for some zest tonight.
And I'm gonna get yo ass just like the chicken I had at Nando's like I said.
Bring your ass.
Just like the stingray to Steve Irwin, I'm gonna fucking kill you.
In game.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ayo.
In game.
Thank you for the clarification.
But let's see the statistics on the poll right here.
And the overwhelming majority thinks that Doki's gonna win by 65%, over 35%.
But we will see, everybody.
They don't believe the underdog story.
You know what I'm saying?
The underdog story lives through.
Look at the rain.
Bro, bro, I'm just saying.
Dude, dude, dude.
Bet for me.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Bet for me and you make that money.
Shout out to Kabusu.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Aww, that's so cute.
That's so cute.
I didn't think you could do that.
Oh my god.
Damn, Doki in the house.
We got Axel here.
Everybody change the statistics now.
Vote for Axel.
Continuation of Tekken 8.
This is a cute image.
But yeah.
Let us now continue.
Doki versus Axel Sirius.
Axel Sirius, dog.
Let's see his fit.
He says it comes from Gucci.
We'll see about that.
It is.
Let's see, let's see.
Damn, this is hype.
Yeah, the loading screen is intense.
The following contest is scheduled for One Fall.
What's a One Fall?
She is the Ayatollah of the Tuberola.
Her heart makes us go Doki Doki.
She is the word Doki.
BAM!
And here she is.
That's so good.
Rising ever so slowly.
Very dramatic.
And she is the king.
Look at that flat tiger face.
That very flat.
Poorly rendered tiger face.
You can't see the snow.
I can't.
But god damn, that is very intimidating and terrifying.
Looks like someone will fucking rob me in the fucking middle of the night.
Jesus Christ.
Woo.
Nothing special.
And there it is!
There it is!
Pyro.
The pyro.
Look at those muscles.
No roaring.
Oh shit, I know that.
It's Cody Rhodes.
Cody Rhodes!
Cody Rhodes entrance.
Woo!
Very fucking nice.
They are crazy on that.
He is physically and mentally prepared for the task at hand in his big time match.
The hype is immense.
I can't wait.
Who is your bet?
I think I am going to bet on Doki for this one.
I am going to bet on Axel just because he is my senpai.
I am going to vote.
I can't.
It's one of the rules.
Introducing her opponent.
The Zest in the world.
Oh my god.
Actually serious.
Axel Seria!
Oh wow!
What the heck guys.
He brought out the bomb stick.
Dude that is so cute.
That's not Gucci.
That's Coochie.
What the fuck are you talking about?
That's not what it means.
Stop!
Where the fuck is the Coochie part?
Octavio!
Damn.
You are not helping.
This stream is so demonetized because of you.
Very confirmed.
But hey.
He has that dog in him though.
It has Axel's hair on the dog.
Yeah.
It's like poorly textured but it's there.
Damn.
He even got the chains.
Like Kurapika.
Alright.
Let's go.
Battle between furries.
Who's gonna win?
The king or Doach.
An immediate beat down from Doachie.
Pummeling his face.
Running.
Yeah this is a furry battle.
Battle the furries.
It is.
Technically.
Oh wow.
I'm just looking at Axel's clothes.
Woah.
It looks like a fucking dog bro.
Yeah.
Those back muscles are crazy.
It's so cute.
It is though.
Like isn't that just a suit though?
Yeah it's just a suit.
It's just a muscle suit.
It's not even real.
It's really thin inside.
Rubbing it.
Rubbing her face.
Oh.
Stun meter is up.
Elbow to the back.
Is this gonna be a quick match?
Slamming the face.
The back of the head to the stage.
Axel's stereo is like a mad dog.
Oh.
Almost stunned here everybody.
What is that taunt?
Oh.
Doachie better get up.
Counter.
The stun meter is going away.
He just stepped on him.
Okay here we go.
Doachie's really tall.
Here we go.
Ow.
Just got hurt.
Bunch of chains on there too.
Oh shit.
Knee to the face.
Even landed on it.
My goodness.
That body weight.
They're both dishing each other's attacks on the fucking face.
They're grabbing each other.
Oh no.
Countered.
Oh.
Technically a hit but a miss.
Can he do it here?
Will it be enough?
Hold onto the rope.
Okay it wasn't enough.
Hit.
Oh.
Throw into the ringside.
And knee to the face.
What is that?
Oh my god.
A quick leverage out of the way.
Doachie instantly recovered for that.
Wow.
Both heavy hitters.
Oh this is gonna hurt.
This is gonna hurt.
Carrying it.
Oh.
On the railing.
Is that allowed?
Disqualification.
You're using...
That should be disqualification right?
Or am I wrong?
My god.
They just left him out there.
And jumped.
Oh.
Fucking spear.
Launching.
Oh.
That's gotta hurt.
Pina walks out.
Animal abuse.
That's pure cement.
Oh.
Could you guys please stop?
Not the railing.
Not the metal.
Oh my god.
That is personal.
Oh wow.
This feels like old wrestling.
The beautiful face.
And he tosses him back in now.
Okay.
The old days of wrestling.
This might be it.
Oh.
Was an attack.
Oh what the fuck.
Axel doing a taunt.
Is it worth it?
One of the moves.
You could have used that time to actually... Oh.
Grinding the face.
And an elbow drop too.
Don't do that to the jaguar face.
Doki.
Can you survive?
One.
Two.
Kick out.
Almost.
Come on man.
Not quite.
You're voting for Doki right?
You bet your own man.
We'll see.
Axel go.
That's a professionalism in an attack like that.
Doki still has a chance.
Oh.
Was that the balls?
I have no idea.
Oh.
Hamstrings.
Okay.
I thought they were the balls.
Oh.
A spear.
Ah.
This is technically one sided as it is.
I don't know.
Look.
She still has a fight in her.
There we go.
Oh.
Rage art.
Oh my god.
Stun meter is back up baby.
Back to the railing again.
You have to continue the pummel.
Pummeling will actually stun Axel.
If this continues.
And.
Oh.
Nothing happened.
What the fuck.
And Axel gained advantage again.
The game bugged.
Before she could even fight back.
What happened?
What happened was.
She threw Axel to the stairs and it didn't hit.
It didn't activate.
He didn't get stunned.
He was supposed to get stunned but didn't.
Oh.
King you better get up.
How many seconds have you been outside?
Two.
Oh okay two.
It got reset.
The dog loves it outside.
The match is rigged against Doki.
And Opa!
Stunned!
But she's outside.
You need to get her in.
Four.
She's gonna stand up.
The stun meter is refreshed.
They're going back in.
Uh Doki?
Is Doki running away?
Oh no!
Axel let her in!
Let her in!
Resetting the timer.
Axel's not giving Doki a chance!
Go back!
Go back Israel!
Oh it wasn't enough.
Gravel.
Is it in favor of Axel or...
I think this might be the final thing.
Is it?
Oh a suplex!
Oh yeah!
Suplex continuous.
And another one!
This is definitely King!
King from Tekken!
It's Jover!
Oh stunned.
The finisher has been set.
Pin pin pin!
Is it enough?
One!
Two!
Three!
Stop slapping the dog's face referee!
Please please you're not helping.
Not gonna lie that move though kinda reminds me of King from Tekken.
The uh unlimited combo grapple.
Oh my god!
A dive attack from such a big person.
This is it!
A finisher!
I know this one!
It's a default finisher!
Oh!
No it isn't!
Again again again!
One more!
One more in him!
Oh one more!
This is it!
Three!
Doki wins!
I'm sorry Axel.
This is the end.
This is it!
This is over.
Pin pin pin pin pin!
Stand up!
Pin pin pin!
Why is Doki knocked out?
Doki!
What?
Axel what is d- Oh!
Pin!
Pin down!
Huh?
I'm so confused.
This doesn't make any sense!
What's happening?
This game is rigged.
This tournament is rigged.
Axel's gonna win!
Ooh!
Pin!
Doki!
Doki I'm...
I'm thinking that you have a plan.
Ouch.
But Axel get your shit together because you are gonna lose!
Senpai!
Axel is getting pummeled.
Axel isn't fighting back.
Doki's gonna tear all his limbs off.
Senpai!
TATAKAE!
Oh nothing's happening.
He's still stunned.
Oh shit!
Another finisher!
This is so painful to watch!
Oh my fucking god!
Oh!
Why?
Axel might win!
Oh shit!
It's over!
It's... OOOH!
Another spear!
He's headed up top!
Oh here we go!
And jumping!
And OOOH!
Is Doki stunned enough to not get into the ring?
After 10 counts?
Oh and she's stunned.
She's stunned.
Axel's doing the finisher.
Axel's gonna do the finisher.
The finisher!
He's waiting!
What?
And slammed!
Chokeslam!
Put her in the ring!
Oh shit.
Damn!
Oh here we go.
This is it.
Axel just...
Is this it?
Oh my god!
He's nodding off the fucking fingers!
This is a long battle.
It is!
There's so many moments where Doki was in...
Oh here it is!
Here we go!
Oh there's a fumble.
I can already tell.
Is this a fumble?
Oh Axel!
Oh he's dead.
He's down.
He's doomed.
Okay.
It's over.
One!
Two!
Three!
The trash talker loses again!
Here is your winner!
She is the word!
DOKI!
BAAAAAAAAD!
Doki came out on top baby!
Wow.
Four out of five.
Amazing.
That was great.
That was intense.
Intense.
I've never seen like an animal matchup before.
I can't believe the only holostars in play are me and Bettle.
Guys, you better.
You better.
Alright, let's switch on to the interview section.
Everybody, let's go.
DOKI!
What can I say?
Let's go!
Just like Steve Irwin.
How are you doing?
Axel?
You got Steve Irwin.
God damn.
I must ask, how was it fighting in a fursuit?
You know what?
I'm a good fighter, so I'm not sure I'll win too soon.
Just wait for me.
I'll try to keep you waiting.
Honestly, you know, I was like yo...
I had to give it up, right?
I mean...
Give up the ghost?
Bro!
That means some big money.
Why do you have to give it up though?
Oh, you fucking threw it!
Somebody sent that in there!
I don't know, but yeah...
Guys!
There are so many more games still left.
Make sure to use the app, BeBets, to get your best bets on Geekiverse now, today!
No, no, no, this is already falling apart.
Go for the underdog.
That's what I'm saying, go for the underdog.
You make some big money on the underdog, yo.
Oh my god, he did this on purpose.
He talked mad shit so people would vote against him!
You know me.
What the heck?
Bro took the fall.
He's a businessman.
He got the money, yeah.
He's a business thinker.
Hell yeah, you know me.
Hey, but that Gucci suit, I can sell it off as well.
Make a couple of extra bucks.
I mean, it's all business at the end of the day, you know?
The Gucci fursuit?
The Gucci fursuit.
I didn't know Gucci made fursuits.
That's crazy.
I mean, hey!
But fursuits are a hell of expensive though.
You have a Gucci fursuit?
Yeah.
Damn.
It's got my sweat all over it as well.
It's got that scent.
It's got that flavor.
Check out eBay after this match.
He's gonna be auctioning that out because he needs to pay his medical bills after that.
Nah, nah, nah, bro.
You saw me playing with my gamer sweat.
Oops, sorry.
I got a call.
Oh no, I got a call.
Guys, he's getting his cash out right now.
He's getting his cash out from VBEX.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I ain't checking my paper.
Sorry, that's my...
The money has transferred.
Oh no, they calling me shit.
But hey.
You know, I mean, you saw me playing with my food and rigging the odds a bit, you know?
Because I was smashing her at the start.
Yeah, you did.
So everyone's like, oh my god, Axel's gonna win.
And then that's when I'm like, alright.
Cinema time.
Time for me to go.
Okay, grandpa.
Absolutely.
That's when I...
That's when I win.
Nah, I'd win.
Guys, I win all of them.
Guys, his post also looks like an absolute cinema moment.
Look at that, guys.
Look at that.
Hell yeah.
But yeah.
Congratulations to Doki!
The tournament organizer is the winner!
Not rigged!
Congrats!
Wrestling is not scripted, guys.
I'm just saying.
Hey.
Hey, I'm just saying, Doki.
It's a win-win situation.
I know, yeah, yeah.
And the viewers?
They were entertained.
Were they not?
Because we split the cash, right?
We made it look so real, right?
Hell no.
Take your fucking dub and get...
Take your fucking dub.
Hell no.
Take your dub and go home, bro.
G...
G's, Axel.
Too bad I can't pummel you again.
Oh, well.
Maybe next time.
Maybe next time you get a match.
Maybe next year, 2025, WrestleTuber.
Oh, shit.
Next year we doing the game.
I'mma be... I'mma be too...
What are you gonna do this year, bro?
We'll run it back, of course!
Of course, why else would there be 2024?
I want a rematch!
Rematch!
Next time, Drog will last longer than one round.
You sure about that?
Making a series, you know?
I'm gonna make my character bulkier this time.
But yeah, is there any more?
It's about the mentality.
Yeah.
Yeah, I suppose.
Are there any more opponents that we can, like, uh...
Look forward to?
I think we're going to an intermission.
Yes, we are going to one more final intermission for one last caster rotation.
We have two games left, everybody.
So, we're gonna rotate our casters to Fillion and Snug.
And we're gonna go to the intermission now.
So, we're gonna go to the intermission now.
Let's thank Octavia and Gerard for the casting, everybody!
Yeah!
Thank you!
Bowing, bowing, bowing.
Thank you for having us here.
And really sorry about the dumb comments that we've been making.
It's just our first time.
Okay, really sorry about that.
I just wanna fucking wrestle.
That's it.
Own it!
Own the casting!
You think I know what I'm talking about?
We called the fucking London Bridge is falling down and the Humphrey Bridge is falling down.
That's it!
So, we're going intermission now, right?
Yeah, we're going intermission.
Alright, you guys.
During the break, make sure to check the VBET apps and make sure to bet on the underdog!
Nice to see you guys all.
Alright, bye-bye!
I gotta kick you guys off the main stage too.
Leave.
Alright, intermission now!
Hello everybody!
This is Backstage Doki here.
Getting ready for the final...
The final two matches.
I am not on screen because this is Backstage Doki.
Not Caster Doki right now.
We have two final matches.
Casted by Fillion and Snuffy.
Calling them in real quick, guys.
Gotta put them on the table.
Real quick chat.
Just kidding.
We gotta find them.
Where could they be?
Where could they be, guys?
Where did they go?
Okay.
There's one of them.
Hey.
She's here.
Alright, don't worry.
I pushed her in here.
She doesn't have her mic set up yet, guys.
We didn't put the headphones in yet, guys.
So, give us a second.
Don't worry.
We have our second caster here.
Our second caster.
And there she is.
There she is.
We have our final two matches.
Bulk Bogan vs.
Doki.
And Beta vs.
Octavio.
Let's get them in the room.
Put the mics on them real fast.
Hello.
Welcome.
Are you guys ready to cast?
Yeah.
You guys are on the main screen now.
Oh, shit.
They got the budget for me.
I may be 240p, but at least I'm animated.
What the hell?
I've been flattened and condensed.
Why am I so fuzzy, bro?
We look like an episode of Amazing World of Godfall.
Bro, we're redacted.
Alright.
Well, you know, I'm done beating children.
It's time to cast them.
So let's definitely get down to this, Jolyne.
This is Backstage Doki.
Do you guys remember what are the two last matches?
Me?
I mean, you're casting?
Of course.
Yes.
Let me just go check my DM.
That snuffy is not sending me right now.
Casters, please look at the broadcast chat, casters.
Alright.
I'm afraid... broadcast chat.
Yeah, I watched that match.
That was really epic.
You were... I thought you were... I didn't think you were gonna make it.
I didn't think you were gonna make it.
I'll be honest with you.
Am I interviewing you?
Yeah, you're gonna interview me!
And Sarah!
Guys, you're the...
Guys, why are you asking me questions?
You're the casters!
I'm Backstage Doki!
Wait, I don't see any...
I don't see who's up next.
What do you mean?
I typed it in wrong.
Yes!
Well, that's really crazy, because apparently I can't read.
Oh!
I see.
Okay.
And I just got word from the casters desk.
I put my hand in my ear to look really cool while I'm doing it.
But right now I'm a Vtuber, so you can't see that.
So, our next match I'm getting word is gonna be no one other than Backstage Doki coming out to the forefront.
She's back!
And her opponent is none other than Miss Sarah?
Sarah?
However you say it, she's here to fight.
Sarah.
Wait, how did...
Is it Sarah or Sarat?
I'm getting blamed in the comments right now.
Oh my god.
Let me put you guys into the The casters aren't here.
The casters are walking here, guys!
The place!
Oh gosh, you guys are so big.
Sorry.
Wait, I'm huge!
There we go.
The casters are here now.
But Sarah's not.
Give us a sec.
We're waiting for her.
Sorry.
We're here for some reason.
Don't worry.
There she is.
Oh, I arrived!
Oh, beautiful.
Beautiful.
Very nice.
I like the snake.
If I win, it will come out at the end.
Yeah.
You're not allowed to bring summons into the arena, right?
Yeah, that's not fair.
If you can bring a snake, I can bring a jaguar.
But you are the jaguar.
Are you not, Mr. King?
I can have two.
Oh.
It's not fair.
We're turning this whole match into a jungle at this point.
I mean, we are.
I mean, 99% of the people here are I mean, 100% of us are animals.
Oh my god.
Really?
I'm not amongst you.
What do you mean you literally have cat ears?
Bro, that's not...
No, these are fake.
They're actually canonically fake.
They're canonically fake.
I can take them off.
Bro, okay, when I was like, Hey, which wrestler do you want to represent you?
She was like, my chat wants the furry one.
So I'm gonna pick that one.
Oh my god.
You don't need me.
I'm a caster, okay?
I'm gonna cast against you biasedly.
You're not supposed to be biased!
Yeah, I'm gonna do it, okay?
Stop it.
Stop her.
She's like good cop, bad cop.
I have to let this happen.
Oh, okay, okay.
You're the good cop then.
We're gonna say...
I'm the cop that conquers the drugs and steals them.
Okay.
Wait, Steffi, what's the good cop?
What are you gonna say to us?
Oh, um...
Everybody do your best.
Right?
I want more!
Well...
Everybody do your best.
That's why we're here.
Just doing our best.
We're going!
You're doing great.
Alright, Sarah.
You're fucking going...
I want a good clean match.
Sarah, you're going down.
I came back from a fighting game championship.
I know my fighting moves now.
So you're going down.
Oh my god.
I've heard a lot about your incredible fighting style, Doki.
Yeah.
I'm gonna put Doki in the turkey.
I didn't come up with anything.
I used my A material.
I used my A material on Shinri.
I'm so sorry.
Are we in kindergarten?
What are these insults?
Oh man.
Am I playing the child now?
In the semis?
Who let this child in?
I mean, she does some weird stuff.
I don't know.
Who let the snake in?
Who let the snake in too?
We have two very fierce opponents here.
And it's going after each other.
What the fuck?
Are you also gonna land on Doki and pummel her, Sarah?
I hope so.
I have a track record of one successful landing so far.
So if I can make it to two, I might be the safest fictional airline in this entire competition.
Let's go.
Better than Ryanair already.
Give it up, chat.
For our two amazing contestants.
Let's go!
I'm so excited.
I'm really curious if we're gonna get fired, Snuffy.
How do you think we're gonna do tonight?
Okay, I'm literally right behind you.
I'm giving you the shots.
Why are we kissing?
I don't know!
What do you mean?
Alright, here we go.
The following contest is scheduled for one fall!
Representing Sarah, No one can win.
Another than the biggest, the meanest, the greenest, BULK!
BULK!
Holy Frick!
This guy's insane!
Where'd you find this dude?
An absolute legend.
Is there supposed to be like an intro music?
Should we make it up?
I think there probably is intro music.
Okay, now we can hear it.
There she is.
Bob Logan!
Oh!
She's beautiful.
Looks like she crawled out of a sarcophagus in Egypt.
I mean, this is eccentric to say the least.
You know what?
Looks like she might corrode you.
She's radioactive.
She kinda looks like she's wearing Peter Griffin's outfit.
I'm not gonna lie.
She comes here ready for combat.
Hey, yo!
These chiseled features don't lie.
She looks like she's wearing Peter Griffin's outfit.
She looks like a superhero.
Oh, she's unleashing the beast!
Call her a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle because this radioactive person is transforming the beast!
My god!
She's striking more poses than an effing Naruto hitting the effing fireball jutsu.
I don't know what she's doing.
We definitely gotta pay our camera guy a little bit more money.
Alright, let's go!
Woo woo woo!
Bulk Bogan!
Sir Ra is already putting on a show, ladies and gentlemen.
Business casual, but yet so fierce and wild.
Will we see her perform in the ring today?
Will we see the beast come out?
She's taking a dump.
It's all part of that wild nature.
Ooh, here comes the entrance?
Dang!
A little saucy with it.
It does look like she's fleeing a little bit of a zesty approach.
Ooh!
Oh my god!
We're holding the ropes like we're making sweet love to it.
And she's in.
I mean, this person's an actual fiend.
I'm not gonna lie, I'm a bit worried for Doki right now.
This person seems a little bit unhinged, to say the least.
Yeah, this person is a caged animal ready to be unleashed at any given moment.
We actually have 911 responders in the back with tasers and, uh...
equipment.
I'm getting unnamed equipment just in case it gets too feral.
She's been known to go absolutely hog wild.
Yoki might not make it today.
Speaking about Quip, I think she's looking pretty good in that department.
Let's see how she does!
I don't know, man.
This person's like peak Darwin evolution right now.
Sarah is looking insane.
I think she was bred solely just for her muscle compatibility.
Look how built she is.
Look at this pure primal nature.
She's currently seeking and sensing her prey.
That's true, Blaine.
Introducing her opponent!
Everybody knows the word!
YOKI!
Holy freak!
This man's got the vocal capacity of an whale.
That's insane.
And he is!
Here's our next challenger of the night!
Alright, it's such a pleasure to cast her match.
The King.
We just witnessed an amazing fight by the King.
And now we're about to watch if she will bring it back another time.
But she's versus an opponent who is just as fierce and feral as Doh King himself.
This is going to be quite intense.
I do have a question for you, Snuffy.
Do you think she's going to take off the mask?
I don't...
Oh!
I thought she might have just done it.
A rare mask reveal.
There's only three of them sold on eBay right now.
That's true.
Things were never the same after the dream mask reveal.
So we're going to see if she keeps us on or not.
But she is making her way down the arena right now.
Slamming her head on the metal stairs.
Do you think you're allowed to use that in combat here or not?
I want to see some steel steel gameplay.
There are no rules in wrestling.
This is just pure wild animalistic fighting.
Yeah, you can say that again.
I mean, it's the f'ing Jaguar versus Serp matchup.
I mean, Slytherin or Hufflepuff.
Who's going to win this one?
Wait, Gryffindor?
I'm going to win this one.
I don't know what I'm saying.
Anyway...
I don't know bro.
I didn't watch the book, okay?
So we're going to see how she can do here tonight.
Wait, can we talk to chat?
Can we read our commentators what the fans are saying live?
I'm kind of curious.
Am I breaking the immersion?
Let's find out.
I'm getting worried.
There's a lot of people in the crowd whispering my ears simultaneously at all a very condensed volume.
Watch the book, they say.
Oh, that's a weird quote.
Oh my gosh.
She goes straight up in the suplex.
I mean, the 49ers are about to draft this chick and she's going and grabbing a doge bird.
Throwing her straight into the railing.
Oh my god!
What was that move?
She hit the butt slam with that anime.
She did the peach sidebite.
Oh my god.
Joki is not starting her match very strongly.
She has spent more time on the floor than her feet on the ground.
I mean, she might be a wobble fit.
We'll have to see if she's a weight bloomer in this situation.
Oh, my god!
What is this?
Oh, she's just getting her ass kicked.
The whole body Circus Olade over here.
The spider monkey maneuver didn't work out that well for Sarah.
Now Doki Bird with the reversal.
She might have the upper hand.
Just kidding.
She's getting jokered by the courtes.
This is that kind of animalistic nature I told you about.
Once she's unleashed, there is no going back.
We will have to... Oh my god, Doki!
I mean, we went with the fatality in the first few seconds.
She's breaking her hands.
She's going for the throat.
Rather than take her ability to win this fight, she's ruining her ability to win an Apex game.
Doki is on the run.
She is currently hiding and screaming, begging for life right now.
She is too afraid to sit back in the ring.
She's... Oh, the eagle kick!
The eagle kick of the seventh condor.
Oh my god, I never...
Jesus Christ, she goes for the back of the head slam.
I... What just happened?
Doki just rage quit the game.
I repeat, Doki...
Is the stream paused?
I think the stream is paused, Doki.
But we're live on a five second delay.
I'm sure they're actually killing each other right now.
They are, they are.
Doki had to take this off camera.
This can no longer be broadcasted onto live TV.
We had to go to the backstage cameras right now.
Doki is currently grabbing her by the hair.
Oh, she's getting... Oh my god.
This is truly any man's game.
All the rules are broken.
They're getting back in the ring.
Back in the stadium, I mean, there's high ground versus low ground.
We saw this worked out in Star Wars, but Doki Bird also did see that.
So she is coming back into the arena now.
We are on a five minute round on the ground.
I'm predicting Doki will now turn it around with a 360 kick.
Spin off the rails.
That's probably what's happening.
Oh my god, that's exactly what happened.
And Sarah said Doki right over.
Doki is kicking her in the jaw.
Now she's grabbing her by the toes.
Yeah, she's grabbing her toes and everything.
We're live on television again.
We're live on television.
We are so back in real time.
It looks like she's hitting it with a Muffler 3000.
And Sarah is literally not feeling it this time.
She keeps grabbing her feet.
I'm starting to think there's a little bit... again.
Oh my god.
This might be more.
She's motivated by some odd...
She doesn't even...
Oh my god.
Four kicks.
Imagine how many testicles would have been lost just now.
Has to be in pieces already.
Oh!
She just grabbed her by the left cheek.
And then she just snapped her own neck.
Snapped her own neck.
That was insane.
And Sarah said, not today, bitch.
Oh my... incredible.
Drop kick with the phlegm spray.
I mean, this is getting violent.
I mean, this is just...
There's fluids everywhere at this point.
Fluids all over.
Wait, she's going for the tryout.
Oh my god, she's got her.
This could be it.
It's the first one already.
It's just Kuroi in the match.
There's no way Doki goes down without a fight.
She's kneeling on the back of that.
It takes three!
She's got that jaguar prowl.
Oh my god.
That was like Keiso landing on Jinxy.
I mean, I think she might be dead.
Oh my god.
Sarah's not done yet.
She's about to show us the true nature.
Her anaconda don't want nothing less.
Doki's got a bunch of them.
Oh!
Okay.
I don't think it was a very effective maneuver, but it did look swag-tastic.
I'm not gonna lie.
Maybe we can count on the snake to save Sarah after all.
Is that a spinning back kick?
Oh my god.
Crab Stomper!
Crab Stomper, Doki!
For the content!
She's just letting her get back up.
No, Doki's just toying with her.
Oh my god.
She's the king.
Oh my god!
She's tossing it around like a five-year-old playing with a Barbie doll.
She's just flinging her around.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Jesus Christ!
And the legendary triple suplex!
This might be it, ladies and gentlemen.
I mean, we're getting angles for sure.
Oh!
Sarah can still fight.
Unbelievable.
After being tossed around like a Gmod ragdoll.
We're moving straight out of leg pin land straight into face knee city.
Oh my lord.
I don't think Sarah's got much left in the tank at this point, but Doki Bird misses a knee.
The crotch sniff of five thousand.
I know.
Oh my god!
She's got him in the crab lock!
This is insane!
And now Sarah's turned to gloat.
This has just become an illusion of fighting.
They are just... I think they're all just pure adrenaline at this point.
Whoa!
Out of nowhere!
Doki could not fight back.
Doki taps out!
Taps out!
Just like that!
Here's your winner by tap out!
Representing Sarah...
BALLS!
BALLGUN!
And they have a snake!
Oh my god!
They have a snake!
She's got the fucking snake!
Oh my god!
We get the snake!
No you can't bring the snake on here!
Who said you could bring the snake in here?
Someone get the trink!
This cannot be legal!
We need the staff!
Staff on the stage now!
Staff!
I know Drake was going to be making a guest appearance.
That's crazy!
But dude, I did not expect Doki Bird to tap out in the final moments.
That was a really unexpected ending.
It was any man's game.
They were practically both out of stamina.
It just became just teeth and claw at that point.
I know, I know.
You know, Sarah might have hit it with a snake venom attack.
And it took down her stamina over the course of the fight.
Yeah, she got that Medusa glare and put Doki down.
I don't get the flag for casting a game where Doki got eliminated, but hey, we're back with her right now.
That was a fight!
I can explain.
Tell us about it.
Axel introduced me to this app called VINETS.
And I got a little bit addicted there.
So I might have lost a fight, but end up a millionaire.
So that's fine with me.
Damn.
That's it.
That's really it.
I won't say it was rigged, but I got a hefty amount of cash coming in soon.
Sarah, your response to this?
All I gotta say is, it's like they say in wrestling, sooner or later, everyone taps.
And today it was Doki.
So, sorry.
Got Doki in the chokie and it happened.
Oh yeah.
Not rigged.
Oh god.
I can't believe it actually happened.
Doki in the chokie.
Wait, it actually happened.
Yeah, the finishing move, right?
Yeah.
What's his name?
Can you tell us how you...
Yeah, what's your snake name?
My snake name is Jin.
But I mean, like, okay.
So like, the reason that my wrestle looks the way it is, is because we're like a package deal.
But since there's two of us, we would have got DQ'd.
If we went in together.
So we did a fusion dance and the abomination that is Wolf-Burgen is a mixture of me and my snake.
But then what is left over is the snake in the back.
And the remainder.
I don't know a snake barista could be so buff.
You guys are like the Wonder Twins.
Yes!
That's what they do call us in the streets.
Wait, that's a fish!
That's two people!
I'm one!
This is not fair!
No, you have a tomato in you.
Don't you have a tomato in you?
It's a fucking...
It's a cosmetic!
It's not like I have a second person.
It's like me putting on a fucking hat.
Which I am wearing one too.
So it's like wearing two hats.
I feel like it's like you and your eyebrows.
Like imagine if you didn't have your eyebrows.
Would you be half the Doki you are?
I feel like you would be missing a whole part of yourself.
I just think you know what?
Okay, all right, fine.
The better wrestler won.
I'll admit the better wrestler won.
You were an incredible opponent.
I'm going to take this whole thing out just to prove that you were one of the best.
Yeah, okay.
You got to win the finals then.
If you beat me and you win, that means I'm the winner too.
Because I lost to the winner.
So like technically I'm also the winner.
You're coming with me on this.
I'm taking you along for the ride.
It's okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I know.
Well, I'm...
All right.
Chat.
Doki Bird Watchers.
What is it?
Is it the Bird Watchers?
The Ruffians?
What?
Do you know this amazing fight we just witnessed?
Let's go!
You don't know my fans' names on my own channel?
Thank you to our viewers like you.
Oh!
Which match is next?
Who's up to the chopping block now?
Well, I sure am going to know because I do know.
A clown!
It's...
Oh!
I sure wish I knew what I was doing.
A clown?
And then a...
Hello?
Yeah, that's me.
That's me.
I'm a clown.
Hi!
You better be funny!
Yes, you are.
Oh, I'm not.
Wait, wait, I didn't even introduce any professional, but I don't know who the names are.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay, I got this.
So I actually knew the entire time.
I would just pick truly.
Yeah, take your time.
Okay, so first off, we are going to introduce...
Okay, I just saw four different names, but one of them is definitely Octavio.
So what's up, Octavio?
Hello.
Badly.
Oh, hi, Octavio.
Sick, nasty.
Okay, wait, so which one's which?
I'm so sorry.
Yeah, you got it.
You got it.
Why don't you guess?
Guess, like, pick.
Pick.
Okay, Octavio is a clown or is he a boo man?
Let's see.
You have to pick.
I'm going to guess.
Octavio sounds really effing quirked up.
I'm going to say he's the clown.
Yikes, yikes, yikes, yikes.
On live TV.
Okay.
Mr. Clown, is your name Charlie?
Oh, you're Bunny Chance?
Yeah.
Let's go.
Let's go, dude.
Hey, guys, Charlie here.
Well, Mr. Charlie, how does it feel to fight your co-hi?
Oh, man, it feels good.
It feels good.
It feels good to just... I'm going... I'm just going to wipe the floor with this guy.
He's got to be going, Octavio.
I'm going like, Octavio, oh, no.
Stop it, sexy clown man, for fucking hitting me in the head.
You're done.
Bettle?
I have to say something.
First off, I think you're cool.
Uh -huh.
It's Charlie.
I think you're handsome.
I think you're admirable.
I think you're inspirational.
Uh-huh.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Okay, I want to see some actual violence.
What the frick is this about?
Yeah, you just have to kiss him.
Yeah, like, what is this?
Go kiss at this point, man.
What the hell?
I did a name pun.
I worked like five... I practiced that for like five minutes before I got here.
Yeah, well, I hope you practiced that punch just as much.
You can do those in seconds.
Like, Bettle, well, you... Bettle not tell anybody.
But you're gonna die today.
What the hell?
What is this?
This is biased commentary.
You're supposed to remain neutral.
No, no.
See, it's weird.
It's good cop, bad cop.
Yeah, Philly already dunked on Octavia.
It's my turn now.
Philly called me Charlie.
Yeah, we're tagged even.
Wait, which one am I talking about?
Oh, my God.
Are you kidding me?
Do your research.
What is this?
I'm just kidding.
Okay.
You're just kidding.
Guys, tell me right now, what is your signature move?
What secret technique are you planning on using this match?
I'm gonna show Bettle my blue balls.
That's not on YouTube.
We're on YouTube.
My signature move is the open hand slap.
Dang.
A pimp.
I respect that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
I mean, we'll see who wins.
Balls are slapping.
You're my senpai.
I can't disrespect you right now.
I'm gonna defile your body in the ring.
What?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I think we should.
I'm sensing a lot of tension in this match.
We're good in a match.
I'm gonna go.
This is a strong rivalry.
Okay, Gavis brittle.
Yeah, I'm sensing some energy here.
It might be a little romantic.
I'm not gonna lie.
Well, I can't wait to see how this fight unfolds.
Slay.
All right.
Let's well to span figure 10, real time.
Let's get to it.
Okay.
What on earth?
What are those characters, bro?
They both are making insane expressions upon seeing one another.
I take a look at the two different directions.
The other one.
The other one is our final match for night one!
Introducing first, the Itaewon
That is a freaking wizard.
I know this dude definitely cast fireballs on the weekend.
he comes to the judgment.
What a beautiful eyeliner.
that would have been a beautiful eyeliner.
I really need the name of his makeup artist.
Okay.
He's got a doll.
I know.
I thought we would stop at body pillows, but apparently not.
Oh my god, that might be his sister, dude.
Yeah, it might be.
I bet it stands up on its own.
We'd have to find out.
So let's see what this man's got going on.
I mean, he's like a walking jellyfish.
He's kind of intense.
Oh my god, I can't look at this guy.
I think he might have meant to go to the rave next door, I'm not gonna lie to you.
I don't know if he knows this is wrestling.
This man looks like he paid 90 bucks for a six pack of water.
I mean, this dude's serious business right now.
I mean, does he know where the camera is?
I don't think this guy's looked away a single time.
I think we would all be better off if he would buy less avocado toast.
Dang, you just roasted an entire state.
That's crazy.
All right, he's rolling up.
Let's see.
They don't call him Octavio for nothing.
It kind of sounds like an emperor name.
What is his legacy?
Oh my god.
Yo!
I think they might be like a rock star maybe.
Yeah.
Maybe.
That's what the vibe I'm getting off.
He's a rock artist.
I think he's just an artist.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh my god.
He's casting fire.
Someone in chat wrote Gandalf.
No, no, no, no.
It's Hatsune Miku.
True.
And his opponent, known as Charlie in some circles, has defeated his brother to be here.
It's Bello!
There's somebody with a frog on the stage.
He's already into the arena.
This man works fast as frick.
Oh my god.
Yeah, this guy is all about business.
He might be a clown.
He might be joking and funny and humorous.
But he's all about business here.
He looks like the type of guy to tip a razor blade to his shoe.
I don't trust him for a moment.
I mean this guy is... What's he got under that hat?
That's what I'm afraid of.
Wait, that was the shortest intro in history.
This dude's here for winning money and leaving.
I think that means he's ready to kill.
Yeah.
Alright, well, Bello versus Octavia.
Let's see how this one rolls out.
Why did he swap to an F-ing D-Word dress?
Will we see kissing?
Let's find out.
Oh my god!
We're about to see Tony Hawk pro skater kickflip.
Riding him like a freaking skateboard.
Okay, way to open up the match.
Oh, and he does it again!
I mean this dude's doing more flips than me right now.
Oh my god!
Okay, Octavia's out of the ring!
He just did a Beyblade.
No, wait, Octavia's already getting pinned.
He's gone.
Oh, Bello got tossed.
These guys are strong.
Somebody please get their grandpa back in the retirement home.
I don't think he's meant to be here.
Oh!
And just like that!
Oh my god!
He's back up!
Oh!
The triple backflip!
I hope grandpa didn't bring his dentures.
Bello's here to fight!
Oh my god!
He's flying around the match like a trapeze!
Octavia's dead already?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, he's got more than this.
He's ready to show the world what he told us he was gonna do.
I think Octavia's already running for his life.
He might get knocked off the back rope right now.
My man missed his takedown maneuver and got head pinched into the... what?
He's blinded by the LEDs!
Oh my god!
Oh!
The sheer amount of light reflection that Octavia's outfit is causing right now.
I know, he's blinded by the lights.
We can definitely get him a copyright.
True?
Wait.
The epic head slam!
The whiplash here is probably equivalent to a 60 mile an hour car crash.
We're not doing this going on!
That was the sickest move I have ever seen in all wrestling history.
That was the coolest thing.
That was the coolest thing I have ever witnessed.
Usually when guys do the helicopters by themselves, I mean this one's crazy.
I think we should hire clowns to fight more often because this is just getting sick.
I mean I think I'm watching a yaoi fold in real time, I'm not gonna lie.
Who's the semi and who's the...
This is the Johnny Appleseed.
Whoa!
Whoa my god!
Grandpa!
It's like a folding chair!
Holy shit!
Just kidding!
He's not...
Okay.
Betel is taking Octavio in literally any position he can get him in.
This is insane.
Oh my god!
How many backflips does he need before he's backflipped enough?
I think he's trying to impress you, Phil.
This is insane.
Is it true?
Oh my god!
Octavio's gonna take him from the top!
I'm literally making love on the stage!
I cannot commentate on this right now!
That's half of the backflip and now his lutz are popped!
Oh my god!
Octavio's got him!
He's dealing with the epic door!
What is he doing?
He's showing the whole world his senpai.
He's just doing some damage all the time.
He's just getting fought like a banana.
Insane.
Oh my god!
Poor damage to himself.
Okay.
Oh my god!
They're just jumping off of each other at this point!
They're playing like leapfrog!
Oh right against the...
Oh my god!
This is getting dirty!
This is getting absolutely filthy!
She said not to worry about...
Neither of them look like they want to get back into the ring.
Oh my god!
This is it!
Wait, Snuff, don't forget you cannot pin outside of the arena.
So that means that currently Beto is safe from being eliminated.
Unless he's stunned until ten seconds runs out.
It's almost there!
We've got seven seconds!
Beto doesn't get back in right now.
He's taunting and the other one's taunting!
He nearly timed out and he is taunting!
I'm not even sure if his head is screwed on straight anymore.
I don't think it ever was.
I mean this dude is tenacious.
He's an actual maniac.
I would not want to fight this guy.
Oh my god!
You hit him with the industrial head slicer.
I've seen that on a live place before.
And now I think...
I don't know.
Grandpa is down!
Grandpa got his arm snapped.
I hope he can cast a healing spell!
Oh!
But that won't save him!
Oh he's got him!
He's got him!
There's no way!
It's over!
Beto packed up Octavio in the caramels.
Here is your winner!
Charlie Bitt!
That was an insane fight.
I witnessed more yoga moves there than I have in the entirety of my career in yoga.
I mean that was a simply acrobatic fight.
I saw more skin and body angles than I did in the entire just chatting section of Twitch.
That was insane.
I think that was a true test of wrestling supremacy right there.
That was beautiful.
That was a true art form.
It was.
You couldn't have said it any better.
God damn!
Oh was there any doubt?
A little bit.
Was there any doubt that you were going to win?
Was there any doubt in I, Charlie Gavis Beto?
Octavio.
That was good.
I liked how they danced around the battlefield.
They showed how they'll touch each other's skin.
It's the dude from Konosuba!
That's crazy!
I think we were off the ground more than we were on it in that fight.
Yeah, yeah.
We were like rabbits, pounding each other.
I have never seen so much um...
inspiration.
Athleticism?
Skill?
Yes, passion for the fight.
Yeah, that was a good whole movie.
I'm not going to lie.
I respect it.
Yeah, we're amateurs though.
Alright!
Beto, Beto!
Congratulations on the win!
Was there any doubt in your mind?
No, no.
I don't doubt myself.
I am a man of pure and unbridled confidence.
It's just the way things go.
Do you know what it takes to win this entire tournament?
Yeah, that was an insane showcasing of skill.
I think you have potential.
No he doesn't.
I'm going to beat him.
I've already won!
Anyone can face me!
Consider it done!
Alright viewers, you heard it here.
He's already won.
So let's take it back to backstage Doki coming front stage for our last remaining things to say for today.
No!
Thanks Doki!
Don't fire me!
She wouldn't...
Alright.
Filia would read anything in the Discord chat which I figured out.
Because I literally wrote Charlie versus Octavio.
And she actually read it.
What?
I was like, are those these guys?
Are these guys just...
Are they coming on to help?
I was too afraid to say their names.
I knew his name was Batel but then he said like three other names.
So I was like, are you calling Batel?
Is this like a 40-4?
KeyCast confusion.
Bro, you wrote like...
I wrote like five different names.
Charlie versus Octavio.
Beto versus Octavio.
I didn't know what was going on.
I'm not sure.
I'm just kidding.
I just came here to say thank you to Filian and Snuffy for casting the last two matches.
If you enjoyed the casting, they will be casting more matches tomorrow.
We lost track of time and matches.
So, because of that, I forgot to put them in earlier.
But, do not worry.
They're gonna be casting more tomorrow.
It will be much more balanced.
But yes!
Give a huge shoutout and thank you to our casters, Filian and Snuffy!
Thank you for having me!
I can't wait to see you guys perform this together.
We'll see you guys tomorrow.
And I'm gonna do an outro for the viewers.
And also give a final note on who are the...
What are the matches for tomorrow.
I'll see you guys later, guys.
Swag.
Peace out!
Let's go!
Alright.
I just left a call because I don't know how long they're gonna be there.
Bring them in and bring me back into the...
Bring me back into this.
Like I said, huge thank you to all the casters.
Gerard, Octavio, Mint, Fillion, Snuffy, and then we have Taka filling in for Sayu to do the announcement very last minute.
Literally like 5-10 minutes before our stream was about to start.
Taka filled in.
And we were trying...
He tried very hard to like try to get the feeling of the announcements.
So a huge shout out to Taka.
Another big shout out to my sound guy for doing all the balancing live.
I'm sorry if the balancing needs...
The sound balancing might need a little bit more work.
I'm not sure yet.
Cause I don't know.
I can't rewatch the VOD to see if anything needs balancing.
But yes, a huge shout out to all the cast.
Everybody that participated.
For like 5 hours.
We've been going at it for 5 hours for day 1.
Now some of you guys are wondering what will be on day 2.
Day 2.
We do have some matches that weren't able to be played.
So we're gonna be playing some of those matches.
So let me get out my handy text tool real quick guys.
Alright.
So from here.
Emma.
Emma made it out from here.
So let me put Emma here.
We're doing this live everybody.
Emma will be here.
They made... Oh my gosh.
White text is not it.
Here we go.
Sorry.
This is um...
A little scuffed here.
Emma made it to the finals for day 2.
We also have for tomorrow.
We will have Fuyo vs.
Snuffy and Nana vs.
whoever.
Who wins that second bracket.
So let me copy and paste real quick.
Put that here.
As Nana has defeated Gerard.
We'll fix it in post.
It's a live experience.
You know this is not pre-recorded.
So from here this will be bracket 1.
These are the matches that we are gonna have.
We're gonna have Fuyo vs.
Snuffy tomorrow.
And then...
And then we'll have Nana vs.
whoever wins that match up.
And then Emma right here.
Um... the second bracket.
Okay.
Where's my other image?
Guys this is why... This is my first time organizing this guys.
I haven't never organized a wrestling event before on Doki Bird.
So please be nice.
So second match up will be um...
Anon vs.
whoever wins the Luto vs.
Sayu match up.
So we have figuring that out.
And I'll be here.
We're gonna figure out who is going to win in the Luto vs.
Sayu.
And then we have Fillion in the finals.
Um... cause she beat up a child and then another child too.
So...
Fillion will be in the finals.
And then finally in bracket...
3!
Bracket 3.
We will have...
Sarah making it to the finals.
And...
Beto vs.
Sarah.
Well actually no.
Sorry.
JK I forgot.
If you think it's gonna be Beto vs.
Sarah It'll actually be...
We will be mixing up the match ups and we'll spin a wheel on who's gonna fight who.
For the final matches.
So those who made it all the way to the finals here with Sarah and Beto.
We're gonna be mixing it up again.
So they're not gonna be fighting each other.
We're gonna be mixing up the match ups for the final finals.
And that will be day 2.
And finally the show matches.
For our show matches.
We will have...
Shy Lily, Lucy, Meriwether, and Buff Puff for a 2-0.
2v2.
Tornado tag team.
As our show match for tomorrow.
So two dogs versus...
not dogs.
I don't know.
What do I describe the other?
What would they be called?
Guys.
Tomorrow our show match will be a tag team.
Dogs vs.
not dogs.
I don't know what the group would be.
What would you call the group?
Of Shy Lily and Lucy.
But yes.
Like I said.
Huge shout out to everybody for being here.
And Juna.
Huge shout out to Juna for being the interviewer.
And stayed out throughout the whole day.
I think she passed out right after.
Huge shout out to Juna.
For being here.
And doing the interview process with everybody.
And I'm very excited for day 2.
I hope you guys have enjoyed the matches so far.
And I know it's a little bit scuffed.
I am a one man team.
It is a bit scuffed.
But I hope you guys still had lots of fun.
As you know there is this wrestling belt has been revealed.
This will be our official wrestling belt.
That will be sent to the winners.
Of both the show matches.
And the tournament.
And I'm super excited to see who is going to win this belt.
Thank you everybody.
I hope you enjoyed day 1.
It has been a long day.
5 hours.
But it's honestly been amazing.
It's been an amazing experience.
And I hope my staff team enjoyed themselves a lot.
Casting and announcing and just having a great time with everybody.
And I hope you fans enjoyed it too.
As always everybody stay hydrated.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys for day 2 everyone.
Day 2.
Bye bye guys.
Bye.